SENATORS HERE TO SENATE
EDUCATION SO THAT WE CAN GET
STARTED STEVE GLAZER EXCELLENT
TIMING.
ALRIGHT WE'LL GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE WELCOME TO THIS
MORNING'S HEARING OF SENATE
EDUCATION WE HAVE NINETEEN BILLS
ON THE AGENDA THIS MORNING WE'VE
SEVEN ITEMS ON CONSENT.
ITEM SIXTEEN AB SIXTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN HAS BEEN PULLED BY
THE AUTHOR.
WE WILL HAVE TO WITNESSES TWO
MINUTES EACH GOING FORWARD AND
SINCE WE DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM WE
WILL START AS A SUB COMMITTEE.
AND I BELIEVE OUR FIRST AUTHOR
HERE IS -- ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY SHE HAS ITEM NUMBER
TWO AB.
THREE TWENTY FOUR BEGIN WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY [inaudible]
RATE.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB THREE TWENTY FOUR
REQUIRES THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. TO
DEVELOP STANDARDIZED EFFECTIVE
IMMEASURABLE GUIDELINES FOR THE
USE OF CURRENT A. B. TWO ONE TWO
FUNDS.
AB TWO ONE TWO WAS A BILL BY
DEREK D. DION RIN -- ADOPTED IN
TWO THOUSAND THAT SET ASIDE
ANNUAL FUNDING TO IMPROVE THE
RETENTION OF CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS.
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET BILL
INCORPORATES THESE GUIDELINES
FOR THE NEW A HUNDRED NINETY
FIVE MILLION EARLY LEARNING AND
CARE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
GRANTS PROGRAM.
HOWEVER EXISTING AB TWO ONE TWO
FUNDS ARE NOT HELD TO THE SAME
STANDARDS.
EVEN THOUGH THE TWO FUNDS HAVE
THE SAME PURPOSE.
AB THREE TWENTY FOUR WAS SIMPLY
LINK THESE EXISTING AB TWO ONE
TWO FUNDS TO THE SAME GUIDELINES
OUTLINED IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET.
BUDGET BILLS HIS ME WE WILL BE
CROSSING AMENDMENTS TO THAT DO
EXACTLY THAT IN THE NEXT
COMMITTEE I ASK FOR YUR AYE
VOTE.
WITH ME TODAY IS AIRING GABLE ON
BEHALF OF FIRST FIVE CALIFORNIA
THANK THANK YOU ASSEMBLY WOMAN
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AARON
GABLE ON BEHALF OF FIRST FIVE
CALIFORNIA EARLY CHILDHOOD
COMMISSION.
AND I WE'RE HERE IN SUPPORT OF
AB THREE TO FOUR AS WE DISCUSSED
MANY TIMES IN THIS COMMITTEE THE
HEART OF EVERY CLASSROOM WHETHER
IT'S A LIVING ROOM FLOOR OR
TRADITIONAL CLASSROOM IS THE
TEACHER.
WITH 90% OF BRAIN DEVELOPMENT
HAPPENING BEFORE THE AGE OF FIVE
THE HOME AND CHILD CARE LEARNING
ENVIRONMENTS ARE KEY TO EVERY
CHILD'S FUTURE.
CHILD CARE TEACHERS ARE AMONG
THE LOWEST PAID PROFESSIONS IN
THE NATION WITH EVER INCREASING
STANDARDS OF PRACTICE IN ORDER
TO IMPACT CHILD DEVELOPMENT AND
LONG LIFE LONG OUTCOMES.
AB -- TWO TWELVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AARON OR WAS
PASSED ALMOST TWENTY YEARS AGO
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE GREAT
EXPENSE OF ONGOING EDUCATION AND
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT FOR
CHILD CARE TEACHERS.
DID NOT COME OUT OF THE
TEACHERS' POCKETS AND TO ADDRESS
THE HIGH TURNOVER RATES DUE TO A
LACK OF COMPENSATION.
AFTER TWENTY YEARS THE STATE
WIDE STAKEHOLDER GROUP INCLUDING
OUR PRESCHOOL TEACHERS AND THE
FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
HAS RECOMMENDED BETTER STANDARDS
FOR THE TEACHERS TYPE AND
PROGRAM WHICH ARE CONTAINED IN
AB.
THREE TO FOUR THE STANDARDS ARE
BASED ON THE BEST PRACTICES
BEING EMPLOYED IN THE FIELD
TODAY AND WILL ALIGN WITH OUR
QUALITY COUNTS CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
INFRASTRUCTURE AT THE STATE AND
LOCAL LEVELS.
AND FINALLY WILL ALSO ALIGNED
WITH THE ONE HUNDRED NINETY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN WORK FORCE
FUNDS THAT WERE JUST APPROVED IN
THE FINAL BUDGET.
AB THREE TO FOUR WILL LEVERAGE
THE EXISTING TEACHERS TYPE IN
PROGRAM WITH HIGHER STANDARDS
AND TO EXPAND THE PROGRAM'S
AVAILABILITY TO ALL TEACHER
TYPES SO THE CHILDREN IN OUR
EARLY LEARNING SYSTEM CAN
BENEFIT FROM A SUPPORTED TEACHER
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT --
GERMAN MEMBERS TIM FITTERS FOR
CHILD THREE SIXTY LOS ANGELES IN
STRONG SUPPORT [inaudible]
Q..
BUT CAN THE CHRISTIANS IN ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
HOUSE SITTING AT A MEAT IS NOT
TO NOW WITH CHILDREN NOW IN
SUPPORT.
MONEY GRAMS SOME HAVE A FIRST
FIVE LA IN SUPPORT.
NORMALLY DILLMAN SAN MATTEO
COUNTY CHILDCARE PARTNERSHIP
COUNCIL IN STRONG SUPPORT.
SUSIE AROUND CHILD CARE PLANNING-COUNCIL OF CINEMA COUNTY IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
IRVING ALVAREZ OF YOU'VE JUST
COALITION BROTHERS SONS ITSELF
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT. THIRTY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE BEFORE
WE BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE I THINK WE HAVE A
QUORUM MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL LEYVA HERE LEAVING
HERE WELL.
CHIANG TO WRESTLE.
WITH SO HERE GLAZER GLAZER HERE
MCGUIRE PAN PAN HERE.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT BUT NOW WE
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL.
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE HIGHER SIMPLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE FOR THE
CHILDREN OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIMILAR
MEMBER.
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR PAM AM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ITEM TWO EIGHTY
THREE TWENTY FOR THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO HUMAN SERVICES LEYVA
AYE LEYVA AYE WILK AYE WILK AYE
CHIANG LU ASAL.
LUNA SO I GLAZERS GLAZER AYE
MCGUIRE PAN PAN AYE.
THE BILL HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO GET
OUT BUT WE'LL LEAVE IT ON CALL
FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS SO MUCH
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT AND WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA.
AB.
THREE THREE ONE BEGIN WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TODAY I PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL.
THREE THIRTY ONE AB THREE THIRTY
ONE WILL REQUIRE A SEMESTER LONG
COURSE OF ETHNIC STUDIES TO BE A
HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION
REQUIREMENTS.
BEGINNING IN THE SCHOOL YEAR.
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS SUGGESTED
IN THE IN THE HOUSES.
THAT WILL CLARIFY THE CHARTER
SCHOOLS MAY ALSO REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL LOCAL GRADUATION
REQUIREMENTS.
JUST AS SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
AUTHORIZED TO DO.
I VERY MUCH AGREE WITH THE LAST --
PRESENTER.
WHO SAID THAT IN EDUCATION?
TEACHER.
IS PARAMOUNT TO STUDENT LEARNING.
AND I WOULD ALSO ADD THAT WHAT
IS TAUGHT.
IS ALSO IMPORTANT IN STUDENT
LEARNING.
SO AS A TEACHER. FOR THIRTY FOUR
YEARS [inaudible]
RIVERSIDE UNIFIED.
AN AN ETHNIC STUDIES TEACHER IN
THE CHICANO STUDIES TEACHER.
I SAW THE POWER.
OF CURRICULUM.
WHEN STUDENTS SEE THEMSELVES
RIFAT REFLECTED IN THAT
CURRICULUM?
IF THEY SEE.
THEMSELVES IN EDUCATION.
AND SEE THE HISTORY.
AND THE CULTURE WHERE THEY COME
FROM.
TAUGHT [inaudible]
AND VALUED.
BY EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS THEY
PROSPER [inaudible]
THEY BLOSSOM.
IN THAT EDUCATION BECOMES
EMPOWERING.
AND THEY BECOME.
SOMEWHAT MASTERS OF THEIR OWN
DESTINY AND WE HAVE SEEN THE
TESTIMONY.
HERE.
IN THE CAPITAL IN DIFFERENT
COMMITTEES FROM STUDENTS WHO
JUST DONE JUST THAT.
STUDENTS WHO WENT ON TO GET
DEGREES THEN AT THINK STUDIES.
BECAUSE ETHNIC STUDIES HAS BEEN
A IN EXISTENCE FOR FIFTY YEARS.
ETHNIC STUDIES GREW OUT OF THE
STUDENT MOVEMENT THIRD WORLD
STUDENTS AT SAN FRANCISCO STATE.
IN.
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE BUTSTILL.
IF WE GO TO CLASSROOMS TODAY.
PUTTING THE HIGH SCHOOL WHERE I
TAUGHT POLY HIGH SCHOOL.
DICK UP A US HISTORY BOOK.
WE WILL SEE JUST A FEW PAGES.
PERHAPS ON SAYS OUR JOBS.
PERHAPS ON MARTIN LUTHER KING.
BUT I I PROVIDE AYE AYE I WOULD
SAY.
THAT SAYS OUR CHAVEZ AND MARTIN
LUTHER KING.
AS IMPORTANT AS THEY ARE IN OUR
NATION'S HISTORY.
IS NOT THE EXTENT.
OF AFRICAN AMERICAN.
OR CHICANO HISTORY.
OR THAT IF WE LOOK ONLY AT ELLIS
ISLAND.
WHEN WE LOOK AT IMMIGRATION? TO
THE EXCLUSION [inaudible]
ANGEL ISLAND.
WE'RE NOT TEACHING THE STUDENTS
THE HISTORY OF THIS NATION.
OR IF WE DO NOT TEACH.
ABOUT WHAT THE GOVERNOR.
OF OUR STATE A CALIFORNIA.
LAST WEEK SAID WAS THE GENOCIDE.
THE NATIVE AMERICANS IN
CALIFORNIA HISTORY WE ARE NOT
TEACHING THE FULL HISTORY.
OF THE STATE OR THIS NATION.
SO WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY. TO
TAKE THE THE RICH.
HISTORY AND CULTURE [inaudible]
KNOWLEDGE.
THE BEEN DEVELOPED [inaudible]
BY ACADEMICS.
BY SCHOLARS IN THE LAST FIFTY
YEARS AND INCLUDED.
IN THE CURRICULUM.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
OFFER THAT TO THE STUDENTS OF
OUR STATE.
AND I AM PROUD THAT WE HAVE WITH
THIS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LUIS ALEJO.
WHO FIRST INTRODUCED THE BILL TO
CREATE THAT CURRICULA?
SO I I PROPOSE IT IS BEYOND TIME.
BUT THIS HISTORY BE INCLUDED.
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB.
THREE THIRTY ONE WITH ME TODAY.
IS JOSE LARA TEACHER LOS ANGELES
AND COORDINATOR OF THE ETHNIC
STUDIES NOW COALITION.
AND DOCTOR DALE ALLENDER
PROFESSOR OF EDUCATION AT
SACRAMENTO STATE UNIVERSITY.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER WELCOME
TO YOU EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
PART THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M
VERY POSITIVE YOU TODAY -- I
WOULD LOT OF DIFFERENT HATS ON
THE CORE NEED FOR THAT THINK
THAT HE'S NOT COALITION ALSO THE
BOARD PRESIDENT OF THE EL RANCHO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT -- WHERE
WE HAVE AN ETHNIC STUDIES
REQUIREMENT FOR ALL OUR STUDENTS
IN OUR DISTRICT AND IT'S
PRODUCED HIRE GRADUATES RESULT
IN OUR DISTRICT IT'S TO PRODUCE
MORE POWER MORE DIVERSE -- THE
THINKING STUDENTS IN OUR
DISTRICT -- I'M ALSO EDUCATED
WITH POLITICS STUDIES TO HELP
EMPOWER STUDENTS ESPECIALLY
DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS WHO OFTEN
DON'T SEE THEMSELVES.
IN THE CURRICULUM -- SOMETIMES
FEEL DISEMPOWERED THINK THAT
THEY'RE NOT GOOD ENOUGH TO BE
ABLE TO GO TO CLLEGE I THINK
THAT THEY'RE NOT -- ABLE TO
ACCESS HIGHER EDUCATION AND I'VE
SEEN HOW TELLING THEIR STORIES
I'M MAKING PART OF THE
CURRICULUM CHANGES THE FRAME OF
REFERENCE.
BUT THIS IS NOT MY PERSONAL
EXPERIENCES ALSO ACT ACTUALLY
ACADEMIC STUDIES THE TWO
THOUSAND TEN THIRTY BY THE NEA
COMPILED.
THE EIGHTEEN DIFFERENT STUDIES
FROM ACROSS THE NATION.
EVERY SINGLE STUDY SHOWED BOTH
AS SOCIAL AND ACADEMIC BENEFITS
FOR ETHNIC STUDIES -- A STUDY
DONE BY STANFORD.
OF THE SAN FRANCISCO UNIFIED
ETHICS THESE PROGRAMS SHOWED
THAT STUDENTS WHO TOOK ETHNIC
STUDIES INCREASED YOUR
ATTENDANCE RATES BY 20%.
GPA BY ONE POINT FOUR PERCENTAGE
POINTS AND TWENTY THREE
ADDITIONAL CREDITS.
IT IS AMAZING THE POWER OF
ETHNIC STUDIES DONE THAT COULD
CAN AND AND AND DOES.
TOO BUT ONE OF THE MOST POWERFUL
THINGS IN ONE OF MY FORMER
STUDENTS QUEEN ROBINSON.
RAISED BY HER GRANDMOTHER IN A
SHABBY APARTMENT THAT IS RIGHT
DOWN THE STREET FROM -- DOUBT
RIGHT -- DOWNSTREAM SKID ROW IN
SOUTH LOS ANGELES.
I ALWAYS REMEMBER WORDS WHEN
ASKED WHY HE WAS AT THE
EXPERTISE WILL POURING WHY DID
SHE FEEL WHY HOW DID THE CLASS
TRANSFORMER.
HE SAID MR LARA.
AFTER TAKING ETHNIC STUDIES.
I HAVE A LOT MORE PEPPER MY STEP.
I STAND A LITTLE TALLER.
I FEEL THAT MY LIFE MATTERS NOW
[inaudible]
QUEEN ROBINSON.
FIRST GENERATION OR FAMILY TO GO
TO CASTERLY SHE'S IN A FORTY
YEAR STUDY MUSIC RIGHT NOW.
I CASTELLI ABSOLUTELY AMAZING.
I KNOW THE POWER OF ETHNIC
STUDIES I SEAT MYSELF INSIDE OF
THE CLASSROOM AND IT'S NO TIME
MORE POR PER CALIFORNIA TO LEAD
ON THIS ISSUE.
IN A TIME WHEN WE SEIZE CHILDREN
MIGRANT CHILDREN IN CAGES.
ALONG THE BORDER CITY SIGNALS TO
OUR STUDENTS THAT MAYBE THEY'RE
LIVES DON'T MATTER.
AND WHEN WE LOOK IN THE
CURRICULUM ARE THERE REFLECTED
IN THAT CURRICULUM.
AS A BOARD MEMBER ALSO SEE THE
PRACTICALITY OF THIS HOW IS THIS
GOING TO BE IMPLEMENTED IN OUR
SCHOOL SITES WOULD BE ABLE TO DO
SUCCESSFULLY NOW RANCHO UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
I'VE SEEN UNFOLD AND EXPANDED
LOS ANGELES I'VE SEEN THE WAY
SAN FRANCISCO UNIFIED IS DOING
IT I CURRENTLY WORK IN ANAHEIM
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT I'M A
UNION HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT WERE
ALSO LOOKING AT IMPLEMENTING
ETHNIC STUDIES.
DISTRICTS ACROSS THE ACROSS THE
GLOBE CROSSES THE ARE LOOKING AT
MAKING THIS.
A PROGRAM INSIDE EDITION BUT
THEY NEED SUPPORT THEY NEED HELP.
CURRENTLY THE INSTRUCTIONAL
QUALITY COMMISSION IS CREATING A
MODEL ETHNIC STUDIES CURRICULUM
THE HOPEFULLY WILL BE
IMPLEMENTED AND THIS BILL WILL
HELP EXPAND ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THE CHILDREN OF THE STATE NEED
ETHNIC STUDIES IMPROVER
GRADUATION RATES CLOSED
ACHIEVEMENT GAP AND THE REALITY
IS IS THAT CALIFORNIA LEADS IN A
MULTICULTURAL SOCIETY THAT'S THE
FUTURE OF AMERICA.
WE NEED AT LEAST THAT IS NOW
MORE MORE DESPERATELY THAN EVER --
SENATORS PLEASE -- VOTE YES ON
ETHNIC STUDIES NOW THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY SO
THE RULES ARE FOUR MINUTES AND I
THINK WE'RE PROBABLY WAY OVER
BUT I KNOW YOU'VE TRAVELED SO IN
THE CHAIR IS NOT HERE SO I'M
GONNA GO ROGUE I'M GONNA ALLOW
YOU.
TO ALLOW YOU TO PRESENT.
SO SERVER FOR C..
THAT.
WAS THE I'LL MAKE MY COMMENTS
BRIEF FIRST THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME HERE AT TO MAKE THESE
COMMENTS.
I'M A PROFESSOR IN THE COLLEGE
OF EDUCATION AT SAC STATE
UNIVERSITY ALSO INVOLVED IN THE
ETHNIC STUDIES NOT COALITION
HERE IN SACRAMENTO -- WHEN I'VE
TESTIFIED FOR THIS -- ENDEAVOR
PREVIOUSLY WE HAD DATA FROM TO
SIGN WE HAD DATA FROM -- SAN
FRANCISCO UNIFIED NOW WE HAVE
DATA IN OUR LOCAL REGION AND I
JUST WANT TO POINT OUT THAT.
STUDENTS WHO HAVE TAKEN THIS
CLASS SOME. 310095298% REPORT
AGREE OR TRONGLY AGREED WITH
STATEMENTS SUCH AS I KNOW MORE
ABOUT MY HISTORY I KNOW MORE
ABOUT MY CLASSMATES HISTORY I
KNOW MORE ABOUT THE HISTORY OF
MY COMMUNITY.
FURTHER I AM INTERESTED IN
KNOWING MORE HISTORY ABOUT MY
COMMUNITY AND FINALLY I
UNDERSTAND THAT SOCIAL JUSTICE
CONCERNS IN MY DISTRICT OR MY
COMMUNITY ARE MY RESPONSIBILITY
TO ADDRESS.
IN WEST SACRAMENTO WE HAVE
STUDENTS SAYING THAT AFTER
TAKING THIS CLASS THEY HAVE A
MUCH MUCH STRONGER SENSE OF
BELONGING THIS.
THAN EVER BEFORE AND I BELIEVE
THAT THAT SENSE OF BELONGING
THIS IS PART OF WHAT HELPS --
SEE THE ACADEMIC AND SOCIAL
VALUE EXPAND BEYOND THE ETHNIC
STUDIES COURSE INTO OTHER
SUBJECT MATTER AS WELL I WANT TO
END WITH A QUOTE FROM A STUDENT
FROM WEST SACK SHE SAID THAT.
AFTER TAKING THIS COURSE I HAVE
SUCH A DEEP CONNECTION WITH
OTHER STUDENTS THAT I HAVEN'T
HAD BEFORE THERE'S MUCH MORE TO
SAY ABOUT THE SENATOR'S BUT I'LL
STOP THERE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I
URGE YOU TO VOTE YES ON A. B..
THREE THIRTY ONE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY I DON'T KNOW YOU
JUST DROVE ACROSS TOWN TO BE.
PASSED OUT SIR BUT I WAS GOING
TO SAY THAT YOU KIND OF GET IN
THE SYSTEM MONEY THAT BUT THAT'S
OKAY SO THAT THAT WAS THERE IS
ACTUALLY OUT OF THE LEVEL
TRAFFIC IT TAKES TO GET FROM.
SIXTY TWO TAKE THAT IT WAS CITY
COUNCIL RIVER NOT ABOUT THAT SO
RIGHT NOW WILL GO TO OUR ARE.
THOSE THAT WANT TO ADD ON SO
NAME ORGANIZATION IN WITH YOU
SUPPORT THE BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NICK ROMAN ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BENNY RODRIGUEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
EDUCATION TRUST WESTERN STRONG
SUPPORT THANKS.
MARTHA'S THEIR AGO SIDIOUS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR BILINGUAL
EDUCATION AND SUPPORT.
THE CITY THAT I MEAN IT'S NOT
GONNA LET CHILDREN NOW STRONG
SUPPORT.
KATHY HALL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PTA IN SUPPORT -- TIFFANY
TRAN ON BEHALF OF C. RACK IN
SUPPORT -- BUT I ALSO WANT TO
SAVE IT -- I BELIEVE THE ETHICS
REYES AND IS AN IMPORTANT COURSE
BECAUSE SO MANY STUDENTS WHO
BENEFIT FROM KNOWLEDGE OF THE
HISTORY ISSUES AND SUCCESSES OF
THE COMMUNITY.
AS A HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT I
ATTENDED TO OVERNIGHT WHOSE
PROGRAM EVENTS ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU.
I'M NOT REALLY NICE GUY JUST
PLAY WHEN IT THE DIET SO.
I AM KAYLYNN KIPLING MOJADDIDI
WITH THE COUNCIL ON AMERICAN
ISLAMIC RELATIONS CALIFORNIA AND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
WELL DONE.
I'M RHONDA AREAS KRAVITZ AN I AM
A LOOK AT THE END TO AN
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS GROUP AND WE
STRONG SUPPORT THIS GROUP.
A MARLIN JONES I'M IN THE
DIVISION OF CRIMINAL JUSTICE AT
SACRAMENTO STATE AND I AM IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KENNETH RODRIGUEZ CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION A STRONG
SUPPORT.
JESSICA LAWLESS CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION STRONG
SUPPORT.
JESSICA WILSON SACRAMENTO STATE
GRADUATE IN SUPPORT. ONE
LEGISLATORS HORRIBLE TOOK A
JUNIOR TRUSTEE FOR THE OQO
SCHOOL DISTRICT SCHOOL BOARD AND
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MILES WATKINS RECENT GRADUATE
CAL STATE EAST BAY I'LL BE
ATTENDING SAN DIEGO STATE THIS
UNIVERSE SENEGAL STATE THIS FALL
FOR MY MASTERS IN PUBLIC
ADMINISTRATION AND THE BLACK
STUDENT LEADER CAUCUS OF THE CSU
STANDS A STRONG SUPPORT.
BRING THANK YOU.
PROFESSOR KENNETH MONTERO FORMER
DEAN OF THE FIRST AND ONLY
COLLEGE WRESTLING STUDIES ALSO
LEAD OFFICER FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY ETHNIC STUDIES
FACULTY COUNCIL.
STRONG SUPPORT.
MARK THE SQUAD ASSOCIATE
PROFESSOR INTO GONNA CHICANO
STUDIES AT CAL STATE NORTHRIDGE
AND IN STRONG SUPPORT.
CLOSE YOUR RIVERA ON BEHALF OF
REVOLUTIONARY SCHOLARS AT
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
NORTHRIDGE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
DAVID SELBY DEPARTMENT OF
POLITICAL SCIENCE ISSUE
SACRAMENTO AND CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION CAPITAL H.
CAPITAL CHAPTER POLITICAL ACTION
COORDINATOR AND LEGISLATION
SHARE STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ERICA ROMERO BEHALF THE HISPANIC
ASSOCIATION OF COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
CHRIS FOR SIDES OF THE CHAIR OF
THE CALL THIS REMAINING RIGHTS
INSTRUCTS SUPPORT.
WICHITA AS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
JUNE NETWORK IN SUPPORT.
LANA SANCHEZ TEACHER IN
SACRAMENTO CITY AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
ACTUALLY WALKER ON BEHALF OF THE
MODERATE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
I REMEMBER A LESS ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION A SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL AND SUPPORT.
MARGOT RENALDO STUDENT AT
SACRAMENTO STATE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
ELSA MINUS POLITICAL SCIENCE
STUDENT AT SACRAMENTO STATE IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
DON STOP FOR HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER
IN WEST SACRAMENTO STRONG
SUPPORT.
MARIO GUERRERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
AND ALSO DODGIN FACULTY AT
SACRAMENTO STATE AND SUPPORT.
ALL THE LA -- STUDENT AT
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
STANISLAUS PRESIDENT OF YOUTH --
INDIGENOUS STUDENTS AND ACTIVISM
CLUB AND STRONG SUPPORT Q..
A DIM SUM MCFADDEN OF FROM
STANISLAUS STATE UNIVERSITY AND
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
IF YOU COULD BASS SIERRA MODESTO
JUNIOR COLLEGE MAJORING IN
PSYCHOLOGY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
DEBORAH WATKINS FOUNDER AND
PRESIDENT EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
A BLACK EDUCATION NETWORK AND I
DID DRIVE TO THEY HAVE HOURS TO
GET HERE.
BUT I'M HERE FOR THE I'LL BE
TESTIFYING BEFORE THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON THIRDLY COMMITTEE
TO IN THE SCHOOL TO PRISON
PIPELINE.
IN IN SHORTLY AND SO I WAS LIKE
OH LET ME GET OVER HERE AND
TESTIFY -- IN SUPPORT OF THIS.
THIS BILL AS A VETERAN TEACHER
OF FORTY TWO YEARS -- THE
SOLUTION TO ONE OF THE SOLUTIONS
THE ENDING THE SCHOOL TO THE
GOOD FOR THE PIPELINE.
IS TO ADOPT ETHNIC STUDIES ARM
ACROSS THE STATE.
AND I STRONGLY RECOMMEND THAT.
RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH BUT GIVE
ME A FULL TWO MINUTES OVER THERE.
DO YOU KNOW WHERE FULL ON MIDDLE
SCHOOL TEACHERS STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
JENNIFER MCAFEE MIDDLE SCHOOL
TEACHER IN THE LA.
LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS ALSO NIKKI.
PLEASE ADDRESS OUR METERS
STUDENTS CSU STANISLAUS DOUBLE
MAJORING IN ETHNIC STUDIES AND
POLITICAL SCIENCE CULTURE OF
MATCHA I AND MY TO CHAPTERS THAN
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
NEARLY WORLD ETHNIC STUDIES
PROFESSOR CSU STANISLAUS AND ON
BEHALF OF THE ENTIRE ETHNIC
STUDIES DEPARTMENT AT STANSTED
EIGHT IN STRONG SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND STRONG FACULTY OF SOCIOLOGY
GERONTOLOGY GENDER STUDIES AND
ON BEHALF OF THAT DEPARTMENT
STRONG SUPPORT CSU STENCILS LIKE
YOU.
THANK YOU THEY'VE CALLED LIKE
PRACTICING IN POLITICAL SCIENCE
AND PUBLIC ADMINISTRATION AND
CAL STATE STAND FALL IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK.
MISC UP HERE SEND TWENTY ONE
YEAR VETERAN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
TEACHER STRONG SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THE QUEUE.
WHEN OUR GERBER THIRD GRADE
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL TEACHER AND
MOM OF A HIGH SCHOOLER STRONG
SUPPORT?
STEPHEN FILLING PROFESSOR OF
ACCOUNTING AND ETHICS IT CSU
STANISLAUS SUPPORT.
PRESTON RUDY A PROFESSOR OF
SOCIOLOGY AT SAN JOSE STATE IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
ARMED WITH SOME ATTACK ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNI LEAGUE OF
UNITED LATIN AMERICAN CITIZENS
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
YEAH NOW THAT RIGHT ON BEHALF OF
THE STUDENTS OF TO MORROW OLD
BLACK INDIGENOUS LET THE NEXT.
MY CURRENT -- FOR QUALITY
EDUCATION I AM AN ALUMNI FROM
THE COLLEGE OF ETHNIC STUDIES AT
SF STATE AND IF THIS BILL
DOESN'T PASS.
IT WOULD BE A WASTE OF WHAT I'VE
BEEN GOING TO SCHOOL FOR PLEASE
LET'S PASS THAT NEXT THIRTIES
LISTA WHITEWASHING HISTORY
UNLESS GIVE OUR STUDENTS THE
CALL EDUCATION THAT THEY DESERVE.
OFTEN WESTERN BEHALF THE ANAHEIM
UNION HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DAVE SPEAK THE FATHER OF THREE
BEAUTIFUL WOMEN OF COLOR AND A
FORMER TRUSTEE ON THE CLAIM A
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
WITH ALL OUR HEART IN OUR SPIRIT
WEAR HERE ON BEHALF OF ETHNIC
STUDIES THAT WOULD THINK
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
AND ALSO AS THE FORMER COAL
CHAIR OF THE INDIGENOUS CAUCUS
OF THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION FOR
CHICANO CHICANA STUDIES.
PLEASE PASS AB THREE THIRTY ONE
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK.
GLORIA PARTITA AND ON BEHALF OF
THE DAVIS PHOENIX COALITION
WHICH IS A NONPROFIT THAT FIGHTS
FOR DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION.
AND CREATING INCLUSIVE DAVIS
SCHOOLS I HOUSE AND GIVING MY
STRONG SUPPORT.
THERE ARE MANY OTHER VEHICLE US
SECOND GRADE TEACHER AT THE
SPANISH IMMERSION IS COOL IN US
AND IN THIS FUNNY VERSION IS
BECAUSE HIS RETIREMENT.
IN DAVIS I MEAN YOU KNOW HOW I
AM ADVOCATING FORD IN THE CASE
STUDIES.
THANK YOU.
A GOOD MORNING ONE OF THE S.
ISRAEL WE ARE WITH ME BY A
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION ARE
SALINAS.
ALSO REPRESENTING THE LINES OF
BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR AND
CALIFORNIA LINE FOR YOU THANK
COMMUNITY JUSTICE INSTRUCTABLE.
JAMES MARTINEZ WITH ME BON IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
KOBE DOES IT -- VICE PRESIDENT
OF THE WASHINGTON UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT -- MUST SACRAMENTO
INSTRUCTS PORT.
GOOD MORNING SEVEN BRAMBLE HERE
ON BEHALF OF MORE THAN TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND EDUCATORS
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THE MORNING ALEXANDER CONTENT AS
A GRADUATE STUDENT UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
YOU.
IRVING OUR AS YOU A YOUTH
JUSTICE COALITION BROTHERS ON
THE SOUTH COALITION -- YOU PUT
CHARTER.
TO IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
YOU.
ERICA HOW OFTEN WE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION WE DO HAVE A
SUPPORTIVE AMENDED ON THE BILL
AND THAT IS FOR FISCAL ISSUES ON
IT BUT WE ARE SUPPORTIVE.
OF WHAT THE AUTHOR IS GOING FOR
WE GREATLY APPRECIATE THE WORK
IN THE CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD
THIS YEAR SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
RIGHT THANK YOU FOR THAT.
I'VE JUST BEEN TAX IT I NEED TO
GO TO THE STANLEY TO PRESENT A
BILL SO YOU'RE GOING ON THEY PUT
YOU IN EVEN BETTER HANDS BECAUSE
IN THE PAST -- GAVEL TO MY
COLLEAGUE SENATOR GLAZER WHO
WILL DO AN EXCELLENT JOB.
THERE WAS NO WARNING OR TRAINING.
SO YOU KNOW.
OKAY.
ALRIGHT SO THAT WAS WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AND I THINK -- AS OUR
PROCEDURES PROVIDE WE WOULD LIKE
TO INVITE UP ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ANYONE HERE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK
AGAINST THE BILL.
ALL RIGHT SEE NINE WILL CLOSE
THAT PART OF OUR PROCEDURE AND
WILL.
OPEN IT UP FOR QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS FROM COLLEAGUES HERE ON
THE PANEL [inaudible]
SENATOR PAT.
THANK YOU -- THIS IS A SUMMER
MEDINA AND FIRST OF ALL -- I
WANT.
THANK YOU FOR THE YOUR TESTIMONY
AND THAT OF YOUR WITNESSES AND
CERTAINLY.
AT I DON'T THINK ANYONE WELL
IT'S THIS WAY.
CERTAINLY NOT QUESTIONING THE
VALUE AND IMPORTANCE OF ETHNIC
STUDIES -- I THINK THAT'S
SOMETHING -- AND I KNOW THAT --
THE I GUESS THE QUESTION IS IS
THAT.
MY MIND IS.
WHY ARE WE PURSUING THIS ROUTE --
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE --
CURRICULA IS -- THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA FIVE EDUCATION IN
FACT THIS COMMITTEE IS ADOPTED
RULES TO SAY THAT.
BECAUSE WE'VE HAD NUMEROUS BILLS
WERE PEOPLE WANT TO PUT THINGS
IN CURRICULA AND SAID THAT WELL.
WE HAVE A BODY WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT YOU CATION -- THAT.
DECIDES THESE THINGS THAT -- WE
SHOULD SHOULDN'T BE TRYING TO
LEGISLATE CURRICULA -- AND YOU
KNOW FOR A AND AND IN FACT THIS
BODY DECIDED BECAUSE IT'S A
PEOPLE.
UP AT VARIOUS BILLS FOR VARIOUS
ITEMS -- OF OF IMPORTANCE -- AND
SO FORTH THAT -- YOU KNOW WHAT
WE SHOULD BE WE KNOW THAT WE
SHOULD LIVE BASICALLY WE CAN
MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS ARE WE
SUGGEST THINGS TO THE BODY AN
INDICATOR THAT THE LEVEL SUPPORT
FOR THAT.
BUT WE SHOULDN'T BE TRYING.
TO LEGISLATURE -- THE CURRICULA.
AND A SO I THINK -- IN MANY WAYS
THAT'S MY CONCERN IS THAT I
WOULD LOVE IT IF EVERY SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
NO DOUBT THAT THEY YOU BILLS
ACCOMPLISHED BUT A MUCH DIME
BAND AS SOME CONCERNS ABOUT.
THIS IS THE ROUTE WHICH WERE
TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH IT -- AND
SO CAN YOU SPEAK.
TO EFFORTS -- I MEAN IS THAT I
UNDERSTAND FUND NOW THIS IS
ACTUALLY SPONSORED BY THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF THE WHOSE
OVERSEAS IN THE VERY DEPARTMENT
I MEAN WHY CAN'T THE
SUPERINTENDENT IN THE WAY OF THE
AND EVERYONE SAID.
WE SHOULDN'T.
WE SHOULD DO THIS THROUGH THE
USUAL WAY THAT WE'RE SUPPOSED TO
BE DOING THIS INSTEAD OF TRYING
TO IMPOSE IT.
FROM THE LEGISLATURE -- BECAUSE
THERE'S MANY WERE THE THINGS AND
THEY SAID THAT MAKE STUDIES
CERTAINLY I THINK YOU MAKE A
VERY POWERFUL CASE FOR ETHNIC
STUDIES -- NAVY PEOPLE CAN'T
BECAUSE POWERFUL CASE FOR OTHER
THINGS BUT YEAH I THINK I THINK
WE I I AM CONCERNING YOUR
TEACHER -- SO I APPRECIATE THAT
TO YOUR OWN EXPERIENCE THAT YOU
KNOW -- YOU KNOW YOU HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO MANAGE A
CURRICULA YOU HAVE A CERTAIN
FIXED AMOUNT OF TIME WITH
STUDENTS -- AND YOU HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT HOW DO I YOU KNOW HOW
TO EDUCATE.
AND SO FORTH AND AND CERTAINLY I
THINK -- ETHNIC SAY IS A VERY
IMPORTANT PART OF THAT BUT AT
CERTAIN POINTS OUT LIKE I AS THE
EDUCATORS NEED TO BE ABLE.
TO YOU KNOW FIGURE HIGH PUT ALL
THE PIECES TOGETHER RIGHT SELF.
THE LEGISLATURE SAYS I WANT
MANDATE THIS COURSE HERE IN THAT
CLASS AND HAS TO BE IN A CERTAIN
WAY -- THAT CAN CONSTRAIN EVERY
I THINK WE SAID.
YOU SHOULD TEACH ETHNIC STUDIES
AND THAT SHOULD BE SOMETHING.
THAT STUDENTS NEED TO
DEMONSTRATE COMPETENCE AND AND
DAY AND AND BEFORE THEY GRADUATE
THAT'S ONE THING BUT THEN THE
START BEING VERY SPECIFIC ABOUT
WHICH I WAS A PERHAPS YOU CAN
SPEAK [inaudible]
TO WHY.
WHY WE'RE NOT GOING THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION WHY
ISN'T THE SUPERINTEND WELL YOU
CAN'T SPEAK FOR THE SUPER DEAD
BODIES SPONSOR BUT I MEAN WHY
ARE WE GOING THROUGH THAT ROUTE
INSTEAD OF THIS -- ONE WHERE
WE'RE BASICALLY TELLING
DEPARTMENT OCCASION THEY HAVE TO
DO SOMETHING.
I MEAN YOU HAVE A LOT OF SUPPORT
WILL HAVE EDUCATORS HERE -- I
MEAN IT'S GREAT -- SO WHY THE
WAY PEOPLE FEEL LIKE THEY CAN'T
GO THROUGH THE EDUCATION ROUTE
THROUGH THE EDUCATION DEPARTMENT
WHERE V. OF EDUCATORS FELL
EDUCATORS THERE AND WE HAVE SO
MUCH SUPPORT AND EDUCATION TO ME
THAT WAS EXPRESSED HERE.
WHY CAN'T IT BE ACCOMPLISHED
THAT WAY INSTEAD OF -- BASICALLY
FROM THE OUTSIDE FRANKLY YEAH.
THANK YOU SENATOR YES I I THINK
IT'S AN EXCELLENT EXCELLENT
QUESTION.
SO AS YOU MENTIONED I WAS A
TEACHER HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER.
AND ONE OF THE SUBJECTS THAT I
TOP WAS HISTORY -- AND GOT A
MASTERS IN HISTORY -- SO I FEEL --
SOMEWHAT COMPETENT IN THE FIELD
OF HIS I RECOGNIZE IS AN EXPERT
IN THIS.
AND I AND I WOULD SAY THAT IT IS
NOT I AGREE WITH YOU.
THAT IT IS NOT OR SHOULDN'T BE.
THE LEGISLATURE'S ROLE
[inaudible] TO RIGHT CURRICULA.
TO SAY WHAT CLASSES SHOULD
INCLUDE.
WHETHER IT BE HISTORY.
OR FOREIGN LANGUAGE OR MATH OR
SCIENCE IT IS NOT THE ROLE OF
THE LEAD OF THE LEGISLATURE TO
SAY WHAT SHOULD BE.
IN THE CURRICULUM.
AND THIS BILL DOESN'T DO THAT.
THIS BILL DOESN'T DO THAT AT ALL.
AS I MENTIONED IN MY EARLIER
REMARKS.
WE HAD A ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVEL
WHO INTRODUCED THE BILL THAT
PASSED THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. TO CREATE THE
CURRICULUM.
THEY HAVE DONE THAT NOW.
THAT CURRICULUM THAT THEY
CREATED.
WITH INPUT FROM TEACHERS.
FROM -- ACADEMICS.
OF FROM PEOPLE IN THE FIELD.
THEY DEVELOP THE CURRICULUM.
SO WE THE LEGISLATURE.
OUR HANDS OFF ON THAT AS WE
SHOULD BE.
AS WE SHOULD BE -- IT I THINK
WOULD BE DANGEROUS FOR
LEGISLATURE'SLEGISLATORS TO SAY
WHAT HAS TO BE IN THE CURRICULUM
SO WE DID THAT.
WE DID THAT WE DID WITH DID THAT
WITH THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALEJO'S
BILL.
BUT THAT'S WHAT THAT BILL DID
[inaudible]
CREATED CURRICULA.
NOW THAT WE HAVE THAT CURRICULUM
CORRECT ROUTE [inaudible]
BY SAYING
WE HAVE THIS CURRICULUM
DEVELOPED BY EXPERTS
[inaudible]
INPUT.
BY A BROAD VARIETY OF EXPERTS.
INCLUDING TEACHERS.
BUT WE THINK THAT CURRICULUM IS
IMPORTANT ENOUGH THAT IT SHOULD
BE TAUGHT.
EVERYWHERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT I DO THINK IS THE ROLE
OF THE LEGISLATURE. TO SAY WHAT
SHOULD BE THE REQUIREMENTS
[inaudible] FOR GRADUATION --
CERTAINLY FOR HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS.
AND LATER TODAY THERE IS A BILL
THAT I AM CO AUTHOR ON ASKING --
TELLING THE CSU THAT THEY SHOULD
DO THE SAME.
AND AND THAT'S AN EVEN BIGGER
STEP BECAUSE I WAS A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE TRUSTEE.
AND RESPECT THE DIFFERENTIATION
BETWEEN -- GIVING THE FACULTY
[inaudible]
POWER.
IN THE END IN THE COLLEGE LEVEL
TOOK. TO HAVE ALL THINGS --
ACADEMIC.
BUT AS I SAID ALSO IN BEEN THE
BEGINNING.
IT IS NOW BEEN FIFTEEN YEARS.
IT HAS BEEN FIFTY YEARS
[inaudible]
SINCE.
STRUGGLE BECAUSE T CAME OUT OF
STRUGGLE.
OF STUDENTS [inaudible]
DIVERSE STUDENTS.
WHO STOOD UP AND SAID YOU KNOW
WE DON'T SEE OURSELVES REFLECTED?
IN THE TEACHERS IN FRONT OF US
IN THE COUNSELORS AT THE HIGH
SCHOOLS IN THE ADMINISTRATORS.
IN THE CURRICULA SO IT WAS OUT
OF THAT STRUGGLE THAT THESE
CLASSES THAT THIS -- CAME OUT OF
AND WE'VE NOW SEEN FIFTY YEARS.
WHERE NOTHING IS CHANGED?
WE WE WE ARE SEEING SOME
DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA SEEING THE VALUE.
OF TEACHING ETHNIC STUDIES AND
INCLUDING THEM IN THOSE INCLUDE --
DAVIS SANTA BARBARA [inaudible]
LOS ANGELES.
SO WE'VE SEEN MANY DISTRICTS
CHOOSE AND AND AND TO MAKE IT A
REQUIREMENT ON THEIR OWN.
BUT I DO THINK IT IS THE THE THE
THE JOB.
OF THE LEGISLATURE TO LOOK AT
THINGS HOLISTICALLY AND TO SAY.
THIS.
BUT NEEDS TO BE TAUGHT THIS
SHOULD BE SOMETHING THAT
EVERYONE.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
COMPETENT AS A TEACHER.
I DO NOT SEE HOW.
IF I COULD MENTION SOMEONE.
SOMEONE WHO IS RESPECTED TOM
BROKE OFF.
SOMEONE WHO IS RESPECTED
NATIONALLY IN THE UNITED STATES
[inaudible]
HOW?
IS SOMEONE LIKE TOM BROKAW
[inaudible]
THE NEWSCASTER. TO MAKE COMMENTS
ABOUT LATINOS -- NOT KNOWING
ENOUGH ENGLISH.
WE'RE NOT TRYING HARD ENOUGH TO
LEARN ENGLISH HOW CAN YOU THINK
OF THAT PERSON AS BEING FULLY
EDUCATED.
WHEN THEY MAKE STATEMENTS LIKE
THAT?
SO IT IS THAT [inaudible]
KNOWLEDGE.
THAT WE HAVE THAT WE ARE SAYING --
STUDENTS WHO DON'T HAVE THIS
EDUCATION ARE LACKING.
THERE SHOULD BE COMPETENT IN I
DO THINK IT IS OUR ROLE TO SAY.
THEY SHOULD HAVE THAT KNOWLEDGE.
ALL RIGHT ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
YOUR FOLLOW UP CENTER PAN SO SO
FIRST OF ALL -- AS IMMEDIATE FOR
SO I WENT AND I I'LL TAKE
TREMENDOUS RSPECT YOU KNOLLYS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BUT ALSO AS AN
EDUCATOR AND I APPRECIATE -- YOU
BRING THIS FORWARD IN YOUR
DISCUSSION I A I A STILL
CONTINUE HAVE CONCERNS --
SOMEONE WHO IS NOW FOR FASTER
AND HIGHER EDUCATION AS WELL --
ABOUT EXACTLY OUR ROLE IN.
DICTATING CURRICULA SO YOU'RE
RIGHT YOU KNOW WE DID HAVE
PROCESS WERE YOU KNOW THOSE THE
A CARIBBEAN CRUISE CURRICULA.
NUMBER DEVELOPED AROUND ETHNIC
STUDIES -- I A YEAH I I SIX
THOUGH.
THE WAY THE BILL WAS FRAMED --
FOR IT REQUIRES A PARTICULAR
COURSE -- IT I THINK IS LOW
CONCERNING IS STILL CONCERNING
TO ME -- IN TERMS OF I I I
SUPPORT THE IDEA THAT PEOPLE
SHOULD HAVE AND FLEE I'VE AS A
PERSON OF COLOR WHO GREW UP WITH
DIDN'T SEE VERY MUCH OF DON'T
WASTE IT MYSELF -- FOR I A AND A
FEW WHAT YOU'RE SAYING AND AND I
I THINK THAT STERN CERTAINLY I
AGREE WITH YOU THERE ARE --
THERE IS A LOT OF THERE IS
TREMENDOUS IGNORANCE OF OF OF OF
OF THE HISTORY OF MANY OF THOSE
PEOPLE TO ACTUALLY TO WHO WHO --
NOW HE LIVES -- BUT CONTRIBUTE
TO OUR COUNTRY THE PEOPLE ARE
NOT AWARE OF THE HISTORY OF AND
A I OPENED MYSELF I HAVE I'VE
IGNORANCE IN MANY AREAS AS WELL
AND THROUGH MY OWN EDUCATION.
AS MUCH AS AS MUCH SCHOOLS HAVE
GONE THROUGH PRIDE MORE SO THAN
ANY -- IT BUT I A YOU KNOW IT AS
AN EDUCATOR I STILL HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT -- NOT WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO TEACH BUT AT X.
WHICH I THINK IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT MADE A VERY POWERFUL
CASE WITNESSES A MADE A VERY
POWERFUL CASE I THE THE THE
ROUTE WHICH WE'RE GOING TO IN
TERMS OF TRYING TO AND HOW WE'RE
TRYING TO DICTATE IT.
AND I I HAVE CONCERNS THAT ABOUT
THE LEGISLATURE DOING THAT --
VERSES -- OTHER MECHANISMS BUT I
I DO APPRECIATE YOU BRING THIS
FORWARD THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENDER TO RAZA.
YES -- I TO WANT TO THANK YOU --
I'M SURE EVERY SINGLE OF CHICANO
LATINO AFRICAN AMERICAN WHO WENT
THROUGH THE STRUGGLE OVER THE
MANY DECADES IN THE PAST CAN
POINT TO OUR OWN STORIES.
OF THE IMPACT THAT TAKE INTO A
CLASS -- SO YOUR STORY PLACE TO
ME MANY MANY YEARS AGO OF NOT
EVER HAVING READ ANYTHING.
IN HISTORY BOOKS OR IN ANY BOOK
ABOUT THE CONTRIBUTIONS ARE ON
THE PRESENCE.
OTHER THAN -- NATIVE AMERICANS
IN A VERY.
NOT IN A VERY POSITIVE WAY IN A
VERY NEGATIVE WAY.
SO I I APPRECIATE EVERYONE'S --
ROLE IN MOVING THIS FORWARD -- I
WOULD.
I WOULD -- WITH REGARD TO MY
COLLEAGUE CENTER PANS --
CONCERNS I WOULD NORMALLY HAVE
THE SAME CONCERN I WOULD START
OUT WITH WITH THAT CONCERNED --
BECAUSE WE DO WANT TO LIMIT WHAT
THE RULE IS AND MAKE SURE THAT
IT'S ABSOLUTELY AN ESSENTIAL
PART OF WHAT.
OUR RESPONSIBILITIES ARE.
BUT HAVING BEEN THROUGH THE
STRUGGLE AND HAVING SEEN THAT
LIKE YOU SAID AT LEAST FIFTY
YEARS AGO THAT THE STARTED
THAT TIME COMES WHEN.
LEGISLATURE HAS TO STEP IN
BECAUSE IT'S NOT GETTING DONE
[inaudible]
AND WE'RE OF THE MIND WE DO THAT
IN A NUMBER OF SUBJECTS IN A
NUMBER OF AREAS.
WE DO THAT WITH HEALTH WE DO
THAT WITH OTHER THINGS WHEN IT'S
NOT GETTING DONE RIGHT.
GOVERNMENT HAS TO STEP IN TO
CORRECT IT -- I WOULD PREFER.
IN A MUCH MUCH OF A BIGGER WAY I
WOULD PREFER THAT WE DIDN'T HAVE
THE WE SPOKE OF THE REQUIREMENT
OF THOSE SPECIFIC ETHNIC STUDIES.
I WOULD PREFER THAT HISTORY
BOOKS INCLUDED US WITHOUT HAVING
ETHNIC STUDIES REQUIRED -- I
THINK IT'S SHAMEFUL I THINK IT'S
SHAMEFUL THAT WOMEN'S ROLES THE
LGBT Q. ROLE THAT THE THE ROLE
OF ETHNIC GROUPS.
I THINK IT'S SHAMEFUL THAT OUR
HISTORY BOOKS DO NOT REFLECT THE
TRUTH.
OF WHAT WHAT HAS BEEN THE
HISTORY OF THIS COUNTRY IN OF
THE WORLD.
SO -- I THINK THERE ARE TIMES
WHEN WE DO HAVE TO STEP IN AND I
THINK THIS IS ONE OF THOSE FEW
TIMES SO.
I APPRECIATE AND SUPPORT YOU.
VERY GOOD -- I OUT ONE AT SHARE
MY THOUGHTS AS WELL -- BUT FIRST
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN THIS AREA I WANT
TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIKE
HELL FOR HIS LEADERSHIP PRIOR TO
YOU AND THERE'S SO MANY OTHERS
WHO HAVE.
TRIED TO LEAD IN THIS AREA NOT
NECESSARILY THROUGH LEGISLATION
BUT THROUGH ACTIVISM ON OUR
CAMPUSES.
AND IN OUR COMMUNITIES --
THERE'S NO DOUBT IN MY MIND THAT
ETHNIC STUDIES IS A CRITICAL.
UP POINT OF UNDERSTANDING FOR US
IN CALIFORNIA FOR US AS A
SOCIETY.
THAT -- WITHOUT THAT TYPE OF
UNDERSTANDING.
AND TOLERANCE OUR WHOLE COHESION
AS A COMMUNITY AS A STATE AS A
COUNTRY AS  WORLD -- IS IS IN
JEOPARDY.
AND SO IT IS SO IMPORTANT THAT
WE HAVE THAT UNDERSTANDING --
THE DILEMMA FOR ME IN YOUR BILL
THOUGH IS SIMILAR TO DOCTOR PANS
THE ISSUE THAT HE HAS RAISED.
AS I UNDERSTAND IT THE
LEGISLATURE IN THEIR WISDOM HAS
A IT HAS DIRECTED.
THAT MODEL CURRICULUM THE
ESTABLISHED IN THIS AREA.
AND THAT WE ARE IN THE PROCESS
OF DOING THAT RIGHT NOW.
IT'S COMPLETED SENATOR.
OKAY ACCORDING TO THE ANALYSIS.
SAYS THAT THE THE INSTRUCTIONAL
QUALITY COMMISSION.
HAS TO SUBMIT THE MODEL
CURRICULUM BY DECEMBER THIRTY
FIRST TWENTY NINETEEN HAVE THEY
ALREADY DONE THAT.
RIGHT THE GROUP MODEL CURRICULUM
AS HAS BEEN COMPLETED.
I IT IS NOW MY UNDERSTANDING AND
IF THERE'S ANYONE HERE FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION THE MY
CORRECT ME.
BUT THE THE MODEL CURRICULUM HAS
BEEN COMPLETED.
IT'S ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED PAGES
IT'S ON MY DESK -- AND IT IS NOW
LOOK -- THE TIME FOR PUBLIC
REVIEW.
OF THAT MODEL GET KILLED AND
THAT THAT THAT'S CONSISTENT WITH
THE ANALYSIS THE HOUSES SAYS
THAT THERE'S A DEADLINE FOR
COMPLETING THE DRAFT IT'S GOING
THROUGH THAT.
REVIEW PROCESS THAT THE THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION HAS TO
ADOPT THE CURRICULUM.
BY MARCH THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY SO WE HAVE A PROCESS IN
PLACE YOU JUST ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THAT WHICH IS GOOD.
THAT THEY'RE TRYING TO PROVIDE.
A AT WITH GOOD WISDOM THIS MODEL
CURRICULUM FOR HOW THE SCHOOLS
CAN TEACH ETHNIC STUDIES RIGHT.
AND THE EFFORT TO TRY TO PROMOTE
AND ENCOURAGE OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO TEACH ETHNIC
STUDIES SO THAT.
THAT PROCESS IS IS IS GOING.
AHEAD.
AND WITH THE MARCH. TWENTY
TWENTY DEADLINE FOR THE STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION TO ENGAGE SO
THE DILEMMA FOR ME IS IS THAT
TYPICALLY WHEN -- THAT THE
QUESTION OF IS THERE A
COMPELLING STATE NEED FOR US TO
GET INVOLVED IN ALL KINDS OF
THINGS.
YOU HAVE TO LOOK AND SAY OKAY.
WHAT'S THE PROGRESS OF THE WORK
BEING DONE.
AND ARE THERE ROAD BLOCKS TO IT
THAT WE SHOULD BE AWARE OF EYES
ARE OPPOSITION TO IT THAT WE
SHOULD BE AWARE OF HAVE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS HAD THE CHANCE TO
ENACT THIS AND THEY HAVEN'T.
TAKEN THOSE STEPS THESE ARE ALL
THE QUESTIONS THAT GO THROUGH MY
HEAD.
AND I GUESS THAT THAT LEAVES ME.
SHORT TO THE EXTENT THAT.
WE HAVEN'T EVEN GIVEN THAT MODEL
CURRICULUM YET.
THAT THERE HASN'T BEEN THE
ENGAGEMENT THAT I'M AWARE OF AND
MAYBE YOU CAN SHARE -- WHAT YOU
NOW?
WHERE SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT SAID
NO NO NO NO NO WE HAVE A
THOUSAND SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE
WE GIVEN THE CHANCE TO DO THE
RIGHT THING -- BECAUSE CLEARLY
THEIR WORK IS LACKING I WE AGREE.
BUT I SEE HOW MANY KIDS ARE
TAKING AT THINK STUDIES 1%
THAT'S EMBARRASSING.
AND IS THAT OUR FAULT WE'RE
WE'RE NOT PROVIDING THAT
CURRICULUM OR IS OR SOME OTHER
PLACE WHERE WE CAN BE WORKING
TOGETHER TO MAKE THAT BETTER.
BUT THAT'S REALLY MY FIRST
QUESTION TO YOU IS IS WHAT WHAT
HAVE WE DONE TO GIVE THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THEIR ABILITY TO DO
THE RIGHT THING BEFORE WE STEP
IN.
SOME SCHOOL DISTRICTS LIKE DAVIS
THAT RECENTLY ADOPTED ETHNIC
STUDIES.
AS RECENT AS LAST MONTH.
HAVE SAID WHY WAIT FOR THIS
LEGISLATION TO GET PAST AND THEY
HAVE SAID THAT AT THEIR MEETINGS.
AT THEIR BOARD MEETINGS AND WE
SAW HERE -- A SEVERAL SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBERS IN SUPPORT OF A OF
THIS BILL.
I I I KNOW THAT.
I I WOULD SAY THAT EVERYONE HERE
WHO'S TESTIFIED -- WHICH SHARE
MY OWN CONCERN.
THAT IT IS ONE THING TO CREATE
CURRICULUM FOR DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION IS ANOTHER THING TO
IMPLEMENT THAT CURRICULA
[inaudible]
AND SO.
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
SOMETIMES CREATES CURRICULUM
LIKE THEY DID FOR THE SEVEN SAYS
ARE CHAVEZ HOLIDAY.
OR PERHAPS THE WHOLE COST.
BUT IT IS ANOTHER THING TO SEE
THAT CURRICULUM IMPLEMENTED IN
THE DISTRICTS.
AND AND I WOULD BE VERY HAPPY.
IF EVERY ONE OF THOSE ONE
THOUSAND SCHOOL DISTRICTS ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
DID LIKE DAVIS.
OR SANTA BARBARA.
AND ON THEIR OWN SAID WE WERE
GOING TO DO THIS.
BUT I THINK THEY'VE HAD TIME TO
DO THAT ALREADY.
YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN AGAIN FIFTY
YEARS.
I AM NOT GONNA LIVE ANOTHER
FIFTY YEARS.
BUT I WOULD HATE.
THAT MY GREAT GRAND CHILDREN
WOULD STILL BE HAVING THE SAME
CLASSES.
BEING TAUGHT THE SAME THINGS
THAT ARE BEING TAUGHT TODAY
[inaudible]
I WOULD RESPECTFULLY SAY THAT.
WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO DO IS GET
BOTH THINGS ON AT THE SAME TIME
THAT WHEN THE CURRICULUM IS IS
READY?
BECAUSE OUR BILL SAYS THAT THIS
WOULD BECOME A HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATE XIN REQUIREMENT AND
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE GIVING SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
AMPLE TIME TO PREPARE TRAIN
THEIR TEACHERS.
GET THE CURRICULUM SO WE ARE
WORKING HAND IN HAND WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
AS AS YOU NOTED [inaudible]
THEY ARE.
A SPONSOR OF THIS BILL.
AND TONY THURMOND STATE
SUPERINTENDENT WAS WITH ME --
WHEN HE WHEN WE PRESENTED THIS
BILL IN THE -- ASSEMBLY THEY ARE
GETTING COMMITTEE WELL AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND SI I THINK THAT THAT IS THE
ISSUE THAT GIVES ME PAUSE NOT
ABOUT THE BELIEF AND THE DESIRE.
TO HAVE THAT UNDERSTANDING THAT
BROADER UNDERSTANDING OF OUR OF
OUR WORLD AND OUR CLASSES BUT
THAT.
THAT WE SEEM TO BE ON ATTRACTED
TO PROVIDE THAT MODEL CURRICULUM
AND THAT HOPEFULLY HAVE OURS ARE
EDUCATIONAL LEADERS TAKE THE
RIGHT STEPS TO INCORPORATED.
AND I THINK THAT'S A BETTER
PROCESS TO PLAY OUT THAN US
CREATING A MANDATE -- RIGHT UP
FRONT EVEN THOUGH FOR SUCH A
GOOD AND IMPORTANT BECAUSE AS
YOU AS YOU PROMOTES THAT BE MY
MY CONCLUDING COMMENTS.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
ALL RIGHT BEFORE I ENTERTAIN A
MOTION I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR BEING SO -- DOGGETT IN THIS
I I BELIEVE THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ALEJO'S HAD THIS BILL WHEN I
FIRST CAME TO THE SENATE AND I
WAS HAPPY TO VOTE FOR THEN.
I VOTED FOR YOUR BILL LAST YEAR
I WILL BE SUPPORTING IT THIS
YEAR.
WE ARE WORKING ON MODEL
CURRICULUM BUT I THINK WHAT I
WORRY ABOUT IS EXACTLY WHAT YOU
SAID ASSEMBLYMEMBER IT'S BEEN
FIFTY YEARS AND SOMETIMES WE
CANNOT RELY ON PEOPLE AND WAIT
FOR THEM TO DO THE RIGHT THING
OUT OF THE GOODNESS OF THEIR
HEART.
AND OUR JOB IS TO LEGISLATE AND
LEGISLATING THIS IS MEANING THAT
PEOPLE WILL BE FORCED TO LEARN
ABOUT EACH OTHER AND GUESS WHAT
WHEN WE LEARN ABOUT EACH OTHER
WE'RE GOING TO DISCOVER THAT WE
HAVE MORE IN COMMON.
THAN NOT A MAYBE IT WILL CREATE
A BETTER WORLD BECAUSE THEN WILL
UNDERSTAND EACH OTHER AND WE
WON'T DISLIKE EACH OTHER SO I
APPRECIATE YOU BEING SO DOG IN
THIS -- HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT --
DO DO WE HAVE A MOTION I'M SORRY
TO STEP BACK OKAY THE BILL HAS
BEEN MOVED BY.
SENATOR TORONTO.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE SORRY
THANK YOU SENATOR.
I I VERY MUCH WANT TO THANK ALL
THE WITNESSES THE STUDENTS THE
TEACHERS PROFESSORS.
VERY FIRST GROUP OF PEOPLE FROM
THE OUT THE HOSTED A CALIFORNIA
WHO'VE COME TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF
OF THE BILL.
AND IN CLOSING I I I WANNA SAY I
HAVE WITH ME TODAY -- VETERAN OF
THE YEAR TEACHER RATIO SAID
THOUGH WHO TAUGHT WITH ME A POLY
HIGH SCHOOL FOR THIRTEEN YEARS.
WHEN?
FILMMAKER KEN BURNS.
DID HIS EPIC DOCUMENTARY ON
WORLD WAR.
TWO THERE WAS NOT ONE LATINOS.
VETERANS.
IN THAT FIVE PART.
A BIG STORY OF WORLD WAR.
TWO WE KNOW THAT.
AFRICAN AMERICANS ASIAN
AMERICANS LATINOS FOUGHT.
IN ALMOST EVERY SINGLE WAR.
THAT THIS NATION.
HAS BEEN IN.
AND TO CREATE SOMETHING LIKE
THAT AND MET.
LATINOS IS PROOF OF WHY WE NEED
AT THINK STUDIES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU SOME A MEMBER THE
BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
DORADO MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM THREE AB THREE THIRTY ONE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE WILK CHAIN TO WRESTLE
TO WRESTLE AYE GLAZER.
MCGUIRE PAN.
THANK YOU SOME A MEMBER WILL
LEAVE THAT BILL ON CALL FOR
OTHERS TO ADD ON THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE YOU GUYS GONE SO LONG
THAT I COULD PRESENT A BILL AND
COME BACK BECAUSE I WANT TO SAY
SOMETHING ABOUT YOUR BILL.
ALL RIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN
IS HERE TO PRESENT FOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOW.
THAT IS FILE ITEM.
ONE AB.
ONE THIRTY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BEGIN
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SHARE AND THAT SENATORS.
AND I HAD THE UNCLES WHO WERE
PARATROOPERS IN WORLD WAR TWO
FORTINOS WHO JUMPED OUT INTO
BEHIND ENEMY LINES -- AB ONE
THIRTY ESTABLISHES THE HIGHER
EDUCATION PERFORMANCE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I'D ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ONE MOMENT IF EVERYONE IN
THE AUDIENCE CAN JUST BE A
LITTLE QUIETER SO WE CAN BE
RESPECTFUL OF OUR AUTHOR.
THANK YOU IF YOU HAVE A
CONVERSATION TAKE IT OUTSIDE
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
AB ONE THIRTY ESTABLISH THE
HIGHER EDUCATION PERFORMANCE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION AS A
STATEWIDE POST SECONDARY
COORDINATION AND PLANNING ENTITY.
WE HAVE BEEN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
ADMIN WITHOUT A PLANNING ENTITY
TO COVER ARE ARE A COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ARE SEE ISSUE IN ARE
YOU SEE SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND
TWELVE WHEN THE SYSTEM WE HAD IN
PLACE WAS DE FUNDED IN.
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN AFTER IT WAS.
AS THE BUDGET IS STATE WAS GOING
TO VERY HARD BUDGET TIMES IT WAS
CONTINUING KIND OF CHIPPED AWAY
AT A AND THAT LEAVES US -- I
THINK IT'S ONLY ONE OF TWO
STATES IN THE NATION THAT DOES
NOT HAVE AN OVERALL COORDINATING.
BODY -- COORDINATING FOR OUR
GOALS COORDINATING FOR WHERE WE
MIGHT HAVE AN A A NEW CAMPUS --
OVERALL -- HOW THE STUDENTS ARE
DOING A AND SO BRED AS AS WE
STAND RIGHT NOW THE WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT LEAVING NO STOOD BEHIND
AND WE KNOW THEY WERE?
THIRTY THOUSAND CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS WITHOUT A SEAT LAST
TIME AND AND THE NEW AUDITS WE
HEAR ALL THE TIME.
ABOUT SOMETIMES AS MANY NOT
BEING SPENT AS IT WAS ACCOUNTED.
FOR IT JUST SEEMS TO ME THAT IT
IS NOW THE TIME TO RE INSTATE
THE OVERSEEING BODY.
THAT WOULD BE ABLE TO SERVE --
IN THIS AND I AND I'M ALSO AWARE
THAT THERE IS ANOTHER BILL
MOVING ON THE SENATE SIDE AND WE
REALIZE AT SOME POINT WE WILL
HAVE TO COORDINATE THE TWO OF
THOSE BILLS.
AND WE ARE STANDING BY READY TO
DO THAT -- THE COMMISSION WAS
BORN IN THE NINETEEN SIXTY
MASTER PLAN -- AND WE GOT AND WE
WENT A LONG TIME AND BEING THE
MODEL FOR THE WORLD AND I THINK
AS WE ALL KNOW WITH BUDGET CUTS
WE'VE TAKEN SOME STUMBLES AND WE
THINK PUTTING BACK INTO PLACE A
COORDINATING BODY.
WOULD SERVE THAT IN TODAY I HAVE
WITH ME.
CHECK BRENNER WITH THE CAT
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY.
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SEVEN MEMBER BEGIN
WHEN YOU'RE READY.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR LEYVA AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE -- MY
NAME IS JAKE BREMNER I'M THE
STATE AND FEDERAL POLICY
DIRECTOR WITH THE CAMPAIGN FOR
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY WERE
STATEWIDE POLICY RESEARCH AND
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION DEDICATED
TO ENSURING THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE AN EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY. TO ATTEND AND
SUCCEED IN COLLEGE I'D LIKE TO
FIRST START BY THANKING ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS EGGMAN AND LOW -- FOR
THEIR LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE
AND EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR AB.
ONE THIRTY WE KNOW THAT IN THE
COMING YEARS CALIFORNIA WILL
NEED A GROWING SUPPLY OF
EDUCATED WORKERS TO MEET THE
DEMANDS OF OUR DYNAMIC STATE
ECONOMY.
AND KEEP FOR BILLING THIS NEED
WILL BE ENSURING THAT THE ACCESS
AND SUCCESS OF POPULATIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN HISTORICALLY
UNDERREPRESENTED IN HIGHER
EDUCATION.
YET AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN
POINTED OUT CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY
STANDS AS ONE OF ONLY TWO STATES
WITHOUT A STATEWIDE COORDINATING
BODY FOR HIGHER EDUCATION.
MEANING WE LACK THE STATE LEVEL
LEADERSHIP RESPONSIBLE FOR
PLANNING OVERSIGHT AND
COORDINATION TO POSITION OUR
STATE TO MEET THESE CHALLENGES
WE NEED A BODY THAT IS NOT
REPRESENTATIVE OF ANY ONE SECTOR
OR SEGMENT.
BUT RATHER UNDERSTANDS THE
BROADER NEEDS OF THE STATE AND
CAN FACILITATE THE NECESSARY
CONVERSATIONS ANALYSIS AND
EXPERTISE TOWARDS THESE GOALS.
WELL IN PERFECT THE FORMER
CALIFORNIA POSTSECONDARY
EDUCATION COMMISSION WITH ABLE
TO OFFER ENROLLMENT PROJECTIONS
ASSESS REGIONAL DEMANDS CRITICAL
INFORMATION TO INFORMING POLICY
AND BUDGETARY DECISIONS.
IN ITS ABSENCE THE CAMPAIGN FOR
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY AND MANY OF
OUR PARTNERS.
ARE ASKED TO HELP FILL THE VOID
IN VARIOUS WAYS WHICH IS NEITHER
SUSTAINABLE NOR IDEAL IN A STATE
WITH SYSTEMS AS LARGE AND
COMPLEX AS CALIFORNIANS.
AB ONE THIRTY RECOGNIZES THIS
CRITICAL VOID AND ESTABLISHES
STATE LEVEL LEADERSHIP POSITION
TO CONFRONT THESE CHALLENGES.
IMPORTANTLY IT ALSO PRESENTS AN
OPPORTUNITY AND MEANS FOR THE
STATE TO ARTICULATE A LONG RANGE
VISION FOR HIGHER EDUCATION WITH
CLEAR AND ACTIONABLE GOALS FOR
ENSURING COLLEGE ACCESS.
STUDENT SUCCESS AS WELL AS
CLOSING THE RACIAL AND REGIONAL
EQUITY GAPS THAT ARE NECESSARY
TO MEETING FUTURE WORK FORCE
NEEDS -- SO WITH THAT AT THANK
YOU AND RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU IS -- DECISIONAL
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MANY RODRIGUEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE EDUCATION TRUST
WEST HERE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KERRY WASHINGTON WITH THE CAL
STATE STUDENT ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING WHEN OF THE AS MY
GOLLY KINCAID WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT.
THE ANOTHER WITH THE ALUMNI FROM
THE CSU SYSTEMS AND ASPIRING
EDUCATOR OF HIGHER EDUCATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
SEEING AND HEARING THEM WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS
CENTER GLAZER.
THANK YOU -- I AM NOT PLEASED TO
SEE YOUR BILL AND HAPPY TO
SUPPORT ITS DAY AND IT IT DOES
MATCH UP SENATOR ALLEN AYE OR
JOINT AUTHORS ON SB.
THREE AND OUR GOALS AND DESIRES
ARE ALL VERY MUCH ALIGNED IN THE
QUARTER THE PARTNERSHIP AND
GETTING THIS OVER THE FINISH
LINE SO THANK YOU SO MUCH AND
THANK YOU SO AND SIGN.
UP.
SENATOR GLAZERS ANIMOTION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
WOMAN REJECT CLOSE JUST LOOK
FORWARD TO ESTABLISHING THIS
INDEPENDENT BODY TO BETTER SERVE
THREE MILLION CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS VERY GOOD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR GLAZER MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ITEM ONE AB
ONE THIRTY THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS
LEYVA.
LEAVE THE AYE WILK CHAIN
GLASSELL TO WRESTLE AYE GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE PAN.
BELIEVE THAT BILL ON CALL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
CORRIE REMOVED -- FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING
COME ON DOWN.
THAT IS FILE ITEM AB ONE ZERO
ZERO ONE BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- FIRST
AND WE JUST THINK YOU AND YOUR
TEAM FOR YOUR AMENDMENTS WERE
MORE THAN HAPPY.
TO TAKE THE AMENDMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE -- I WAS HONORED TO BE
I WAS HONORED TO BE OUR ON OUR
SPEAKERS BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION
ON EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE FOUND
IS THAT WE REALLY NEEDED BETTER
LOCAL PLANNING AND BETTER LOCAL
DANA -- IN SO AB ONE THOUSAND
ONE DOES EXACTLY THAT IT CHANGES
THE MEMBERSHIP OF LOCAL PLANNING
COUNCILS TO INTO NEW STRATEGIC
PLANNING COUNCILS.
WHICH REPRESENTATIVES FROM EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION.
ACROSS THE SPECTRUM INCLUDING
PROVIDERS PARENTS -- AS WELL AS
EDUCATORS IT ALSO SETS CLEAR
EXPECTATIONS IN REGARDS TO DATA
COLLECTION OF STANDARDS.
AND MAKES A MAKES IT CLEAR WHO
THE RESPONSIBLE PARTIES ARE
RENDERED IN REGARDS TO THE
COUNCIL AS WELL AS THE PALM BUT
OCCASION.
IT ALSO GIVES COUNTIES THE
FLEXIBILITY IN THE MEMBERSHIP OF
THE COUNCIL TO HELP MAKE THE
MODEL FIT BOTH FOR BE COUNTIES
AND FOR SMALL COUNTIES.
I HAVE A TWO WITNESSES HERE TO
SPEAK IN FAVOR THE BILL.
PERFECT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WHICH IS WITNESSES AND SUPPORT
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES EACH --
MADAM CHAIR AND LEGISLATORS --
MY NAME IS NEAR MAILLET DILLMAN
I'M THE COORDINATOR OF THE SAN
MATTEO COUNTY LOCAL TALKER
PLANNING COUNCIL.
SENATE HILL WAS THE FIRST ONE TO
TO BE ESTABLISHED AND I THINK WE
HAVE.
A LOT OF STRENGTH BEHIND US
BECAUSE OF THE HISTORY ETCETERA.
THIS BILL WOULD BILLS WELL THEY
WERE DEVELOPED IN THE NINETIES A
LOT HAS CHANGED FIRST FIVE
DIDN'T EXIST -- Q. R. I. S.
DIDN'T EXIST MANY THINGS.
THIS BILL WILL REALLY UPDATE AS
AS THE LEGISLATOR SAID THE THE
MEMBERSHIP THE MANDATES.
AND THE LOCAL CLOUT OF THE
INSTITUTIONS IT WILL GIVE A
PARTNER AT THE STATE LEVEL WHEN
THE STATE'S MAKING THIS
TREMENDOUS NEW INVESTMENTS IN
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION.
WE NEED A BODY WHERE EVERYONE
HAS A VOICE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
THAT WILL ENSURE THAT -- THESE
INVESTMENTS ARE USED EFFICIENTLY
AND WELL AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
PARTICULARLY THINGS IF YOU CAN
IMAGINE LIKE FACILITIES.
IT'S HARD TO TELL FROM THE STATE
LEVEL WHERE THEY'RE NEEDED HOW
THEY COULD BE ESTABLISHED WHO IS
LEFT OUT OF THE PICTURE WHICH
VOICES ARE NOT AT THE TABLE.
WE REALLY -- THINK THIS BILL
WILL WILL BRING.
THE STRENGTHS THAT SOME COUNTIES
THAT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO ESTABLISH
LOCALLY AND AND MAKE THAT
POSSIBLE FOR ALL COUNTIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
ALLEN CHAIR AND OKAY THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SO -- MY NAME IS SUSIE MARONEY I
AM THE CHILD CARE PLANNING
COUNCIL COORDINATOR FOR CINEMA
COUNTY AND I TO A SUPPORT AB.
ONE ZERO ZERO ONE IT REALLY LIKE
MY COLLEAGUE AMALA MENTIONED --
BRINGS TOGETHER THE LOCAL VOICES
AND AND STRENGTHENS WHAT WE
ALREADY DO AS OF PLANNING
COUNCL COORDINATORS ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU WE HAVE
REMAINING TIME DID YOU WANT.
TO OKAY NO GOD NO DON'T CALL ON
ME.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS JEFF BACA REPRESENTING
THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS IN
SUPPORT.
MANAGER MEMBERS NICK RAMLI ON
BEHALF OF THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS
IN SUPPORT.
ERIN GABLE ABOUT THE FOR SIDE
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MONEY GRIMACE ON BEHALF OF FIRST
FIVE ELAINE SUPPORT.
YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT THIRTY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE WILL
COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS.
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE RESPECT FRENCH
FRIES.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBERS THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
GLAZER MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM FOR AB ONE THOUSAND AND ONE
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO HUMAN SERVICES LEYVA.
HI LEYVA AYE WILK CHAIN LASSELL.
WHO ASAL AYE GLAZER GLAZER AYE
MCGUIRE PAN?
THE BILL ON CALL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH
COME ON DOWN.
YOU ACTUALLY HAVE TO BILLS TO
PRESENT WOULD YOU LIKE TO START
WITH AB.
TEN FIFTY ONE ALL RIGHT VERY
GOOD BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
[inaudible] FOR THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR GOOD MORNING MEMBERS.
AB TEN FIFTY ONE SPONSORED BY
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE WOULD RE
ESTABLISH AN EXEMPTION INITIALLY
PUT INTO STATUTE IN TWO THOUSAND
SIX FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE
NURSING FACULTY TO EXCEED THE
PART TIME FACULTY COURSE LOAD
CAP.
ALLOWING FOR MORE CONTINUITY IN
CLINICAL NURSING EDUCATION.
UNLIKE OTHER PROGRAMS NURSING
REQUIRES EXTENSIVE CLINICAL
COMPONENTS ON TOP OF TIME IN THE
CLASSROOM REQUIRING CLINICAL
ROTATIONS EXTENDING SIX TO
EIGHTEEN WEEKS IN TWELVE HOUR
SHIFTS ONE TO TWO DAYS A WEEK.
MANY CLINICAL NURSING
INSTRUCTORS CONTINUE TO SERVICE
PRACTICING LICENSE NURSES WHILE
TEACHING LEADING TO A LARGER
NUMBER OF PART TIME NURSING
FACULTY.
UNDER EXISTING LAW COURSE LOADS
FOR PART TIME COMMUNITY COLLEGE
AND ADULT EDUCATION FACULTY ARE
CAPPED AT 67%.
OF THE HOURS PER WEEK OF A FULL
TIME COURSE LOAD WHICH IS
APPROXIMATELY TWO COURSES.
THIS CAP RESULTS IN INSTRUCTOR
CHANGES IN THE MIDDLE OF
ROTATION INTERRUPTING STUDENTS
LEARNING PROCESS AND
INTERRUPTING THE CARE AT THE
CLINICAL SITES.
AB TEN FIFTY ONE WOULD PERMIT
PART TIME CLINICAL NURSING
FACULTY TO BE EMPLOYED BY ANY
ONE COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
FOR UP TO FOUR SEMESTERS OR SIX
QUARTERS ALLOWING COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ACROSS THE STATE. TO
SERVE AT LEAST THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY ONE ADDITIONAL STUDENTS
PER YEAR IN NURSING PROGRAMS AND
ENCOURAGING THE HIRING OF
PRACTICING LICENSE NURSES WHO
WILL BRING VALUABLE AND RELEVANT
REAL WORLD EXPERIENCE TO THE
EDUCATIONAL ENVIRONMENT.
WITH ME TODAY IS ALLOWED TO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT JUSTIN
SALAS NICK LEGISLATIVE ALLEN
ANALYST FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
AND AUSTIN WEBSTER OUT
REPRESENTING SEVERAL COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
BOTTOM YOU CHECK TWO MINUTES.
A GOOD MORNING CHEN MEMBERS
JUSTIN SELLING COMBAT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
BOARD OF GOVERNORS THE SPONSOR
OF AB.
TEN FIFTY ONE A BY REMOVING THE
67% LOW CAP ON PART TIME NURSING
FACULTY.
THE SCENARIO THAT WAS DESCRIBED
BY THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHERE AN
INSTRUCTOR MUST BE REPLACED IN
THE MIDDLE OF A TERM WOULD BE
AVOIDED.
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE IT IS
DIFFICULT FOR AN INSTRUCTOR TO
PROPERLY EVALUATE THE STUDENT
THAT THEY HAVE NOT BEEN WITH
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THE
SEMESTER.
THIS MID TERM ON BOARDING IS
DISRUPTIVE TO THE INSTRUCTORS OF
THE STUDENTS AND THE CLINICAL
FACILITY THAT IS HOSTING THE
PROGRAM.
AB TEN FIFTY ONE IS ALSO NEEDED
BECAUSE OF THE DIFFICULTY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE NURSING
PROGRAMS HAVE IN FINDING FULL
TIME FACULTY. FOR EXAMPLE OVER
THE LAST TEN YEARS VENTURA
COLLEGE HAS HAD THREE TO FIVE ON
FIELD OPENINGS FOR FULL TIME
NURSING FACULTY.
RECENTLY THEY WERE FORCED TO
REDUCE EMISSIONS BY 20% AND
THEIR ASSOCIATES DEGREE OF
NURSING PROGRAMS.
IN THE EXEMPTION AND AB TEN
FIFTY ONE WOULD HAVE ALLOWED THE
COLLEGE TO ACCEPT IN THEIR
NORMAL THAT MISSION NUMBERS.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE NURSING
PROGRAMS ARE HIGH QUALITY AND
AFFORDABLE OPTIONS THAT PROVIDE
SOCIAL MOBILITY TO STUDENTS FROM
DIVERSE BACKGROUNDS FROM ALL
OVER CALIFORNIA.
AND AB TEN FIFTY ONE IS A
VALUABLE TOOL THAT DISTRICTS CAN
UTILIZE TO MAXIMIZE THE NUMBER
OF STUDENTS THE GENERAL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY.
THANK YOU CHAIR OF LATIN
SENATORS ALSO WEBSTER ON BEHALF
OF THE COAST COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT RANCHO SANTIAGO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT AND
THE ORANGE COUNTY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE LEGISLATIVE TASK FORCE.
WE JUST WANNA BRIEFLY LINER
COMMENTS WITH THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
TOOL FOR OUR PROGRAMS -- IT'S IN
SPECIALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE
THESE -- ABILITY TO BRING IN
THESE THESE GUYS PRACTITIONERS
ARE COMING IN AND ACTUALLY
HAVING THE HANDS ON EXPERIENCE --
AND THEN PREVENTING THESE
DISRUPTIONS AS MENTIONED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SMITH -- IMPROVE
STUDENT OUTCOMES AND JUST
GENERALLY IS -- THE BEST
PRACTICE THAT WE WANT TO HAVE
AVAILABLE FOR COLLEGES SO WE ARE
DRY VOTE.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
SEEING AND HEARING THAT WILL
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS.
DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
AS A BLOOM YOU MAY CLOSE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU THE BILL
HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR DORADO
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ITEM FIVE AB TEN FIFTY ONE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
LEAVE THE I WILL WILK AYE CHANGE --
ASAL LUNA SO I GLAZER PLEASE ARE
AYE MCGUIRE PAN.
THAT BILL ON CALL A AND NOW I
THINK YOU HAVE AB.
SEVENTEEN TWENTY NINE PROS
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU AGAIN MADAM CHAIR AND
HELLO MEMBERS.
DUAL ENROLLMENT PROGRAMS
PARTICULARLY THOSE WHICH TAKE
PLACE ON HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTION CAMPUSES HAVE SHOWN
TO BE EXCELLENT TOOLS FOR
ENCOURAGING COLLEGE READINESS.
PARTICIPATING STUDENTS ARE MORE
LIKELY TO COMPLETE COLLEGE THAN
THEIR NON PARTICIPATING PEERS.
AND CONCURRENT ENROLLMENT HAS
PROVEN PARTICULARLY EFFECTIVE
FOR YOUNG MEN OF COLOR LOW
INCOME STUDENTS AND FIRST
GENERATION STUDENTS.
NOT ONLY GAIN VALUABLE CAREER
SKILLS OR EARNED GENERAL
EDUCATION UNITS THAT CAN
TRANSFER TO A FOUR YEAR
UNIVERSITY BUT THEY ALSO LEARNED
THEY CAN BE SUCCESSFUL IN
COLLEGE.
THIS GIVES THEM THE CONFIDENCE
TO CONTINUE WITH COLLEGE AFTER
HIGH SCHOOL AND PUTS THEM ON A
PATH TOWARD ACHIEVING THEIR
ACADEMIC GOALS.
SUMMER IS THE IDEAL TIME FOR
STUDENTS TO PARTICIPATE IN DUAL
ENROLLMENT PROGRAMS AS STUDENTS
ARE FREE OF THE RESPONSIBILITIES
AND WORKLOAD THAT COME WITH THE
REGULAR ACADEMIC YEAR.
HOWEVER CURRENT LAW LIMITS THE
NUMBER OF HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
WHO CAN ENROLL IN SUMMER COURSES
AT OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
ONLY 5% OF STUDENTS PER GRADE
LEVEL PER SCHOOL ARE PERMITTED
TO ENROLL IN THESE PROGRAMS.
AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY NINE EXPANDS
COLLEGE ACCESS FOR HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS DURING THE SUMMER BY
REMOVING THAT 5% CAP FOR
STUDENTS WHO ENROLL IN GENERAL
EDUCATION COURSES THAT TRANSFER
TO A FOUR YEAR UNIVERSITY OR A
CAREER PATHWAY.
THIS BELIEVES IN PLACE
RESTRICTIONS ON PHYSICAL
EDUCATION COURSES AND COURSES
DURING THE REGULAR ACADEMIC YEAR.
AND WITH ME TODAY AS A WITNESS
IN SUPPORT IS ERIC HARNISCH FROM
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT A COLLEGE OF THE
CANYONS IN SANTA CLARITA.
THANK YOU WELCOME.
I'M SHOULD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY IN SUPPORT OF AB --
SEVENTEEN TWENTY NINE WHICH
PROMISES TO HELP MORE HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS FIND THAT THEY
HAVE A PLACE IN COLLEGE.
THERE ARE COLLEGE MORE THAN A
THOUSAND HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
GET A JUMP START.
ON COLLEGE EACH YEAR -- BY
TAKING CLASSES AT COLLEGE OF THE
CANYONS.
THEY NOT ONLY GAIN VALUABLE
CAREER SKILLS WERE GENERAL
EDUCATION UNITS A CAN TRANSFER
TO A FOUR YEAR UNIVERSITY.
BUT THEY ALSO LEARN THEY CAN BE
SUCCESSFUL IN COLLEGE.
THIS GIVES THEM THE CONFIDENCE
TO CONTINUE WITH COLLEGE AFTER
HIGH SCHOOL AND PUT THEM ON A
PATH TOWARD ACHIEVING THEIR
ACADEMIC GOALS.
AND THEY SUCCEED ACADEMICALLY
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS REGULARLY
OUTPERFORM THE COLLEGE AGE
STUDENTS AND THEY'RE SITTING
NEXT TO IN THEIR CLASSES.
AS OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM
CONTINUES.
TO IT'S EFFORTS TO MEET THE
AMBITIOUS VISION FOR SUCCESS
GOALS OF INCREASING DEGREES AND
CERTIFICATES TRANSFERRING MORE
STUDENTS TO FOUR YEAR
UNIVERSITIES AND HELPING MORE
STUDENTS SUCCESSFULLY MOVED FROM
CLASSROOMS TO CAREERS.
THESE ARE THE KINDS OF
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE NEED TO
CREATE.
AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY NINE OFFERS
MORE FLEXIBILITY FOR STUDENTS
GIVING THEM THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ENROLL IN ALMOST ANY COURSE A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE OFFERS DURING
THE SUMMER.
AS THE SUMMER WOMAN SAID SUMMER
IS THE IDEAL TIME FOR HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS TO ENROLL.
AND AS THEY ARE FREE THE
RESPONSIBILITIES IN WORKLOAD THE
COME WITH THE REGULAR ACADEMIC
YEAR.
MOREOVER THEY TAKE THE CLASSES
AT THE COLLEGE CAMPUS GIVING
THEM A CHANCE TO EXPERIENCE
CAMPUS LIFE.
MAKE USE OF AVAILABLE SUPPORT
RESOURCES LIKE FREE TUTORING AND
LEARN THEY CAN INDEED BE
SUCCESSFUL IN COLLEGE.
THIS IS WHAT PERRANCE TELLS THAT
THEY WANT FOR THEIR STUDENTS
WHEN WE SURVEYED PARENTS OF
ELEVENTH AND TWELFTH GRADERS
RECENTLY. 88% OF THEM EXPRESSED
INTEREST IN THEIR SUDENTS
TAKING CLASSES AT COLLEGE OF THE
CANYONS.
AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY NINE WOULD
ALLOW MORE THAN TO DO JUST THAT.
SO I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
GROWING WE HAVE FOR THE
WONDERFUL COMPANY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CENTER GLAZER --
YES ASSEMBLY WOMAN -- I WANT TO
COMMEND YOU ON THIS BILL I THINK
IT'S A FANTASTIC BILL I I THINK
WE CREATE ALL THESE --
BUREAUCRACIES THAT PREVENT --
OUR EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM FOR
TREATING KIDS AS THEY ARE ABLE
TO AND TO MATCH THEIR CAPACITY.
AND THERE'S SO MANY THINGS ABOUT
THIS BILL AND THE OPPORTUNITY
THAT IT MAY PROVIDE TO STUDENTS
THAT'S JUST ABSOLUTELY WONDERFUL
I KNOW YOU HAD THE WONDERFUL
COMPANY SPEAK UP A MOMENT AGO.
INSPIRED MY WONDERFUL IN THIS --
IF THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY DOWN
THE ROAD IF YOU EVER AMEND THE
BUILD UP TO BE A CO AUTHOR THANK
YOU AND HAPPY TO MOVE IT CHEERS
REQUEST.
THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
WHICH I TO CLOSE CERTAINLY I AM
THINKING SENATORS FOR YOUR TIME
AND I HAVE THE THE PRIVILEGE OF
REPRESENTING COLLEGE OF THE
CANYONS ALONG WITH US SENATOR
WILK AND WE'VE SEEN IN OUR OWN
COMMUNITIES HOW OFTEN STUDENTS --
OF EVERY TYPE AND EVERY GRADE
LEVEL TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THIS
DURING HIGH SCHOOL WHEN THEY
CANNOT PRESENTS A TREMENDOUS
OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM TO KIND OF
DIP THEIR FEET IN THE COLLEGE
EXPERIENCE. TO TEST OUT THEIR
LEVEL OF INTEREST IN IN
DIFFERENT COURSE WORK AND IT'S A
TREMENDOUS SAVINGS TO THE
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES WHEN
THEY'RE ABLE TO DO THIS IN A AND
A WONDERFUL OPPORTUNITY SO.
I APPRECIATE YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE BILL HAS
BEEN MOVED BY CENTER GLAZER
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ITEM EIGHTEEN AB SEVENTEEN
TWENTY NINE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE WILK WILK I CHANGED
WOULD ASAL LUNA SO I GLAZERS
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE PAN.
BELIEVE THAT BELONG CALL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT -- WE
ARE GOING IN FILE ITEM ORDER --
DOCTOR WEBER SHE IS FILE ITEM
TWELVE AB.
FOURTEEN SIXTY BEGIN WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY THANK YOU WELCOME
GOOD MORNING AND TO MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THE I'M HERE TODAY
TO PRESENT TO YOU AB.
FOURTEEN SIXTY THE C. ISSUE
EDUCATES THE MOST ETHNICALLY
DIVERSE STUDENT BODY IN THE
NATION.
AND THAT DIVERSITY SHOULD BE
CELEBRATED BY INSTITUTIONALIZING
A CURRICULUM THAT IS RELEVANT.
INCLUSIVE AND REFLECTIVE OF THE
STUDENT CULTURES AND BACKGROUNDS
THEY SERVE. FIFTY YEARS AGO THE
C. ISSUE BECAME THE BIRTHPLACE
OF MODERN ETHNIC STUDIES.
AND ALMOST ALL OF ITS CAMPUSES
ALREADY MAINTAIN SOME LEVEL OF
ETHNIC STUDIES ON THEM.
ETHNIC STUDIES SCHOLARSHIP
FOCUSES ON THE CENTRAL ROLE THAT
RACE AND ETHNICITY PLAY.
IN THE CONSTRUCTION OF AMERICAN
HISTORY CULTURE AND SOCIETY.
ETHNIC STUDIES FEELS IN THE THE
KNOWLEDGE GAP AND CORRECT
INTENTIONAL.
MISREPRESENTATION OF PEOPLE OF
COLOR.
AND THEIR HISTORIES
CONTRIBUTIONS AND EXPERIENCES.
STUDIES HAVE FOUND THAT BOTH
STUDENTS OF COLOR AND WHITE
STUDENTS BENEFIT ACADEMICALLY
AND SOCIALLY.
FROM TAKING ETHNIC STUDIES
COURSES.
ETHNIC STUDIES COURSES
CONTRIBUTE TO IMPROVE GRADUATION
RATES POSITIVE CAMPUS CLIMATE
OUTCOMES AND ARE VITAL TO A
STUDENT SUCCESS BEYOND COLLEGE
IN AN INCREASINGLY DIVERSE
WORKFORCE AND SOCIETY.
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
CHANCES OFFICE LAUNCH THE TASK
FORCE.
ON THE ADVANCEMENT OF ETHNIC
STUDIES COMPRISED OF FACULTY
DEPARTMENT CHAIRS PROGRAM
DIRECTORS COORDINATORS DEAN'S
ACADEMIC SENATE CHEERS AND
PRESIDENT'S THROUGHOUT THE CSU
SYSTEM.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THE NUMBER ONE
RECOMMENDATION OF THAT TASK
FORCE.
THAT DOUBT FINAL REPORT WAS TO
MAKE ETHNIC STUDIES A GENERAL
EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS
THROUGHOUT THE CSU SYSTEM.
AB FOURTEEN SIXTY CODIFIES A
NUMBER ONE RECOMMENDATION OF THE
C. ISSUE TASK FORCE REPORT.
AB FOURTEEN SIXTY WOULD HAVE THE
CSU TAKE UP THE TORCH TO
SYSTEMATICALLY LIVE UP TO ITS
MISSION WHICH IS TO PREPARE
STUDENTS FOR YOU INTERNATIONAL.
MULTI CULTURAL SOCIETY.
BY INCLUDING THE COMPLETION OF
AN ETHNIC STUDIES COURSE AS A
GRADUATION REQUIREMENT.
AB FOURTEEN SIXTY IN SECTION TO
SEE ANDY DIRECTS THE ACADEMIC
SENATE TO WORK WITH THE CSU
CHANCE COUNCIL ETHNIC STUDIES.
TO DEVELOP AND IMPROVE AND
APPROVE CORE COMPETENCIES TO BE
ACHIEVED BY STUDENTS TAKING AN
ETHNIC STUDIES COURSE.
THIS MEANS FACULTY WOULD BE IN
CHARGE L. OF AND WOULD DETERMINE
WHAT COURSES COUNT TOWARD THAT
WITH THIS REQUIREMENT.
AND NOT THE LEGISLATURE.
THIS BILL IS STRUCTURED IN A WAY
THAT THE ETHNIC STUDIES
REQUIREMENT MUST BE COMPLETE
IMPLEMENTED WITHIN THE EXISTING
NUMBER OF UNITS REQUIRED TO
GRADUATE FROM THE UNIVERSITY.
THEREFORE TIME TO DEGREE IS NOT
IMPEDED ON IT EITHER.
IN ADDITION AN ETHNIC STUDIES
COURSE COULD EASILY DOUBLE COUNT
FOR MULTIPLE REQUIREMENTS AND IF
A STUDENT TOOK IN ETHNIC STUDIES
COURSE AT A COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
THE REQUIREMENT WOULD BE FULFILL.
THIS BILL DOES NOT PRESCRIBED
CURRICULUM COAST CONTENT OR
STUDENT LEARNING OUTCOMES.
NOR DOES THIS BILL LIMIT FACULTY
MEMBERS A STUDENT'S ABILITY TO
ENGAGE IN INTELLECTUAL DEBATE AT
ALL.
AND THEREFORE DOES NOT INFRINGE
ON ACADEMIC FREEDOM.
IT SHOULD ALSO BE NOTED THAT THE
C. ISSUE ALREADY HAS COURSE
REQUIREMENTS SUCH AS THE
AMERICAN INSTITUTION
REQUIREMENTS.
THE FLEXIBILITY GIVEN IN THIS
BILL ALLOWS FOR EASY
IMPLEMENTATION FOR EACH
INDIVIDUAL CAMPUS.
DIFFERENT CAMPUSES HAVE
DIFFERENT WAYS OF CREDITING
CROSS LISTED COURSES.
AS LONG AS OF COURSE HAS A CORE
COMPETENCIES DETERMINED BY
FACULTY.
THEN THE REQUIREMENT WOULD BE
FULFILL.
LESLIE A. B. FOURTEEN CITY BUILT
ON THE INTRODUCTORY KNOWLEDGE
STUDENTS WILL RECEIVE AT THE
SECONDARY COLLEGE LEVEL AND IT
WILL MOST LIKELY BE CSU
GRADUATES TEACHING ETHNIC
STUDIES COURSES IN THE K. TO
TWELVE LEVEL.
I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THE FACT
THAT THIS BILL IS SUPPORTED BY
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION.
AND SUPPORTED BY A MULTITUDE OF
CAMPUS DEPARTMENTS STUDENT
ORGANIZATION CIVIL RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS AND LABOR GROUPS
OUT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I WON ALSO EMPHASIZE THE FACT
THAT FOR FORTY YEARS I CHAIRED
I'VE FOUND IT AND SHARED AT
ADMINISTER THE ETHNIC STUDIES
DEPARTMENT AFRICANA STUDIES
DEPARTMENT AT SAN DIEGO STATE
UNIVERSITY.
ADDITIONALLY FOR SIX YEARS I
CHEERED I WAS PRESIDENT OF THE
NATIONAL COUNCIL FOR BLACK
STUDIES THE NATIONAL
ORGANIZATION OF ETHNIC STUDIES.
AND SO I COULD BRING TO YOU A
WEALTH OF EXPERIENCE AND
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW THE
UNIVERSITY WORKS.
AND HOW IT DOESN'T WORK.
AND THE THINGS THAT HAVE TO
HAPPEN IN ORDER TO MOVE FORWARD.
WITH ME TODAY TO SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF FOURTEEN SIXTY IS ROSS OUT.
ROCKY -- RIVERA MARIE MARIE ALL
BLACK OF WHO'S A RECENT CSU
NORTHRIDGE CHICANO STUDIES
GRADUATE.
AND KENNETH MONTERO THE FORMER
DEAN OF THE COLLEGE OF THE THE
ONLY BECAUSE IT WE HAVE A ETHNIC
STUDIES IN THE NATION BUT HE IS
A FORMER DEAN OF THE COLLEGE OF
ETHNIC STUDIES AT SAN FRANCISCO
STATE UNIVERSITY.
I WELCOME TO BE HERE TODAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU SOMEONE MEMBER
WHATEVER WELCOME TO YOU EACH
HAVE TWO MINUTES.
GOOD MORNING TERRY LEYVA AND SET
EDUCATION COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
ROSY ONLY MINIMALLY -- AND I
GRADUATED A COUPLE WEEKS AGO
FROM CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
NORTHRIDGE WITH A DOUBLE MAJOR
IN SOCIOLOGY AND SHE GOT A
CHICANO STUDIES. FIVE YEARS AGO
I WAS A HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT
ORGANIZING TO TO MAKE ETHNIC
STUDIES IN A THROUGH G.
REQUIREMENT AND ELLIE U. S. D..
FIVE YEARS LATER STUDENTS ARE
FIGHTING THE SAME BATTLE TO PASS
AB FOURTEEN SIXTY AND MAKE
ETHNIC STUDIES A REQUIREMENT
ACROSS THE TWENTY THREE CSU
CAMPUSES.
WITHOUT ETHNIC STUDIES I WOULD
HAVE NOT GRADUATED WITH A
RESEARCH ASSISTANTSHIP.
PROVIDED THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PUBLISHED IN A PEER REVIEWED
JOURNAL PRESENTED OUT FIVE
NATIONAL CONFERENCES AND
ORGANIZE ALONGSIDE MY COMMUNITY.
I AM ONE AMONG THOUSANDS OF
STUDENTS TO TESTIFY ABOUT THE
WAYS THE ETHNIC STUDIES CHANGE
MY LIFE IN POSITIVE WAYS THAT I
NEVER ANTICIPATED.
IN FALL TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND
FALL TWENTY EIGHTEEN FOR EXAMPLE
THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS MOBILIZED
WALKED OUT AND BOYCOTTED.
AGAINST THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
EXECUTIVE ORDERS ELEVEN HUNDRED
AND ELEVEN HUNDRED ARE MANDATED
BY CSU CHANCER TIMOTHY WHITE
MEAT THEY'LL BLANCO.
IN THE WAKE IN THE WAKE OF THE
FIFTIETH YEAR ANNIVERSARY OF
ETHNIC STUDIES STUDENTS IN THE
CS YOU FIND IT EVEN MORE
COMPELLING TO MAKE ETHNIC
STUDIES A REQUIREMENT.
ETHNIC STUDIES IS A POWERFUL AND
INNOVATIVE INTERDISCIPLINARY
FIELD THAT TACKLES ISSUES
RANGING FROM IMMIGRATION
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
INCARCERATION LABOR GENDER
RIGHTS AND SEXUALITY.
IN WAYS THE TRADITIONAL
DISCIPLINES SIMPLY CANNOT.
UNDER TITLE FIVE MANDATE THE CSU
IS ALREADY LEGALLY MANDATED TO
TEACH AMERICAN INSTITUTIONS FOR
EXAMPLE CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUES.
TITLE FIVE DOES NOT MEET THE
NEEDS OF STUDENTS WHO COME FROM
HISTORICALLY DISENFRANCHISED
BACKGROUNDS LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND FIRST GENERATION.
I NOTHING STUDIES REQUIREMENT IN
THE CSU ABROAD IN THE CURRICULUM
TO EMPOWER FACULTY AND STUDENTS
TO MAKE CURRICULUM DECISIONS
THAT ARE INNOVATIVE
GROUNDBREAKING AND
TRANSFORMATIVE SO THAT STUDENTS
CAN SUCCEED IN THE CSU SYSTEM.
AB FOURTEEN SIXTY IS NEEDED TO
PROTECT THE RIGHT FOR ETHNIC
STUDIES TO EXIST.
IN FALL TWENTY SEVENTEEN CSU
PRESIDENT DIANNE HARRISON
PROMISED TO MAKE ETHNIC STUDIES
A REQUIREMENT ACROSS THE CSU.
CLOSED DOORS ADMINISTRATORS LIE
ABOUT THEIR SUPPORT FOR ETHNIC
STUDIES HOWEVER ADMINISTRATORS
RARELY TAKE THE RISK OF A
HOLDING THE INTEGRITY THAT
ETHNIC STUDIES.
DESERVES.
THIS IS THE ONLY FIELD OF
KNOWLEDGE THAT WAS CREATED BY
COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND ACTIVISTS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK ALL OF YOU TO
PLEASE VOTE IN FAVOR OF AB
FOURTEEN SIXTY AND THE ENTRANCE
OF EDUCATIONAL EQUITY.
DIVERSE CITY AND CALIFORNIA'S
FUTURE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
LEYVA AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M
COULD PROFESSOR KENNETH MONTERO
LEAD OFFICE OF OVER TWO HUNDRED
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY AT THE STUDIES
COUNCIL.
AND CHOSEN BY THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATIONS BECOME
THEIR BEHALF AS WELL SO I THINK
EVERY TIME HARD WORKING
ENCOURAGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
POTENTIALLY HISTORIC LEGISLATION.
FOR BREVITY WILL HIGHLIGHT TWO
THEMES FIRST ONLY A COUPLE
SELECT EXAMPLES. FOR TENS SECOND
SELECT A COUPLE OF MYTH IN
OPPOSITION.
ARGUMENT FIRST IT IS UNTHINKABLE
THAT IN EDUCATION EDUCATED
PERSON IN THE MULTI ETHNIC
MULTICULTURAL GLOBAL.
GLOBAL CONNECTED TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY ONLY STUDIES ONE
INTELLECTUAL AND CULTURAL
TRADITION THE UNIVERSITY.
EPIC STUDIES PROVIDE THAT ADDED
VALUE [inaudible] TO AS
MENTIONED EARLIER STRUGGLE CHAU
QUICKLY ON IT RESEARCH
DEMONSTRATES NUMEROUS ADDITIONAL
VALUES FOR ETHNIC STUDIES
INCLUDING AND UP 220% INCREASE
IN GRADUATION RATES FOR COLLEGE
STUDENTS TO SUCCEED.
IN AT LEAST ONE COURSE NO MATTER
THE MAJOR YES THAT'S A 20%
INCREASE AND ANY MAJOR SITES
BUSINESS.
MYTH ONE AB ONE OF ONE FOUR SIX
OO IS DESCRIBED AS UNPRECEDENTED
IN VIOLATES PRINCIPLES OF SHARED
GOVERNANCE AND ACADEMIC FREEDOM.
SHARED GOVERNANCE IS BESTOWED BY
THIS AUGUST BODY AND THE
LEGISLATURE JUDICIOUSLY.
ALREADY REGULATES GENERAL
EDUCATION OF THE GRADUATION
REQUIREMENTS AS APPROPRIATE AND
NECESSARY PROFESSES NO ECONOMIC
FREEDOM IS NOT ACADEMIC LICENSE
WE ARE FREE TO EXPRESS HOW WE
TEACH WITH AN ESTABLISHED
PROFESSIONAL PARAMETERS.
SET BY LEGISLATURE THIS BILL
SIMPLY REQUIRES THAT WE OFFER
THIS FACULTY CREATED CURRICULUM
WITH PROVEN ACADEMIC BENEFIT TO
ALL AS RECOMMENDED IN THE CSU
CHANCES BLUE RIBBON TASK FORCE
SEVERAL YEARS AGO.
MYTH TO THOUGH CUSTOMARILY THEY
WOULD ADMINISTRATIVE LEADERSHIP
DID NOT CONSULT THE ETHNIC
STUDIES FACULTY BEFORE SPEAKING
ON OUR BEHALF REGARDING ACADEMIC
FREEDOM OF SHARED GOVERNANCE OR
ON THE RECENT CURRICULA
EXECUTIVE.
ORDERS AND MATH THREE BY -- AS
INDICATED BY JOINT LETTER
SUBMITTED BY ETHNIC STUDIES AND
WOMEN'S STUDIES DEPARTMENT SHOES
JOINTLY IF YOU TO CLAIM THAT
THIS BILL WOULD.
ETHNIC STUDIES AGAINST OUR
COLLEAGUES TO THE CONTRARY THE
SUPPORTED.
SO I ENCOURAGE YOU TO CORRECT
THE DECISION FIFTY YEARS AGO
WHEN THE GOVERNOR LEGISLATOR AND
SEE ISSUE LEADERSHIP SECURE
THEIR PERMANENT PLACE ON THE
WRONG SIDE OF HISTORY.
AND TO TAKE AN IMPORTANT STEP
TOWARDS INVITING ALL PARTIES TO
THE CORRECT SIDE OF HISTORY
SHAPING A BETTER FUTURE FOR ALL
WE APPRECIATE YOUR TIME ON THIS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
ASHLEY WALKER WITH NASA MEN ON
BEHALF OF THE MODERATE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT.
MARTHA SERRA GOES A TIAS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
BILINGUAL EDUCATION AND WE ARE
IN SUPPORT.
MUCH OF THE SQUAD ASSOCIATE
PROFESSOR AND YOU'RE GONNA TO
KIND OF STUDIES THAT CAL STATE
NORTHRIDGE.
FIRST GENERATION STUDENTS WHO
GRADUATED FROM COLLEGE AND WENT
ON TO GET A PHD BECAUSE ABOUT
THINK STUDIES IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MARIO GUERRERO BE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
AN ADJUNCT FACULTY AT SACRAMENTO
STATE OF THE POLITICAL SCIENCE
DEPARTMENT SUPPORT.
CAN REALLY RESONATE WITH SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
RESERVING TALK ON BEHALF OF FOR
THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF UNITED
LATIN AMERICAN CITIZENS A CIVIL
RIGHTS ORGANIZATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
STEPHEN FILLING FACULTY MEMBERS
CSU STANISLAUS AND ADVOCATE FOR
ACADEMIC FREEDOM IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
I HAVE A CONTRAST SOCIAL WORKER
SEXTET ALUMNI IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MELISSA MARINO FORMER CSU
FACULTY AND CURRENT -- CHAIR OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ETHNIC STUDIES
PROGRAM AND I STRONGLY ASK YOU
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MERRY ROVE PROFESSOR OF ETHNIC
STUDIES CSU STANCE TO AID IN
STRONG SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF THE
ENTIRE ETHNIC STUDIES DEPARTMENT
AND SEE IF YOU STAND STATE.
AND NOT ONLY DO I BELIEVE THAT
THIS BILL WILL NOT INFRINGE UPON
ACADEMIC FREEDOM BUT IT WILL
ACTUALLY OPEN UP CROSS
DEPARTMENT NAME IN SUPPORT ONLY
PLAYS SO ABERRATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IF OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT JUST YOUR NAME AND
SUPPORT OF THE BILL PLEASE.
ALRIGHT LE LISA L'OREAL --
STUDENT AT SACRAMENTO CITY
COLLEGE AND ALSO ORGANIZER WITH
STILL HERE COLLECTIVE A
TRANSGENDER ORGANIZING
COLLECTIVE.
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT I
SUPPORT EXPECTS THAT IS TO BE
PASSED BECAUSE I WANT EDUCATION
FOR MY PERSPECTIVE FIRM NAME AND
ORGANIZATION AND IF YOU SUPPORT
THE BILL PLEASE I SUPPORT THE
BILL THANK YOU THE NEXT WITNESS.
DOMINIQUE WILLIAM SACRAMENTO
CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT I
GRADUATED FROM THE CSU AND NOW
TEACH ETHNIC STUDIES AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
OKAY PARTICULAR JUNIOR TRUSTEE
FOR THE OAK GROVE SCHOOL
DISTRICT CHOOL BOARD -- ETHNIC
STUDIES TEACHER AS WELL AND ON
BEHALF OF THE ETHNIC STUDIES NOW
COALITION WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
CHRIS RESPONSE OF THE CHAIR OF
THE COLLEGE FOR MINIMUM RIGHTS
AND ALSO AS A STUDENT OF I THINK
STUDIES AT CSU SADAT'S A STRONG
SUPPORT.
WICHITA'S WITH CALIFORNIA JIM
NETWORK AND SUPPORT.
MANUAL BUT I CUTS PROFESSOR THIS
WAS UTOPIA AFFECT STATE CHAIR OF
FORT. FOR THE CENTER ON RACE
IMMIGRATION SUCH ASSISTANCE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
KIM DRUM PROFESSOR OF POLITICAL
SCIENCE AT CAL STATE EAST BAY.
I'M ON BEHALF OF MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES WILL STRONG SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
THEY ALLOW UNDER COLLEGE OF
EDUCATION SACRAMENTO STATE
UNIVERSITY STRONG SUPPORT.
YEAH NOW THAT RATHER A SPIRE IN
PROFESSOR AND ETHNIC STUDIES IN
STRONG SUPPORT PLEASE MAKE MY
FUTURE HAPPEN.
TIFFANY CHAT ON BEHALF OF
SOUTHEAST ASIA RESOURCE ACTION
CENTER IS STRONG SUPPORTER.
JULIE SUNDRIES FROM METERS
STUDENT AT CSU STANISLAUS DOUBLE
MAJORING IN ETHNIC STUDIES AND
POLITICAL SCIENCE CULTURE OF
MATCHA.
AND OF OUR CHAPTER AND OF OUR
REGIONAL -- US COMMITTEE IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
HI I'M DAVE KOHLER KIND CHAIR
AND PROFESSOR IN THE DEPARTMENT
OF POLITICAL SCIENCE AND PUBLIC
ADMINISTRATION AND CAL STATE
STANISLAW.
I AM ALSO THE CHAPTER PRESIDENT
CALIFORNIA FACTLY ASSOCIATION
FACTLY WRITES THAT BUT ADVOCATE.
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME IS AND STRONG ON THE
CHAIR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIOLOGY GENDER STUDIES.
AND GERONTOLOGY.
AND I AM REPRESENTING AN AMAZING
GROUP OF HUMAN BEINGS AND IN
SUPPORT OF MY COLLEAGUES AND MY
STUDENTS I STAND HERE BEFORE YOU.
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THE MORNING PRESTON RUDY
SOCIOLOGY PROFESSOR AT SAN JOSE
STATE GRADUATE OF UC DAVIS THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING TENANTS RODRIGUEZ
FAX STATE ALARM AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
IT ALSO MY MOST POLITICAL
SCIENCE STUDENT AT SACRAMENTO
STATE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MARGOT RENALDO POLITICAL SCIENCE
STUDENT AT SACRAMENTO STATE IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
DR ROBBINS JEWEL CAMACHO I'M
HERE FOR THIS SUPPORT BY.
JESSICA LAWLESS FORMA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE GENDER STUDIES PROFESSOR
HIS COURSES ACROSS LISTED WITH
ETHNIC STUDIES AND NOW
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
TESCO WILSON'S ACKERMAN IS A
GRADUATE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
IF YOU COULD BASS MODESTO JUNIOR
COLLEGE WOMEN OF COLOR WHO WANTS
TO SEE HERSELF REFLECTED IN HER
STUDIES AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THEM TO MCFADDEN FROM SAYS OUR
STATE -- DOUBLE MAJOR AND I
THINK STUDIES IN BUSINESS ON I'M
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
DAVID SELBY DEPARTMENT OF
POLITICAL SCIENCE ISSUE
SACRAMENTO I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MARLIN JONES PROFESSOR CAL SAY
SACRAMENTO STRONG SUPPORT.
RENTERIA'S KRAVITZ DEAN EMERITUS
FROM SAKS CITY COLLEGE ALSO
ALUMNO CS US AND FORMER FACULTY
MEMBER CSU US AND SEE VOLUMES
THAT IMMIGRANT RIGHTS GROUPS AND
WE ARE IT'S STRONG SUPPORT.
LV ALLOWS STUDENT AT CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY STANISLAUS --
ETHNIC STUDIES MAJOR PRESIDENT
OF YOU SEND DID YOUR STUDENTS
AND ACTIVISM IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
HELLO BOB DR REVEREND MINISTER
CIVIL RIGHTS AND HUMAN RIGHTS
SOME STRONG SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
CAN WE GO FROM THE ADDRESSES
COALITION WILL HAVE A HIGH
SCHOOL FREELY HIGH SCHOOL IN
STRONG SUPPORT IT'S ONE OF THE
ONLY REASONS OUR STUDENTS COME
TO SCHOOL.
ROSARIO THOMAS WITH THE JUSTICE
COALITION IS STRONG SUPPORT.
IRVING OUR THESE YOUTH JUSTICE
COALITION BROTHERS ON THEMSELVES
COALITION STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
COME ON UP THEIR SEATS AT THE
TABLE. TWO WITNESSES TWO MINUTES
EACH BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
MY NAME IS KATHERINE NELSON I'M
CHAIR OF THE ACADEMIC SENATE OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE WITH YOU
THIS MORNING.
WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB.
FOURTEEN SIXTY THE ACADEMIC
SENATE CSU IS THE
INSTITUTIONALLY AND LEGALLY
RECOGNIZED VOICE OF THE CSU
FACULTY IN MATTERS OF SYSTEM
WIDE ACADEMIC CONCERNS.
INCLUDING CURRICULUM AND
GRADUATION REQUIREMENTS.
YOU'VE HEARD A VERY POWERFUL
CASE FOR THE IMPACT OF ETHNIC
STUDIES ON OUR STUDENTS.
CASE WITH WHICH WE AGREE HOWEVER
WE DO NOT BELIEVE THAT A
LEGISLATIVELY MANDATED
GRADUATION REQUIREMENT IS AN
APPROPRIATE MEANS.
OF ACCOMPLISHING THE ENDS
EMBODIED IN THE LEGISLATION.
FACULTY HAVE THE EXPERTISE AND
EXPERIENCE TO JUDGE THE
APPROPRIATE REQUIREMENTS FOR A
UNIVERSITY DEGREE.
LEGISLATIVE INVOLVEMENT
SUBSTITUTES THE GOVERNMENT'S
AGENDA FOR THAT EXPERTISE AS THE
BASIS FOR CURRICULAR DECISIONS.
THE POTENTIAL RIPPLE EFFECTS OF
THE BILL DESERVE CONSIDERATION
AS WELL.
GIVEN THE C. ISSUES HUNDRED AND
TWENTY UNIT LIMIT ON
UNDERGRADUATE DEGREES THE
ADDITIONAL THREE UNIT GRADUATION
REQUIREMENT HAS THE POTENTIAL.
TO ALTERNATE MAJOR REQUIREMENTS
ESPECIALLY IN HIGH UNIT MAJORS
ALREADY PRESSED TO MEET
ACCREDITATION AND GENERAL
EDUCATION.
REQUIREMENTS SIMULTANEOUSLY.
IN ADDITION THE WAY THE
REQUIREMENT IS CONSTRUCTED.
POSES POTENTIAL CHALLENGES FOR
THE NUMBER OF OPTIONS STUDENTS
HAVE FOR SATISFYING GENERAL
EDUCATION CULTURAL STUDIES
REQUIREMENTS AND FOR DOUBLE
COUNTING IN MAJORS AND MINORS.
THAT INVOLVE COURSES FROM THE
MULTIPLE ETHNIC STUDIES
DEPARTMENTS.
THE START DATE OF FALL TWO THAT
DIED TWENTY TWENTY IS ALSO
INSUFFICIENT TIME TO PREPARE FOR
IMPLEMENTATION.
CSU COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ARTICULATION AGREEMENTS LEARNING
OUTCOMES COURSE CERTIFICATION
AND CHANGES IN ACADEMIC PROGRAMS
ALL NEED TO BE THOROUGHLY VETTED
THROUGH APPROPRIATE CURRICULUM
REVIEW PROCESS SEES.
AND BECAUSE THE BILL CREATES AN
UNFUNDED MANDATE REDUCTIONS IN
OTHER PROGRAMS MAY BE NECESSARY
TO SORT THE BECAUSE OF
IMPLEMENTATION.
THIS COMMITTEE HAS A POLICY
REGARDING BILLS RELATING TO
CURRICULUM FRAMEWORKS AND MODEL
CURRICULA THAT STATES THAT SUCH
MEASURE SHOULD BE INTRODUCED
ONLY A MINUTE AFTER REMEMBER HAS
TRIED UNSUCCESSFULLY TO USE
ADMINISTRATIVE ROUTES.
TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE.
A PARALLEL EXISTS.
IN THIS CASE AS WELL.
ANY PROPOSAL FOR SYSTEM MY
GRADUATION REQUIREMENTS SHOULD
BE VETTED THROUGH ESTABLISHED
CSU SHARED GOVERNANCE PROCESSES.
OUR RESOLUTION AS THREE THREE
EIGHT ZERO CREATES THAT
ALTERNATIVE BY PROVIDING JUST
SUCH A SHARED GOVERNMENT
GOVERNANCE MECHANISM TO
RECOMMEND CSU ETHNIC STUDIES
CURRICULUM BASED ON THE ETHNIC
STUDIES TASK FORCE REPORT.
WE APPRECIATE THE INCREASED
FLEXIBILITY IN THE BILL
RESULTING FROM CLARIFICATION
FROM MEMBER WEBBER'S OFFICE
ABOUT WHICH COURSES SATISFY THE
REQUIREMENT AND THE AMENDMENT
THAT ESTABLISHES A MINIMUM THREE
UNIT REQUIREMENTS.
WE ALSO ARE VERY MUCH AWARE OF
THE HISTORY OF RACIALIZATION OF
THE PRINCIPLES OF ACADEMIC
FREEDOM AND FACULTY CONTROL OF
THE CURRICULUM.
AS MUCH AS WE APPRECIATE THESE
DEVELOPMENTS WE REMAIN OPPOSED
TO THE BILL.
THE USE OF GOVERNMENT POWER TO
MANDATE CURRICULUM IS QUITE
FRANKLY CHILLING NO MATTER HOW
WORTHY THE GOAL.
IF AB SIXTY FOURTEEN SIXTY
BECOMES LAW IT WOULD SET A
PRECEDENT FOR FUTURE CURRICULAR
MANDATES TO BE IMPOSED BY THE
LEGISLATURE.
SO WE URGE YOU TO SERIOUSLY
CONSIDER THE LONG TERM
IMPLICATIONS OF THE VOTE YOU ARE
ABOUT TO TAKE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD MORNING I'M LAUREN
BLANCHARD I SERVE AS EXECUTIVE
VICE CHANCELLOR FOR ACADEMIC AND
STUDENT AFFAIRS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
TODAY I I JOIN MY COLLEAGUE
CATHERINE NELSON IN OPPOSING
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN SIXTY
WHICH WOULD IN IN POLLS THE
COMPLETION OF A THREE UNIT
ETHNIC STUDIES COURSES A
GRADUATION REQUIREMENT. FOR ALL
STUDENTS.
LET ME BE CLEAR THAT OUR
CONCERNS REST NOT WITH THE VALUE
DERIVED IN BRINGING GREATER
AWARENESS AND UNDERSTANDING OF
THE HISTORICAL AND CONTEMPORARY
EXPERIENCES.
OF ETHNIC GROUPS IN OUR IN OUR
COUNTRY WE FULLY UNDERSTAND THE
ETHNIC AND RACIAL TENSIONS AND
INTOLERANCE THAT HAVE BEEN AND
EVEN TODAY ARE STILL TOO
PERVASIVE.
IN AMERICAN SOCIETIES WE ALSO
UNDERSTAND THAT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY IS THE
BIRTHPLACE OF ETHNIC STUDIES
FIRST ESTABLISHED AT SAN
FRANCISCO STATE UNIVERSITY IN.
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE AND AS A
RESULT OF THE ETHNIC STUDIES
TASK FORCE RECOMMENDATION A TASK
FORCE THAT WAS COMMISSIONED BY
CHANCE WERE WHITE. FOR YEARS TO
GROW AGO WE HAVE NOW SEEN FIRST
A 9% INCREASE IN ENROLLMENT IN
ETHNIC STUDIES COURSES.
THE ISSUE IS HIRED OVER SEVENTY
SEVENTY TWO FACULTY MEMBERS
STUDENT TENURE TRACK IN ETHNIC
STUDIES.
AND WE NOW HAVE 47% OF OUR CSU
GRADUATES COMPLETING AND ETHNIC
STUDIES COURSE IN ONE OF THE
FOUR COURSE AREAS PRESCRIBED IN
THE BILL.
LASTLY THE CSU CHANCELLOR WHITE
HAS MADE PROGRESS.
IN MAKING SURE THAT THE ETHNIC
STUDIES TASK FORCE
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE BEING FOR
FIELD AND HAS MADE A PART OF HIS
ANNUAL EVALUATION PROCESS WITH
THE PRESIDENT'S.
THE ISSUE IS THE MOST ETHNICALLY
ECONOMICALLY AND ACADEMICALLY
DIVERSE STUDENT BODY IN THE
UNITED STATES.
PART OF THE C. ISSUES MISSION IS
TO PREPARE STUDENTS TO LIVE AND
TO WORK IN A CULTURALLY DIVERSE
SOCIETY.
AND THIS MISSION IS TAKEN VERY
SERIOUSLY BY THE CSU WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT ETHNIC STUDIES COURSES
AND PROGRAMS IN THE CSU.
HOWEVER AS WAS JUST MENTIONED BY
DOCTOR NELSON THIS BILL WOULD
REPRESENT AN UNPRECEDENTED
LEGISLATIVELY DICTATED
CURRICULAR REQUIREMENT.
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE HAS
NEVER IMPOSED COURSE
REQUIREMENTS FOR CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY STUDENTS BEFORE.
THE BILL UNDERMINES THE PROCESS
OF SHARED GOVERNANCE AND
ACADEMIC FREEDOM SUCH A MANDATE
WILL SET THE DANGEROUS PRECEDENT
OF ALLOWING GOVERNMENTS TO
DETERMINE CURRICULAR AND
THREATENS THE ACADEMIC FREEDOM.
INHERENT IN COLLEGIATE EDUCATION
CSU FACULTY ARE HIRED FOR THEIR
DISCIPLINARY EXPERTISE.
THEY SHOULD BE RELIED ON TO
DEVELOP CURRICULAR THAT ARE
RESPONSIVE TO LOCAL COMMUNITIES
YOU'RE OUT OF TIME SO IF YOU CAN
WRAP IT UP PLEASE.
SECONDLY THIS BILL RUNS CONTRARY
TO THE WORK OF THE CSU WELL AS
POINT LARGELY DRIVEN BY THE
FACULTY TO FOCUS MORE ON
INCLUSIVE EXCELLENCE.
AND IMPLEMENT STRATEGIES THERE
WITHIN TO ADDRESS ACT EQUITY IN
OPPORTUNITY GAPS OF ALL EFFORT
UNDER REPRESENTED STUDENTS ARE
ARE DISENFRANCHISED STUDENTS
THAT WE SERVE.
SO UNLIKE THE RESTRICTIVE
LANGUAGE OF LANGUAGE IN A. B.
FOURTEEN SIXTY WHICH LIMITS US
TO FOUR DISCIPLINES OUR CAMPUS
IS REALLY HAVE INCLUDED A MORE
INCLUSIVE RANGE OF PERSPECTIVES.
INCLUDING WOMEN'S STUDIES GENDER
STUDIES RELIGIOUS STUDIES LGBT
Q. STUDIES WHICH THIS BILL WOULD
THEN ISOLATE THOSE PARTICULAR
COURSE.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER MET ANY
OTHER -- OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
[inaudible]
SIR.
HI DAVE SPEAKING I'M STILL THE
PROUD PARENT OF THREE WOMEN OF
COLOR BEAUTIFUL WOMEN OF COLOR
I'M ALSO FOUR TIMES OF THE CHAIR
OF THE ECONOMIC SENATE CAL POLY
POMONA.
AND I AM CURRENTLY CHAIR OF THE
FISCAL AND GOVERNMENTAL AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE OF THE SYSTEM MIGHT
SENATE BA A CSU.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL
THANK OU SIR ANY OTHER
OPPOSITION SEEING AND HEARING
THEN WE'LL COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE SENATOR ALSO.
YES -- THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO
THE AUTHOR -- I AM.
VERY PROUD OF YOU.
VERY PROUD OF AS A WOMAN OF
COLOR THAT YOU ARE MOVING THIS
FORWARD AND THAT YOU WON'T GIVE
UP ON IT.
I AM VERY EMBARRASSED.
THAT FORTY FIVE YEARS AGO WHEN I
WAS IN COLLEGE.
THAT I'M HEARING SIMILAR
EXPLANATION SIMILAR EXCUSES. FOR
NOT DOING WHAT THE EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEM OF THE STATE AND THIS
NATION SHOULD HAVE DONE.
WORDS LIKE HOWEVER NOT NOW I'LL
NEVER BEFORE -- THREATENS
ACADEMIC FREEDOM SHOULD DO THIS
SHOULD DO THAT. FORTY FIVE YEARS
AFTER I WAS IN COLLEGE.
WHAT IN THE BAREST MOMENT?
WHAT AN EMBARRASSMENT?
I EXPECT A WHOLE LOT MORE FROM
OUR EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM IN THIS
STATE.
AND TO THINK THAT WE ARE STILL.
AT OUR AGE STILL FIGHTING FOR
THE RECOGNITION OF STUDIES THAT
SHOULDN'T BE SEEN AS SOMETHING
THAT SEGREGATED AWAY FROM THE
REST OF OUR EDUCATION.
BUT SHOULD BE SEEN AS SOMETHING
SO INTEGRAL FILL HEALTHY FOR
EVERYBODY -- I'M I'M JUST
[inaudible]
SO SHOCKED.
OF I NEVER THOUGHT THAT AT THIS
POINT IN MY LIFE.
THAT THIS WOULD EVEN BE A
CONVERSATION OR A DEBATE -- AND
THERE ARE LOTS OF EXCUSES THAT
ARE DRUMMED UP. TO KEEP OUT OUR
PART OF HISTORY OUR PART OF WHAT.
ALL PEOPLE DO ANNA -- AT I JUST
THE IT'S QUITE.
A SURPRISE TO ME SO.
I AM A STRONG SUPPORTER -- AND I
GREATLY APPRECIATE YOUR
CONTINUED LEADERSHIP AND I WOULD
EXPECT.
NOTHING LESS THAN.
THIS FOR ALL.
THE YOUTH ALL THE STUDENTS WHO
ATTEND OUR HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS THANK YOU AND I
WILL BE PROUD TO MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU CENTER DORADO CENTER
GLAZER -- THANK YOU.
A DOCTOR WEBER YOU ARE TRULY A
TRAILBLAZER IN THIS AREA -- AT
YOUR LEADERSHIP AND AT EIGHT
EIGHT I'M A OBSERVER DID BEGAN
AT THE BEGINNING OF YOUR
PROFESSIONAL LIFE BECAUSE YOU
HAVEN'T REALLY DEVIATED FROM
THAT ALL THE THINGS THAT YOU
HAVE DONE AND AND LET ON AND
TAUGHT.
AND OF COURSE I WE SHARE SOME
HISTORY TOGETHER I WENT TO SAN
DIEGO STATE AND I A IT WASN'T A
REQUIREMENT THAT AND THAT I TOK
AT AN ATTIC STUDIES COURSE IN
MEXICAN AMERICAN STUDIES -- I
BRIEFLY ENROLLED IN -- DOCTOR
KARENGA ITS COURSE -- UNTIL MY
WORKLOAD GOT SO GREAT THAT I
COULDN'T CONTINUE BUT AND I TOOK
WITHIN STUDIES AND I THESE ROLE
CHOICES THAT I GOT TO MAKE AND I
WAS VERY MUCH IN RICH BY IT.
NO DOUBT ABOUT IT -- AND I AS
YOU I DON'T KNOW IF YOU WERE
HERE DURING THE EARLIER
CONVERSATION ON ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA IS BILL HEARD ON
TELEVISION VERY GOOD THEN YOU
KNOW MY SENTIMENTS ABOUT HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS THAT.
THAT WE TEACH.
OUR ALL OF OUR CITIZENS ABOUT
EACH OTHER AND OUR BACKGROUNDS
IN OUR CULTURE.
THAT THAT REALLY IS SO IMPORTANT
TO OUR COHESION AS A AS A AS A
WORLD AND THERE'S NO DOUBT NO
DOUBT ABOUT THAT.
THE ISSUE I HAVE WITH YOUR BILL
AS I HAD WITH HIS IS THIS ISSUE
OF A MANDATE.
ADDED THE REQUIREMENT THAT WE
SHOULD GET IN THE WAY OF THOUGHT.
I'D IN THE CASE OF THE MEDINA
BILL THE BOARD OF EDUCATION AND
THE SCHOOL BOARDS IN THE CASE OF
YOUR BILL.
THE ACADEMIC SENATE'S ON THE
CAMPUSES AND IN MANDATING A
SPECIFIC ACTIVITY EVEN IF IT'S
ONE I THINK I VERY WORTHY.
OF STUDY -- AND ENGAGEMENT.
NOW ACCORDING TO THE ANALYSIS
THE THE CHANCELLOR ISSUED AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN IT DIDN'T MANDATE --
THE COURSE REQUIREMENT BUT AT
SUGGESTED.
AND SO I GUESS I'M INTERESTED IN
HEARING.
WHERE WHERE IS IT THAT I BECAUSE
I'M TRYING TO ESTABLISH THIS
HIGH BAR THAT WE NEED TO STEP IN --
CAN YOU SPEAK TO THE WORK THAT
THE ACADEMIC SENATE'S OF DINO
THEY'VE NOT EVEN CONSIDER THIS
ISSUE HAVE THEY TURNED IT DOWN.
HAD THERE NOT BEEN A CAMPUSES
THAT HAVE ADOPTED THIS IS A PART
OF THEIR CAMPUS CHOICE COULD YOU
CAN YOU SPEAK TO THAT ISSUE.
WHAT I THINK -- YOU KNOW IF YOU
LOOK AT IT IN TERMS OF THAT
RECOMMENDATION AND THAT'S NOT
THE FIRST TIME IT'S EVER BEEN
RECOMMENDED IT'S BEEN
RECOMMENDED BEFORE.
FROM VARIOUS OTHER AREAS IN
TERMS OF ALL PERSONS CONCERNED
AND LEADERSHIP AREAS -- IT HAS
NOT BEEN TAKEN UP AS A STATEWIDE
INITIATIVE -- THE
RECOMMENDATIONS BEEN THERE BUT
THERE IS NO PLAN IN PLACE THAT I
KNOW OF WHERE THEY HAVE
SYSTEMATICALLY DECIDED HOW THEY
WOULD ROLL THIS OUT OVER THE
OVER THAN A NUMBER OF YEARS.
SO THE RECOMMENDATION IS THERE
BUT IT IS NOT BEEN TAKEN UP TO
BASICALLY BE IMPLEMENTED.
THOSE DEPARTMENTS WHO HAVE --
AND I'M SEVERAL DEPARTMENTS HAVE
CONTACTED US WHO HAVE TAKEN THAT
INITIATIVE AND HAVE TRIED TO
PUSH IT A LITTLE BIT MORE ON
THEIR CAMPUSES HAVE MET
RESISTANCE OF COURSE -- A FEW
HAVE BEEN ABLE -- TO WHO ALREADY
HAVE IN PLACE A STRUCTURE THAT
ALLOWS IT TO HAPPEN TO HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO DO SOMETHING WITH IT --
BUT IT HAS NOT BEEN COME A MAJOR
ISSUE STATEWIDE THAT WE CAN
EMBRACE AND SAY OKAY THEY'VE
TAKEN THE RECOMMENDATION IN A
MOVING FORWARD WITH IT -- IT'S
NOT THE YEAR AND SO -- SO YOU
DON'T HAVE A PLAN THAT'S BEING
LAID OUT BY THE THE ACADEMIC
SENATE -- TO IMPLEMENT THIS
PARTICULAR PROPOSAL.
SO I I KNOW YOU'RE SPEAKING
ABOUT THE STATE WIDE I THINK
YOU'RE SPEAKING ABOUT THE
STATEWIDE ACADEMIC.
BUT I'M REALLY INTERESTED IN THE
CAMPUS BY CAMPUS CHOICE SO OTHER
WORDS.
I HEAR THAT ALREADY WHO'VE
ALWAYS DONE THAT WHO'S ALWAYS
HAD ETHNIC STUDIES OR I SHOULD
SAY A MULTI CULTURAL STUDIES
COMPONENT WHICH IS DIFFERENT
THAN AN ETHNIC STUDIES COMPONENT.
ALL AND AND IT SAID IT WILL
STATE WE HAD A MULTI CULTURAL
REQUIREMENT THAT WAS THE ACOSTA
CULTURE WHATEVER IT WAS.
AND IT COULD BE SATISFIED IN A
MULTITUDE OF WAYS THAT WOULD
NEVER CAUSE THEM TO EVER ADDRESS
THE ISSUES OF PEOPLE OF COLOR IN
CALIFORNIA -- WE COULD YOU COULD
TAKE IT BY STUDYING SOUTHERN
EUROPEANS OR WHATEVER YOU WANTED
THAT THAT HAVE SOME DIVERSITY
COMPONENT BUT ABILITY TO
ACTUALLY DEAL WITH THE ISSUES OF
OF RACE AND AND AND AND
ETHNICITY IN CALIFORNIA IN THE
UNITED STATES AND THE ISSUE THAT
IT.
IMPACTS THEIR LIVES DALY OF THAT
WAS NOT YOU COULD GET A WAY YOU
COULD GET OUT OF THE UNIVERSITY
WITHOUT EVER TECH TAKING THAT
SUBJECT MATTER.
AND AND THAT IS ONE OF THE
CONCERNS THAT IF WE'RE GOING TO
REALLY ADDRESS THE ISSUES THAT
WE FACE EVERY DAY.
THAT WE SEE EVERYDAY IN OUR
CLASSROOMS AND ARE IN IN THE
PLACES WHERE WE LIVE YOU HAVE TO
BEGIN TO BASICALLY CRACKED OPEN
THAT IT CAN BEGIN TO ENGAGE IN
THAT CONVERSATION.
AND NOT NOT DIVERT YOUR INTEREST
IN OTHER AREAS AND SAY ALWAYS
SATISFIED BECAUSE WE TOOK A
COURSE IN.
SOME SOME OTHER COUNTRY
SOMEWHERE ELSE WITHOUT ACTUALLY
TOUCHING THE CALIPHATE THE
YELLOW CALIFORNIA OR THE OR THE
USE UNITED STATES ISSUES.
RIGHT BUT MY QUESTION REALLY IS
TRYING TO ADDRESS.
I THE COMPELLING NEED FOR US TO
ACT AS A LEGISLATURE WE CAN
BECAUSE WE WE JUST MADE TO MEET
THEM IS FINISHED -- BECAUSE OF
AN ABSENCE OF ACTIONS ON THE
CAMPUS IS TO SHOW THAT
SENSITIVITY AND IN SOME CASES TO
ADOPT THAT AS A REQUIREMENT IN
GENERAL EDUCATION.
AND THAT FOR ME AT LEAST IT'S
LIKE WE'VE TWENTY THREE CAMPUSES
WE HAVE SHARED GOVERNANCE ON
EACH WITH ACADEMIC SENATE'S ON
EACH.
AND SO FOR ME TO TRY TO GET TO
THIS HIGHER BAR -- AND PRATT
PRECEDENT SETTING BAR.
I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND --
WHETHER IT SINCE THE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN EXECUTIVE
ORDER BY THE CHANCELLOR HAVE WE
HAD CAMPUS IS THAT HAVE DONE
NOTHING AND ACTUALLY REFUSED TO
ACT AND SAID THAT IT'S ON THE
RECORD THEY HAD TO DELIVER TO
PROCESS THEY SAID NO WE AT
CAMPUSES THAT HAVE SAID YES.
AND WATER EVERYBODY IN BETWEEN I
WAS I'VE I'M LOOKING FOR SOME
FACTUAL BASIS TO UNDERSTAND THE
NEED TO ACT TODAY.
FACT THAT YOU HAVE FIFTY YEARS
OF ETHNIC STUDIES.
AND AND THAT FIFTY YEARS IS NOT
FIFTY YEARS OF IDLE ACTIVITY.
YOU KNOW HAVING BEEN A CHAIR OF
ETHNIC STUDIES FOR ALMOST FORTY
YEARS THIRTY OF THE FORTY YEARS
I WAS THERE -- THERE IS
PERSISTENT AND CONSISTENT
DISCUSSIONS OF ETHNIC STUDIES ON
THOSE CAMPUSES AND INCLUSION OF
THOSE COURSES IN THE REGULAR
COULD NOT ONLY JUST IN THE
REGULAR CURRICULUM THE CONTENT.
BUT ALSO THE REQUIREMENTS TO
HAVE STUDENTS TAKE THOSE CLASSES
THAT IS A CONSTANTLY THAT IS
THERE ON ALL THE CAMPUS AND IT
ALWAYS HAS BEEN.
AND AFTER FIFTY YEARS OF THAT
WHEN I CAME TO THE LEGISLATURE
AUTHORED THE FIRST PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT WAS A A
RESOLUTION CONCERNING ETHNIC
STUDIES.
AND OUT OF THAT RESOLUTION WE
HAD A HEARING APPEAR OUT OF THE
RESOLUTION THE CHANCELLOR THE
AND WHO CAME IN WHITE CAME IN
AND THE BLACK CAUCUS AND SOME
OTHER CAUCUSES MET WITH HIM AND
SAYS THIS IS A A AN ISSUE THAT
WE HAVE THE NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED.
SO OUT OF ALL OF THAT THEN YOU
GET THIS COMMISSION THIS SERVICE
FOR A COUPLE YEARS THAT'S
PRESIDENT'S IN FACULTY MEMBERS
AND YOU NAME IT ALL THE
COLLABORATIONS IS THERE.
AND IT COMES OUT WITH A
RECOMMENDATION TO SAY AS ONE OF
THE NUMBER ONE RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE A THREE
UNIT REQUIREMENT OF ETHNIC
STUDIES THROUGHOUT THE SYSTEM.
NOW THIS IS AS A RESULT THIS IS
WHAT I'M THIS IS MY SEVENTH YEAR
HERE.
SO THIS IS A RESULT OF SEVEN
YEARS OF DISCUSSION AN ONGOING
AND WE STILL DON'T HAVE THAT WE
HAVE CONTINUING CONVERSATION
ABOUT WHAT SOME DEPARTMENTS HAVE
DONE.
HOW THEY'VE TAKEN SOME HAVE DONE
THAT BUT THEY'VE BEEN DOING THEY
HAD BEEN DOING THAT ALL ALONG SO
YOU DON'T HAVE THE INTRODUCTION
OF THIS NEW -- A STATEWIDE
MOVEMENT SO.
THE ISSUE IS YES THE URGENCY IS
THERE. TO THE EXTENT THAT HOW
LONG AND AND HOPEFULLY AS KINGS
IS NOT LONG.
HOW LONG DO YOU HAVE TO WAIT FOR
THIS TO HAPPEN IS FIFTY YEARS
ENOUGH?
OF IT OR DO WE KNOW ENOUGH
INFORMATION ABOUT ETHNIC STUDIES
TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE YOU KNOW
ALL WE THE PEOPLE IN THIS
GENERATION DETERMINED TO MAKE
THIS HAPPEN.
IS THIS LEGISLATURE DIVERSE
ENOUGH TO BEGIN TO SEE THE
NECESSITY OF IT -- AND I AND I
SAY THIS BECAUSE THIS IS MY
BATTLE FOR FIFTY YEARS I BECAME
THE UNIVERSITY IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY TWO TO DEVELOP ETHNIC
STUDIES A CYNICAL STATE.
SO I'VE BEEN IN THIS A LONG TIME
I'VE HEARD ALL OF THESE.
CONVERSATIONS I HAVE BEEN A PART
OF THE ACADEMIC SENATE FOR SIXTY
YEARS OUR SERVICE AQABA SENATE I
SERVICE CHAIR OF THE CAMPUS
CURRICULUM COMMITTEE FOR THE
SENATE FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS.
I KNOW ALL THE DIFFICULTY AND
THE AND THE RESISTANCE THAT
SEVERE I'VE BEEN IN THE IVORY
TOWER AND TRY TO PAINT MULTIPLE
COLORS AND IT HAS NOT WORKED.
SO ALL I'M SAYING IS THAT.
WHAT ELSE DO YOU NEED TO KNOW?
WELL ENDING IN A SITUATION WHERE
YOU YOU OF THE BIRTH PLACE OF
ETHNIC STUDIES FOR FIFTY YEARS.
I MEAN WHAT ELSE DO WE NEED TO
KNOW TELL ME AND AND TELL ME HOW
YOU WOULD DO IT I AND I KNOW I'M
NOT POLLS BECAUSE THEN YOU BUT
THAT'S OKAY I'M SORRY.
BUT IT IT BEFORE BEFORE YOU
RESPOND CENTER GLAZER IF I COULD
JUST ASK THE AUDIENCE WHEN YOU
LIKE SOMETHING WE GO LIKE THIS
IF YOU DON'T LIKE SOMETHING WE
JUST STAY SILENT.
SO I I LOVE YOUR PASSION AND I I
AND I LOVE YOUR HISTORY AND
CERTAINLY THERE'S FEW THEY CAN
SPEAK TO THAT UNDERSTANDING
HISTORY IS SOMEONE LIKE YOU --
WITH ALL THAT YOU HAVE DONE.
THE THE SYSTEMS HAVE COME AT THE
SYSTEM IS COMING IN SAID THAT
SINCE THE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
EXECUTIVE ORDER THAT.
THERE'S BEEN A 9% INCREASE IN
THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS TAKING --
ETHNIC STUDIES AND THEY PROFESS
TO SAY AND I I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU'VE INFORMATION TO THE
COUNTRY THAT THEY'VE HIRED.
SEVENTY TWO S. ETHNIC STUDIES
TENURE TRACK FACULTY WHICH IS A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF FACULTY SO
THEY'RE READY NOT TO IMPLEMENT
THE STATE WIDE INITIATIVE SO
IT'S AN EIGHT AND I THINK THAT
IF YOU IF YOU I I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU CAN SPEAK TO THE EVIDENCE
THAT THAT THE COURSE.
CATALOG HAS BEEN SHRUNK IN TERMS
OF ETHNIC STUDIES THE MAJORS
HAVE BEEN ELIMINATED DEPARTMENTS
HAVE BEEN ELIMINATED.
ANYWAY I I'M STILL TRYING TO GET
TO THIS ISSUE OF THE COMPELLING
NEED AYE AYE DEAL IS AND IT
ISN'T IT ISN'T OUT OF A GREAT.
APPRECIATION FOR THE GOALS THAT
YOU HAVE ESTABLISHED OKAY AND
HIS LAST THING AND AND AND THAT.
IF YOU WANT TO DRESS YOU CAN BUT
LOOK.
THERE IS AN EVAN FLOW TO OUR
POLITICAL SYSTEM -- THAT -- IS
SOMETIMES COMFORTABLE DO OBSERVE --
BECAUSE WE OBVIOUSLY WOULD LIKE
IT TO BE THE WHERE IS TODAY
RIGHT.
AND IN PREVIOUS LEGISLATURE'S
THERE'VE BEEN PEOPLE IN CHARGE
THAT HAVEN'T BEEN LIKE YOU ARE
LIKE ME -- AND THEY DON'T HAVE
TO GO TOO FAR BACK AND SO.
YET THERE IS A POTENTIAL IN THE
FUTURE EVEN THOUGH WE WOULDN'T
EXPECT OR HOPE FOR IS.
THAT THE FOLKS THAT ARE UP HERE
AT THE DAIS -- ARE GONNA BE AT
FOLKS WITH A DIFFERENT
PHILOSOPHY PHILOSOPHICAL VIEW
ABOUT OUR CAMPUSES IN ACADEMIC
FREEDOM AND THE CHOICES THAT --
MAYBE THEY WANT TO MAKE ABOUT --
MANDATES THAT THEY WANT TO
REQUIRE WE HAVE NEVER PROVIDED
THIS TYPE OF A MANDATE BEFORE IT
IS AN BY WORRY A SLIPPERY SLOPE.
IN TERMS OF WHAT WOULD COME NEXT
I'M NOT BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF
MERIT BUT BECAUSE OF WE HAVE A
PROCESS IN PLACE WE HAVE A BOARD
OF TRUSTEES WHICH IS A VERY
DIVERSE BOARD OF TRUSTEES.
WE HAVE CAMPUS LEADERSHIP WITH
GREAT DIVERSITY NOW
UNPRECEDENTED.
MORE THAN HALF OF THE UNIVERSITY
PRESIDENTS ARE WOMEN TODAY AT
THE CSU.
HAVE A LOT MORE WORK TO DO ON
DIVERSITY WITHIN OUR FACULTY AND
I KNOW THAT'S AN ONGOING
CHALLENGE.
IT WAS I WAS HEARTENING TO HEAR
EARLIER IN TESTIMONY THAT AS A
PART OF THE PRESIDENTIAL REVIEW
THAT THIS ISSUE IS A PART OF
THOSE STANDARDS AND I KNOW I
SAID AS A TRUSTEE DURING THOSE
REVIEWS.
AND THOSE THINGS ARE TAKEN VERY
SERIOUSLY IN TERMS OF THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE CAMPUS.
IN THESE TYPES OF AREAS.
AND SO I JUST WANT TO INSURE
THAT THAT OBSERVATION THAT AS
MUCH AS THESE ARE THINGS WE
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE I CERTAINLY
WOULD LIKE TO SEE IT.
TOO THERE IS A VERY SLIPPERY
SLOPE WE GET ON WITH THESE TYPES
OF MANDATES AND AGAIN THAT'S NOT
OUT OF ANY COULD.
LIMIT OF THE REST OF THE
ENORMOUS RESPECT I HAVE FOR YOU
AND YOUR LEADERSHIP AND I THANK
YOU FOR INDULGING ME.
YOU KNOW ONE OF THE WELL KNOWN A
FEW MINUTES FUND TO THAT OR NOT.
WHAT WE'VE GOT OTHER QUESTIONS
IF YOU DON'T MIND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THANK CENTER GLAZER
SENATOR PAM?
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND SYSTEM
OR A WITH FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU --
FOR WE'VE HAD A CHANCE TO TALK
TO AND APPRECIATE APPRECIATE
YOUR THANK YOU FOR TIME.
AND YOUR LEADERSHIP -- YEAH I DO
AGREE WITH MY GOOD FRIEND US AND
RAZA THAT -- IT DID IS IT NOW
THE SHOULD BE SOMETHING IDEALLY.
A INTO A NOTED WE ARE NOWHERE
NEAR THE IDEAL -- THAT.
THAT IT MEETS INTEGRATED
TOGETHER THE FACT THAT IT'S NOT
MEANS THAT'S WHY WE NEED TO HAVE
I THINK STUDIES -- SO I GUESS
THE QUESTION I HAVE AND I WON AT
FIRST BECAUSE IT TO SEE ISSUE
AND THEN S. A ONE THE SPONSORS
THE RATS ALSO RESPOND.
SO WHAT I SEE IS IS THAT YOU
KNOW EVEN TASK FORCE IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN UNDERSTANDS ON THE ONLY
TASK FORCE IT COMES OUT WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION AND THAT WAS.
THREE YEARS AGO.
AND ONE THE RECOMMENDATIONS IS
THAT -- WE SHOULD DO WITH THIS
BILL CALLS FOR RIGHT AND I AND I
ADMIT THAT I HAVE -- THAT
TREMENDOUS.
RELUCTANCE TO SOMEONE WHO IS A
YOU KNOW PROFESSOR THE OTHER
INSTITUTION UC.
ODD TO HAVE CURRICULA DICTATED
BY.
THE LEGISLATURE OUTSIDE BODIES I
MEAN THE YOUNG FACULTY HAVE TO
DO A LOT OF WORK TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE EDUCATE.
BUT IT IS SO I GUESS THE
QUESTION I HAVE FOR YOU IS YOU
FIRST OF ALL IT IS IS THAT.
SO THE REPORT DID RECOMMEND THIS
SO.
WHAT HAS IT'S BEEN THREE YEARS
SO WHAT HAS THE ACADEMIC SENATE
DONE?
HAS IT -- AND AND WHAT I MEAN
WHAT HAS THE ACADEMIC SENATE
DONE IS IS THAT IN THE PAST
THREE YEARS YOU SHOULD HAVE PUT
IT UP FOR DISCUSSION AND ABOUT --
AND EITHR YOU'RE TELLING ME YES
WE AGREE.
OUR NO WE DON'T AGREE NOT
WHETHER BY THAT SO WE'RE ARGUE
ABOUT THE BILL BECAUSE AGAIN AND
YOU MAKE THE POINT AND I
ACTUALLY DO.
HAVE IT'S YOUR YOUR CONCERNS
THAT.
WE IS THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD NOT
YOU KNOW THAT WE SHOULD BUT THE
FACULTY TAKE THE LEAD BUT NOW
THE QUESTION I HAVE IS IS THAT
SO HAVE THE FACULTY TAKEN THE
LEAD.
LIKE YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN THREE
YEARS WHAT HAVE YOU DONE.
HAVE YOU ACTUALLY DEBATE THIS
ISSUE CAN YOU TELL ME THAT YOU
VOTED IT DOWN THAT'S WHY IT'S
NOT HAPPENED HAS RESULTED WHY
ARE YOU PUTTING US IN THIS
POSITION OF HAVING TO DEBATE
THIS SO -- SO I THAT THAT'S
THAT'S IT'S BEEN THREE YEARS
SINCE THIS EPORT AND THE
RECOMMENDATION CAME OUT SO.
I WANT TO KNOW FROM THE FACULTY
SENATE AND ALSO ONE NO FOR THE
CANCER WHAT IS HE WHAT HAS A
CHANCE ARE DONE. TO ENACT THIS
PARTICULAR RECOGNIZING ITS YOUR
GOVERNANCE SO THAT'S WHY BOTH OF
YOU I'M ASKING BOTH OF YOU TO
ANSWER THE QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION AND I
APPRECIATE THE MOTIVATION BEHIND
IT BELIEVE ME -- AT THE TIME THE
REPORT CAME OUT ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT.
PART OF THE DYNAMIC OF THE STATE
WHAT ACADEMIC SENATE IS A
DIFFERENCE TO CAMPUS AUTONOMY.
WHEN IT COMES TO CURRICULAR
DECISIONS SO I GUESS MY AND AND
THE SO THE ANSWER IS NO WE DID
NOT TAKE UP THE REQUIREMENTS?
AND I THINK THAT THE I THINK I
SO HAVE YOU CALLED ON EACH OF
THE CAMPUS IS AS YOU SAID YOU
DEFERRED THE CAMPUSES.
THAT EACH CAMPUS SHOULD HAVE
ALREADY HAD A VOTE ON IN THE
PAST THREE YEARS.
AND WE HAVE CALLED ON CAMPUSES
TO SERIOUSLY CONSIDER THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE ETHICS
REYES AND AND AND AND I DIDN'T.
IF YOU IF YOU LET ME FINISH ARE
WE HAVE NOT SPECIFICALLY SAID
TAKE OF THIS REQUIREMENT.
SO HAS IT SO HAS IT BEEN A CHEN
DIES AND EVERY CAMPUS FACULTY
SENATE TO HAVE A DISCUSSION
ABOUT THIS REPORT AND THE
RECOMMENDATIONS INCLUDING THIS
RECOMMENDATION THAT I DO NOT
HAVE AN ANSWER.
TO OKAY WHEN CAN YOU GIVE ME THE
ANSWER THAT.
UGH I CAN GET TRY TO GET IT TOO
SOON AS POSSIBLE.
OKAY SO IT'S IT'S THE SUMMER SO
I CAN GET NOW OKAY SO TO LAST
ANOTHER QUESTION AND THEN I WANT
TO HEAR FROM THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE.
IF IT HASN'T.
IS THERE A COMMITMENT ON PAR THE
FACULTY SENATE TO TAKE IT UP
BETWEEN BEFORE THE END OF THE
YEAR THAT EVERY CAMPUS SHOULD
HAVE AT LEAST HAS DISCUSSION AND
MADE A PUBLIC DECISION ON WHAT
TO DO WITH THIS RECOMMENDATION.
THAT IS PRETTY MUCH THE
EMBODIMENT OF THE RESOLUTION
WHICH PASSED IN MAY SETTING UP A
SHARED GOVERNANCE -- MET IS THE
ANSWER YES YES OKAY SO BY BEFORE
THE END OF THIS YEAR EVERY
CAMPUS FACULTY SENATE.
WOULD HAVE CONSIDERED AND TAKEN
A POSITION ON THIS ON THE
RECOMMENDATIONS REPORT INCLUDING
SPECIFICALLY THE RECOMMENDATION
FOR REQUIRING ETHNIC STUDIES FOR
GRADUATION IN THE CAMPUS. TWO
QUESTIONS ONE ARE WE TALKING
ABOUT THE TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
TWENTY SCHOOL YEAR.
ACADEMIC YEAR I AM TALKING ABOUT
BEFORE THE END OF THIS CALENDAR
YEAR CALENDAR YEAR I KNOW
THERE'S THIS ACADEMIC YEAR BUT
ACADEMIC SENATE CAN MAKE
DECISIONS WITHOUT WAITING FOR AN
END OF THE SCHOOL YEAR THEY CAN
DO IT.
DEAL WE HAVE SIX MONTHS.
I CANNOT IT'S AND IT'S NOT TO
LIFE ITS NAME IN JULY FIRST YET
I CAN GIVE YOU COMMITMENT THAT
THE STATE WHAT ECONOMIC SENATE
WILL TAKE THIS ISSUE UP I CANNOT
GIVE YOU A COMMITMENT THAT EVERY
INDIVIDUAL CAMPUS SENATE.
WILL TAKE THIS UP AND AND WILL
HAVE TAKEN A POSITION ON IT
BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO DO THAT IN THE
STATE WHAT SENATE DOES NOT HAVE
THE AUTHORITY TO DO THAT.
OKAY AND IS THAT SOMETHING OKAY
FOR THOSE THAT THERE WAS A
CHANCE ARE DONE IS THAT
SOMETHING THE CHANCEL CALL.
FOR SO WE WE DO HAVE INFORMATION
THAT LAYS OUT EXACTLY HOW EACH
CAMPUS HAS BEEN AND HAS NOT BEEN
RESPONSIVE TO EACH AND AND I
KNOW THE QUESTION I ASKED IS
THAT TAKING UP THIS VERY ISSUE
OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
REPORT AND HAVING THE SENATE
SIDE LIKE TO DEFER. TO THE
SENATE BUT THE SENSE NOT
ACTUALLY GOING TO ACT ON IT AND
EVEN DEBATE AT THE END THAT'S
CONCERNING TO ME.
AND IT'S BEEN THREE YEARS SINCE
A REPORT CAME OUT.
THE THE BASIS OF MY STATEMENT IS
SAYING THAT WE ALREADY HAVE SOME
INFORMATION THAT WE CAN SHARE
WITH YOU RELATIVE TO THOSE
CAMPUSES THAT HAVE TAKEN IT UP.
AND SO WHAT WE WILL NEED TO DO
IS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE A
COMPREHENSIVE BASE OF
INFORMATION THAT SAYS WHICH
CAMPUSES HAVE AND WHICH HAVE NOT.
TAKEN OF THIS PARTICULAR ITEM
AND THAT IF YOU'RE ASKING THAT
WE CAN PROVIDE INFORMATION THERE
AND WHICH HAVE AND WHICH HAVE
NOT WE CAN CERTAINLY HAVE THAT
BY THE END OF THE CALENDAR RIGHT
IN IT NO NO ADD INFORMATION IS
GREAT.
A BUT WHAT I WANNA KNOW ALL YOU
HEAR ABOUT'S LEADERSHIP.
SO WILL THE CHANCELLOR SO I JUST
HEARD YOU KNOW THE THE STATEWIDE
SENATE WILL TAKE SOMETHING UP
BUT SAYS HE DOESN'T HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO ALTHOUGH I HOPE THE
STATEWIDE SENATE WOULD CALL IN
EACH OF THE CAMPUS'S TO DO THIS --
I WOULD ALSO HOPE THE CHANCELLOR
WOULD COMMIT TO CALLING ON EACH
FACULTY SENATE EACH CAMPUS. TO
TAKE UP TO DISCUSS AND MAKE A
DECISION WHETHER THEY SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE.
LET'S PUT HIM ON THE RECORD.
THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF THIS
REPORT THAT CAME OUT THREE YEARS
AGO THAT WAS DONE I UNDERSTAND
IT THE CHANCES BEHEST RIGHT.
AND AND AND AND SO THAT WE I'D
LIKE TO HEAR BACK FROM THE
FACULTY SENATE.
ARE DO THEY AGREE WITH THE IDEA
OF FOOT THIS GOAL OF THIS BILL
COST FOR AS WELL AS THE REST THE
REPORT ARE WE GOING TO HIT YOU
KNOW RECOMMEND -- ETHNIC STUDIES
IS THERE A GRADUATION CLIMATE AS
RECOMMENDED BY THIS TASK FORCE
SO IT BECAUSE RIGHT NOW WHAT
HAPPENS IS THAT IF THE SAYS THAT
THEY DON'T ACT.
YOU'RE PUTTING US IN A BAD
POSITION BECAUSE I AGREE WITH
YOU I DON'T WANNA HAVE TO TELL
THE FACT THE SENATE WHAT TO DO
BUT THE FACT WE SENATE'S NOT
EVEN GOING TO ACT THAT PUTS US
IN A VERY AWKWARD POSITION WE'VE
HEARD A LOT OF POWERFUL
TESTIMONY ABOUT.
HOW IMPORTANT ETHNIC STUDIES IS
A VALUABLE IS NOT ONLY FROM THE
PROPONENTS BUT FROM YOURSELVES
AND SO I THINK THIS WOULD BE A
MATTER OF -- TOP IMPORTANCE
GIVEN THE IMPACT OF ETHNIC
STUDIES TO THE FACULTY SENATE.
AND CHANCELLOR BY THE WAY SO
WHERE'S THE CHANCELLOR ON THIS.
WELL THE THE THE CHANCELLOR HAS
BEEN VERY RESPONSIVE IN TERMS OF
IN TERMS OF MAKING SURE THAT THE
CAMPUSES.
UNDERSTAND THEIR RESEARCH.
I I'D LIKE TO SEE A LITTLE MORE
LEADERSHIP IN THAT REGARD WEBER
CALLING ON THE FACULTY SENATE TO
IT EITHER TO EACH OF THE
ACTUALLY SENATE'S AND THE
PRESIDENTS OF EACH.
TO BE SURE THAT THEY ACTUALLY
TAKE THIS UP THE GEN DIS TO HAVE
A DISCUSSION TO MAKE A DECISION
BEFORE THE END OF THE YEAR.
SO THAT HOPEFULLY THE SYSTEM
COULD MOVE FORWARD I MEAN IF IF
EVERYTHING COMES A SAYS WELL
THESE ARE ALL THE REASONS.
WE DON'T THINK THIS IS A GOOD
IDEA OF THIS PUT THAT ON THE
RECORD AND LET'S HAVE A
DISCUSSION ABOUT THAT MAYBE
THERE'S SOMETHING WE CAN DO TO
MELIORATE THOSE ISSUES BUT WE
CERTAINLY HEARD A LOT OF
POWERFUL TESTIMONY NAY HER TO
YOU DON'T DISAGREE WITH THAT.
ABOUT THE VALUE OF ETHNIC
STUDIES AND SO I'D LIKE THE
FACULTY TO TAKE THE LEAD.
RIGHT I'D LIKE TO FACULTY TAKE
THE LEAD INSTEAD OF US HAVING TO
DO IT.
I MEAN I AGREE WITH YOU I DEBTS
THIS IS THIS IS PROBABLY NOT A
GOOD IDEA THAT WERE TRYING YOU
KNOW THAT FOR THE FIRST TIME WE
WERE GONNA POST SO I THEM AND I
TALKED.
TO SEVERAL WEBER AND EXPRESSED
HIS CONCERNS AS WELL BUT I ALSO
SUBMIT THAT I HEAR HER
FRUSTRATION I HEAR THE
FRUSTRATION OF MANY OF THE
PEOPLE OF TESTIFIED FOR THE BILL
THAT.
WHAT'S TAKING SO LONG AND YOU
KNOW IF AND IF THERE'S A REASON
THE FACT THE SENATE OPPOSES.
LET'S UNDERSTAND THAT WHAT'S THE
REASON FOR THE OPPOSITION WHAT
IS THERE SOMETHING WE COULD DO
THE MILLER IT SO WE CAN SOLVE
THE PROBLEM.
INSTEAD OF WAITING AROUND THIS
IT WILL BE HEARD FIFTY YEARS
THIS REPORT CAME OUT THREE YEARS
AGO.
CAN CAN WE HAVE SOMETHING DONE.
SO THE THE BASED ON WHAT YOU'RE
SAYING THAT THE TEN UP WE'LL GO
BACK TO THE CHANCELLOR AND MAKE
SURE THAT THE CHANCELLOR HAS A
CONVERSATION WITH EACH OF THE
PRESIDENT'S.
AS A PART OF THE EVALUATION
PROCESS THAT I JUST TALKED ABOUT.
DETERMINE WHICH ONES HAVE
ALREADY TAKEN THIS UP AS AN
ISSUE IN HALF THAT AND THEN ASKS
THE PRESIDENT'S TO ENSURE THAT
THEY'RE WORKING IN COLLABORATION
WITH THEIR SENATE'S. TO GET
ANSWERS FROM THE OTHERS AS WELL.
IS THE ANSWERS I'D LIKE THEM TO
ACTUALLY TELL IF GIVE US
FEEDBACK TELL TELL HIM WHAT
THEIR POSITION IS ON THE
RECOMMENDATIONS.
AND WHY [inaudible]
GET OUT.
I MEAN THIS IS NOT JUST ABOUT
INFORMATION IS ABOUT LEADERSHIP
RIGHT.
BUT STE CONFRONT THE ISSUE AND
DEAL WITH IT NOT JUST SAY WELL
WE COLLECT SOME DATA ABOUT AND I
APPRECIATE THERE'S MANY CAMPUSES
ACTUALLY YOU KNOW EXACT STATE I
TALKED TO THE PRESIDENT -- THERE
A DINNER STANDARD.
OLD BUT WE HAVE BEFORE US A
RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE BEFORE US
A BILL THAT BASICALLY SUPPORTS A
RECOMMENDATION THAT CAME FROM
CSU SYSTEM ITSELF.
THE TASK FOR THE CSU SYSTEM
ITSELF.
RIGHT SO IN THAT SENSE WHAT
HAPPENS IS THAT.
YEAH I DON'T LIKE THE IDEA OF US
IMPOSING THOSE REQUIREMENTS.
AT THE SAME TIME.
I'VE MET THAT SOME LABOR WEBER
ISN'T PULLING THIS OUT OF THIN
AIR IT'S NOT JUST SOMETHING THAT
SHE WANTS TO IMPOSE ON CSU SHE'S
BASICALLY SAYING LET'S.
LET'S DO IT A TASK FORCE TO USE
YOU ACTUALLY RECOMMENDED.
AND SO.
YOU KNOW THAT'S NOT ENTIRELY
UNREASONABLE.
ALTHOUGH AGAIN I'D HAVE CONCERNS
THAT YOU'VE EXPRESSED AND I
SHARED THAT WE SHOULDN'T BE
DICTATING BUT AT SAME TIME.
I NEED TO KNOW THAT.
CSU ITSELF THEY CREATE A TASK
FORCE THAT RECOMMENDATION IS
TAKING THAT RECOMMENDATION
SERIOUSLY.
AND IF THEY DON'T AGREE WITH
THAT THEN EXPLAIN WHY NOT AND
THEY AGREE WITH IT DO IT.
THAT'S WHAT I'M NOT HEARING I'M
HEARING YOU KNOW WHERE SOME
PEOPLE THAT'S CETERA BUT THIS IT
IS A SYSTEM WIDE RECOMMENDATION
SO THIS AND SO.
I LIKE TO SEE A SYSTEM WIDE
RESPONSE IN RECOGNIZE WHAT'S
YOUR GOVERNMENT'S NO EACH CAMPUS
HAS YOU KNOW HAS OUR OWN ISSUES
THEY HAVE TO DEAL WITH TO IN OUR
OWN CHARACTERISTICS SO.
OKAY FINE HAD LOTS OF EACH
CAMPUS BUT THIS IS A PRIORITY.
FOR AND I GUESS YOU'RE HEARING
FROM US THIS IS A PRIORITY FOR
US BUT AGAIN WE RECOGNIZE YOU
KNOW SHARED GOVERNANCE SO.
WE HOPE THAT YOU MAKE THIS A
PRIORITY AND THAT'S WHY I'M
CALLING FOR HEARD SAYING WELL
CAN YOU PLEASE MAKE A DECISION
AND TELL US WHAT YOU DECIDED TO
DO.
CAMPUS BY CAMPUS RECOGNIZING
SOME OF THE INDEPENDENT CAMPUS
AS WELL AS THE SYSTEM.
BEFORE THE END OF THE YEAR
BECAUSE GUESS WHAT NEXT YEAR WE
HAVE ANOTHER THE LEGISLATIVE
SESSION AND I HOPE THAT YOU
SOLVE THE PROBLEM FOR US SO WE
DON'T HAVE TO LEGISLATE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
SO BE IT.
OKAY ALL RIGHT AND THAT JUST
PLEASE DEAL.
ALL RIGHT AND ANY.
AT THE TIPS THAT YOU KNOW -- I
DON'T KNOW IF THEY'RE ANY OF THE
QUESTIONS -- I'LL JUST LET ME
SAY THAT -- THIS ISSUE OBVIOUSLY
HAS BEEN CIRCULATING AROUND FOR
A NUMBER OF YEARS AND IT SHOULD
BE APPARENT TO THIS BODY.
BUT THAT BODY IS NOT GOING TO
ACT IN THE WAY THAT WE THINK
IT'S APPROPRIATE.
I MEAN -- AS I SAID YOU KNOW
I'VE BEEN AT THE UNIVERSITY FOR
FEEL LIKE FOR EVER.
AND I'VE SERVED ON ALL OF THE
COMMITTEES THAT THEY TALK ABOUT --
AND I KNOW THAT THEY HAVE OFTEN
BEEN MANDATE FROM OUTSIDE.
THAT HAVE IMPACTED THE CAMPUS.
I REMEMBER WHAT ROTC CAME SAN
DIEGO STATE.
THE FACULTY DID NOT WANT IT.
BACK THE SAME ACADEMIC SENATE
ACTUALLY VOTED AGAINST.
BUT IT WAS ADMINISTRATION AND
THE POWERS ABOVE THAT
IMPLEMENTED ROTC IT'S AN ABLE
STATE.
DESPITE ALL OF THOSE QUESTIONS
ABOUT OUR RIGHT TO CONTROL
CURRICULUM AND TO DECIDE WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO DO THERE ARE
OTHER THINGS THAT HAPPEN AT THIS
INSTITUTION.
THAT DOT THAT BASICALLY OF DO
NOT FOLLOW THIS REALLY PRISTINE
ANALYSIS OF A FACULTY ENGAGEMENT
AND SO FORTH AND SO ON AND I
GUESS THE PROBLEM IS I'VE BEEN
BEHIND THE CURTAIN AND I KNOW
WHAT'S BEHIND THE CURTAIN.
SO I'M NOT IMPRESSED WHEN PEOPLE
TELL ME ABOUT THE IVORY TOWER
TELL ME ABOUT ACADEMIC FREEDOM
DIALOGUE IS THE SENATE
COMMITTEES THE DADA DADA DOT.
I KNOW THAT'S ALL A WAY OF
SAYING IT'S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN
WHEN YOU LOOK AT ETHNIC STUDIES
ETHNIC STUDIES CAME INTO
EXISTENCE NOT BECAUSE PEOPLE
THOUGHT IT WAS A GOOD ACADEMIC
IDEA.
NOT BECAUSE THEY THOUGHT IT WAS
TIME BUT IT WAS FAIR IS BECAUSE
STUDENTS WERE BURNING BUILDINGS
AT IN THE CAMPUS I CAME TO SAN
DIEGO STATE BECAUSE A BUNCH OF
STUDENTS BURNED ALL THE TRASH
CANS OF FROM THE PRESIDENT'S
OFFICE.
HE REALIZED ALL WE GOT TO HIRE
SOME BLACK PEOPLE TO GET UP IN
HERE THE STOP THE STUFF.
AND THAT'S HOW I GOT HIRED AND
THAT'S WHAT MOST LOS GOT HIRED
SAN FRANCISCO STATE WAS A
PROTEST FOR WELL OVER A YEAR.
OKAY EVERY CAMPUS THAT YOU SEE
WAS NOT SOME LITTLE ORDERLY
PROCESS THAT OCCURRED STUDENTS
SO OFTEN WERE DISPEL FROM
CAMPUSES I HAVE FRIENDS WHO
COULD NOT FINISH THEIR DEGREE
CAL STATE LA.
AND GUIDED MAYBE TWENTY YEARS
LATER BECAUSE THEY WERE EXPELLED
FROM THE CAMPUS FOR PROTESTING
BUT ETHNIC STUDIES SO THIS IS
NOT SOMETHING THAT IS GOING TO
EASILY WALK THROUGH THE IVORY
TOWER HOLES AND BE EMBRACED IT
IS NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
THE A LOT OF POLITICS THAT OCCUR%
WHEN YOU HAVE WHEN YOU START
TALKING ABOUT REQUIRING A COURSE
TO BE TAUGHT YOU HAVE BEEN
CHANGING THE PERSPECTIVE NOT
ONLY OF THE PUBLIC BUT OF THE
FACULTY AS WELL.
IN TERMS OF WHAT THEY SEE IS
IMPORTANT WHAT THEY VALUE THAT'S
GOING TO CHANGE IT'S ALSO GOING
TO SOMETIMES CHANGE THE DYNAMICS
OF POWER AT AN INSTITUTION.
BECAUSE STUDENTS NOW WILL BE C.
FACULTY WILL HAVE REQUIRED TO
SEE PEOPLE WHO DON'T LOOK LIKE
THEM WE CAN GIVE THEM
INFORMATION THAT THEY DON'T HAVE.
IT ALSO CHANGES THE DYNAMICS IN
TERMS OF WHO'S FUNDED AND WHO'S
NOT FUND IT SO LET'S BE REAL
ABOUT IT THIS IS POWER
DISCUSSION THIS IS ABOUT WHO
WILL HAVE INFLUENCE.
NOT ONLY AT THE INSTITUTION BUT
WHO WILL HAVE INFLUENCE AND CAL
ONE YEAR THE IVORY TOWER SOMEHOW
ANOTHER STRONGHOLDS ITSELF INTO
THIS IMPARTIAL -- PERSPECTIVE
BUT THE REALITY IS IT IS VERY
PARTIAL IT IS VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT ECONOMICS IT IS VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT.
MAINTAINING THE STATUS QUO AND
WE CAN YOU TO PARTICIPATE IN
THAT OR WE CAN CHANGE IT.
AND SO I YOU KNOW I'M NOT
IMPRESSED AT ALL WITH THE
CONVERSATION BECAUSE I KNOW
WHAT'S GOING HAPPEN NEXT YEAR
THE YEAR AFTER YEAR AFTER IT WE
CONTINUE DOWN THIS PATH.
AT SOME POINT EVERYTHING WE'VE
EVER DONE HAS VIOLATED THE RULES
IN ORDER TO GET IT DONE BROWN
VERSUS BOARD OF EDUCATION TALKS
ABOUT THE ARE WE GOING TO
INTERVENE IN STATES WHERE THEY
HAVE STATES RIGHTS TO DETERMINE
WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN IN SCHOOLS.
AND WE FINALLY SAID YES WE HAVE.
TO AND WHEN WE BEGIN TO LOOK AT
ALL THE CHANGES THAT HAVE
OCCURRED IN THIS NATION THEY
HAVE ATTAINED THEY'VE A CARD
BECAUE PEOPLE DECIDED.
ENOUGH IS ENOUGH WE HAVE TO MOVE
FOR THIS IS WHAT WE BELIEVE IN
AND WE HAVE TO CHANGE THE RULES
OF ENGAGEMENT.
AND SO WHEN I LOOK AT THE
ACADEMIC SENATE HAVING SPENT ALL
OF MY LIFE AT THE C. ISSUE.
ALL OF MY ACADEMIC LIFE THERE
AND WORKING TO CHANGE THE WHAT
IS HAPPENING I UNDERSTAND THE
LANGUAGE I UNDERSTAND THE BOOKS
IN THE HOWEVER BECAUSE MAYBE SO
FORTH AND SO ON ALL THE
RESTRICTIONS THAT ARE OFTEN PUT
UP. TO SIMPLY SAY WE'RE NOT
GOING TO DO THIS BECAUSE WE'RE
NOT GOING TO EMPOWER STUDENTS TO
HAVE THE INFORMATION THEY NEED
TO BE THE KIND OF CITIZENS THAT
WE WANT.
WE COMPLAIN ABOUT ALL THE HATRED
IN CALIFORNIA WE COMPLAIN ABOUT
THE LACK OF INFORMATION PEOPLE
HAVE WE COMPLAIN ABOUT STUDENTS
NOT BEING CHALLENGED TO THINK
DIFFERENTLY AND TO FORM A
CALIFORNIA THAT IS VERY VERY
DIFFERENT.
I SEE WHAT HAPPENS TO WHITE
STUDENTS WHO TAKE ETHNIC STUDIES
THEIR LIVES ARE CHANGED FOREVER
THE PERSPECTIVES ARE CHANGED FOR
EVER AND AND SO WE HAVE TO LOOK
AT THIS NOT JUST AS A BLACK
BROWN THING.
BUT WE HAVE TO LOOK AT THIS AS
RESCUE IN CALIFORNIA IF WE'RE
EVER GOING TO TALK ABOUT ETHNIC
STUDIES IN K. TWELVE IT IS
BECAUSE WE HAVE EDUCATED THE
TEACHER TEACHERS IN THE C. ISSUE
TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT. TO BE
ABLE TO CHANGE THE COMMON
NARRATIVE THAT'S THERE AND TO
PRESENT THE INFORMATION THAT'S
ALWAYS CENTRAL.
THIS IS CRITICAL FOR CALIFORNIA
BEING THE DIVERSE STATE IT WANTS
TO BE HAVE THE INFORMATION TO
MAKE THE DIFFERENCE IN THE LIVES
OF OUR YOUNG PEOPLE BUT IN THE
LIVES OF ALL OF US.
AND IT'S ONLY FOR THAT REASON
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND
I BOTH DID YOU TO HAVE THE
COURAGE TO JOIN ME AND NOT
LISTEN TO THE NARRATIVE THAT I
HAVE LISTEN TO FOR FIFTY YEARS.
ALL IN TERMS OF WHAT THE
UNIVERSITY CAN AND CANNOT DO
BECAUSE I KNOW THEY DO WHAT THEY
WANT TO DO WHEN THEY WANT TO DO
IT REGARDLESS OF WHO WAS IN
CHARGE.
WHO HAS A ROLE TO DO IT WHO HAS
THE RIGHT TO DO IT ALL THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS?
I HAVE BEEN A PART OF THAT FOR
EVER I KNOW THE NARRATIVE I KNOW
THE LANGUAGE AND THANK GOD I'M
HERE TO TELL YOU THAT IT'S ALL.
UNFAIR UNFOUNDED AND IF I
BELIEVE IN THE EASTER BUNNY THEN
I WOULD BELIEVE IN THAT SO ONCE
AGAIN I ASK FOR YOU TO VOTE FOR
THIS BILL FOR AB FOURTEEN SIXTY
FOR US TO DO SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
AND THE CHALLENGES SYSTEM AS IT
SHOULD BE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER -- OKAY.
SO NONE OF US EVER WANT TO
FOLLOW DR WEBBER BUT BEFORE WE
VOTE.
I DO JUST WANT TO EXPRESS MY
OPINION ON THE BILL -- AND I DO
HAVE TO SAY TO THE C. ISSUES.
I THINK YOU GUYS COULD COME A
LITTLE BIT MORE PREPARED IT'S
REALLY CLEAR THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT THE ACADEMIC
SENATE HAS RECOMMENDED THAT THE
EXIT WITH THE TASK FORCE HAS
RECOMMENDED.
THAT IT HASN'T BEEN INSTITUTED
AS WE'VE GONE OVER IN THREE
YEARS WE'VE HEARD PEOPLE TALK
ABOUT THIS BEING A PRECEDENT AND
IT'S NEVER HAPPENED.
AND I WOULD JUST SAY THAT NEVER
NEVER HAPPENS UNTIL IT DOES
HAPPEN AND SOMETIMES WE HAVE.
TO WE HAVE TO CHANGE THE STATUS
QUO AND AS I SAID WITH THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA IS BILL
HOW DO WE EXPECT IN AS YOU
ARTICULATED VERY WELL DOCTOR
WEBER HOW DO WE EXPECT PEOPLE TO
KNOW ABOUT EACH OTHER IF WE
DON'T GIVE THEM THE OPPORTUNITY
O LEARN ABOUT.
EACH OTHER HOW DO WE EXPECT TO
BREAK DOWN WALLS BREAKDOWN BAY
AREA BARRIERS EXCEPT EACH OTHER
LOVE EACH OTHER IF WE DON'T
TEACH OUR YOUNG PEOPLE -- SO I I
AM VERY HAPPY TO TO SUPPORT THE
<c.green>ILL TODAY I APPRECIATE YOU ALSO</c>
BEING AN ADVOCATE AND WORKING SO
HARD AND TIRELESSLY ON THIS. FOR
ALL THE YEARS THAT YOU'VE THAT
YOU'VE BEEN DOING IT AND I JUST
THINK THAT WE NEED TO CHANGE AND
IF WE DON'T CHANGE THINGS FOR
OUR YOUNG PEOPLE.
THEN HOW CAN WE EVER EXPECT A
BETTER FUTURE SO I THINK YOU
VERY MUCH THE MORE WE KNOW ABOUT
EACH OTHER THE MORE WE WILL KNOW
THAT WE ARE MORE ALIKE THAN
DIFFERENT.
AND I WOULD SAY TO ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES IF NOT US THEN WHO.
AND IF NOT WIN.
IF NOT NOW THEN WHEN WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR TO ROSAMOND
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM TWELVE AB FOURTEEN SIXTY
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA AYE LEYVA
AYE WILK CHIANG RUSSELL.
RUSSELL AYE GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN.
WE WILL LEAVE THAT BILL ON CALL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR WEBER.
ALRIGHT MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM ELEVEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIPSON.
THIS IS FILE ITEM ARE EXCUSE ME
THIS IS AB.
THIRTEEN FIFTY FOUR BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY BUT IF YOU WANT TO
WAIT FOR THE ROOM TO CLEAR A
LITTLE BIT
[inaudible]
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WELCOME TO
THE COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION
YOU'RE WELCOME TO BEGIN AS SOON
AS YOU'RE READY AND AND AND
RECOVERED FROM THAT WONDERFUL
FINISH BASE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER OF THANK
YOU VERY MUCH -- SENATOR AND TO
THE SENATE -- THIS HARD TO
FOLLOW BEHIND DOCTOR SHIRLEY
WEBER -- I FEEL STILL FILL THE
SMOKE COMING FROM.
THIS PODIUM BUT AGAIN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN
FIFTY FOUR WHICH WILL ENSURE
CONSISTENT EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOU WHO WERE
FORMALLY INCARCERATED.
FOR ME FOR ME -- IN THE JUVENILE
OF JUVENILE JUSTICE -- SYSTEM
THIS BILL REQUIRES THE COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION TO
COLLABORATE WITH THE PROBATION
ON AN INDIVIDUALIZED TRANSITION
PLAN FOR YOU TRANSITIONING OUT
OF JUVENILE -- COURTS SCHOOL
EXISTING LAW AND ACTED -- BUT BY
THE ABOUT THE SIGNING OF AB.
TWENTY TWO SIXTY SEVEN BOCANEGRA
IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
REQUIRES A JOINT TRANSITION PLAN
A SEARCH TO WHAT THIS BILL DOES
IS WHEN INDIVIDUALS RE OF
GETTING OUT OF THE JUVENILE --
COURT SCHOOL -- IT WILL MANDATE
THAT A PLAN IS PUT IN PLACE FAR
TOO LONG INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
COMING OUT OF JUNE OUT OF
FACILITIES -- BILL AND GO
THROUGH A BLACK HOLE FALL
THROUGH THE CRACKS -- IN THE
SYSTEM WHERE WHEN THEY RETURNED
TO A PUBLIC SCHOOL COMMUNITY
SCHOOL -- THERE IS NO PLAN FOR
THEM TO SUCCEED I'M A FIRM
BELIEVER AS MY MOTHER SAID IF
YOU DON'T PLAN YOU PLAN TO FAIL
AND SO THIS MANDATES ALL PARTIES
INVOLVED TO COLLABORATE WITH
PROBATION.
THE THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCAL
SERVICES TO MAKING SURE THAT A
PLAN IS PUT IN PLACE TO MAKING
SURE THAT THESE YOUNG PEOPLE'S
TRANSITIONING.
FROM THE JUVENILE -- FACILITY
HAS A PLAN THAT WOULD TRANSITION
THAT WILL GET THEM ON THE RIGHT
COURSE IS THE RIGHT CLASSES FOR
THEM TO TAKE -- WHEN GOING BACK
TO THEIR HOME SCHOOLS -- THIS
COMES HAVE COME OUT OF A WORK
GROUP OF STUDENTS -- WERE PUT
THIS PLAN TOGETHER AND A NUMBER
OF TESTIMONIES HAVE COME FORTH
OF THE STUDENTS WHO HAVE FALLEN
THROUGH THE CRACKS AND WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
THAT THERE'S A CONSISTENT PLAN
THROUGH A MANDATE THAT WOULD
MAKE IT POSSIBLE FOR THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE TO SUCCEED WITH ME TO
PROVIDE SUPPORTING TESTIMONY --
BUT THIRTEEN FIFTY FOUR ARE A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE YOUTH
LAWCENTER AS WELL AS A JAY YOU
THINK CHU WITHOUT COALITION
REPRESENTATIVE WHO WAS SELF
INTRODUCED IN SUPPORT OF
THIRTEEN FIFTY FOUR VERY GOOD
WITNESSES IN FAVOR [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE MY NAME IS
ARE YOU TOM NEWSOME HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENT IN A LOCAL AT THE YOUTH
JUSTICE COALITION LOBEL
STRESSFUL LEADING OUR BROTHERS
AND SISTERS OUT OF THE SYSTEM.
AND WE ORGANIZE FOR IMPROVEMENTS
IN THE COMMUNITY AND CHANGES IN
STATE LAWS TO GIVE INCARCERATED
YOUTH MORE OPPORTUNITIES.
I HOPE YOU'LL VOTE YES ON A. B.
THIRTEEN FIFTY FOUR EDUCATION IS
THE MOST IMPORTANT RESOURCE WE
NEED TO GET A JOB.
THAT PAYS ENOUGH TO LIVE ON GET
OFF THE STREETS AND STAY OUT OF
JAIL.
BUT 90% OF THE YOUTH AND
CALIFORNIA'S JUVENILE HALLS
PROBATION CAMPS AND RANCHES IN
BJJ FACILITIES WAS SUSPENDED OR
EXPELLED BEFORE THEY WERE LOCKED
THE I WANT TO FINISH HIGH SCHOOL
IN LOS ANGELES AND I GOT KICKED
OUT FOR FIGHTING NO ONE EVER
ASKS ME WHAT MADE ME SO ANGRY --
SAT ME DOWN WITH OTHER STUDENTS
TO WORK THINGS OUT I WASN'T
REFERRED TO ANOTHER SCHOOL.
WHICH I FOUND OUT LATER IS IS
GET STATE LAW INSTEAD I WAS OUT
OF SCHOOL FOR MONTHS.
I WILL LEAVE EVERY DAY FROM
HOMES TO MAKE IT LOOK LIKE I WAS
IN SCHOOL.
BUT I WAS REALLY IN THE STREETS
ARE THEM ON MY MAMA KNOWS KICKED
OUT OF SCHOOL EVENTUALLY.
OUR ROAD IN ANOTHER SCHOOL BUT
THERE WHEN A TEACHER MADE A
RACIST COMMENT IN CLASS I LOST
MY TEMPER IN A THROUGH CHAIR.
THE TEACHER CALLED THE POLICE
AND I WAS ARRESTED AND TAKEN TO
JUVENILE HALL.
PROBATION TELL ME THIS IS WHERE
I WOULD BE FOR A LONG TIME IF I
DIDN'T STRAIGHTEN STRAIGHTEN UP.
I WAS TOLD I WOULDN'T BE HOME
FOR CHRISTMAS I GUESS THEY WERE
TRYING TO SCARE ME IT WAS A VERY
HUMILIATING EXPERIENCE.
AT JUVENILE HALL ARE WAS NEVER
TESTED OR SAYS ON MY EDUCATIONAL
NEEDS.
I WAS NEVER ROLLED IN SCHOOL
EVEN THOUGH I WAS THERE FOR
WEEKS WHEN I WAS RELEASED I GOT
NO REFERRAL TO ANOTHER SCHOOL.
NO TRANSCRIPTS I HAD NO ID ALL
OF THESE THINGS ARE ESSENTIAL TO
GET INTO SCHOOL.
AS THEIR PROBATION BASICALLY
KICKED ME OUT TO THE STREETS.
I WAS PUT ON PROBATION FOR THREE
YEARS DURING THE ENTIRE TIME I
WAS ON PROBATION I NEVER HAVE
SUPPORT AND ROLE IN SCHOOL I WAS
TOLD TO DO ANGER MANAGEMENT
CLASSES FOR HIGH RISK HIGH NEEDS.
YOU'VE BUT MY MOTHER COULDN'T
AFFORD THE FEES SO BASICALLY ALL
I GOT DURING THOSE THREE YEARS
WAS DRUG TESTED.
I AM A ROLE NOW DO YOU JUSTICE
COLLISIONS HIGH SCHOOL AND I
KNOW I WILL GRADUATE BUT IT IS
HARD.
ALL THE TIME OUT OF SCHOOL BROKE
MY CONFIDENCE IN MY LOVE FOR
LEARNING.
AND I HAVE TO GET USED TO HAVING
THE SAYS GRADUAL SCHEDULE FOR
SCHOOL EVERY DAY.
THE STREETS IN TROUBLE PULLS
HARD ON THE U. IT'S NO MYSTERY
WHY WE ARE ALL IN THE STREETS WE
NEED TO EAT.
AND WHEN YOU FALL BEHIND THE
SCHOOL YOU START TO BELIEVE THAT
SHE WON'T MAKE IT WOULD
EDUCATION.
THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF YOU THAT
HAVE MY SAME STORY BUT CURRENT
LAW DOESN'T REQUIRE ANY
OVERSIGHT OF SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS.
LIKE HELP WAS SCHOOL RECORDS AND
CREDITS TRANSFERS ALL THE THINGS
THAT I NEEDED.
AB THIRTEEN FIFTY FOUR WILL
REQUIRE THAT THE COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION AND PROBATION TO
DEVELOP A PERSONAL PLAN WITH THE
STUDENT AND THEIR FAMILY IN
ORDER TO MEET THE ACADEMIC.
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL AND CAREER
NEEDS OF EACH STUDENT WHO WAS
LOCKED UP FOR MORE TAN TWENTY
CONSECUTIVE SCHOOL DAYS.
I HOPE WILL ENCOURAGE THEM TO
EVENTUALLY GUARANTEE THAT ALL
YOUTH WHO ARE RISKY GET THE
SERVICES.
AND OUR SCHOOLS AND OUR JUVENILE
HALLS IN ALL YOU FACILITIES WE
NEED COLLAGEN JOB PREPARATION
BUT WE ARE GETTING PRISON
PREPARATION.
THAT'S THE REASON WHY SO MANY
YOU GRADUATE NOT BY WALKING THE
STATE'S BOUGHT BUT BY WALKING
THE PRISON YARD.
AND THE REASON WHY 85% OF THE
PEOPLE WHO ANSWER PRISON ACROSS
THE COUNTRY HAVE NO HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA.
THANK YOU FOR LISTENING TO ME I
URGE.
YET URGENT OF ALL YES ON A. B..
THIRTEEN FIFTY FOUR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR VERY POWERFUL
TESTIMONY THANK YOU FOR BEING
WILLING TO COME AND SHARE WITH
US TODAY.
NEXT WITNESS.
I'LL KEEP MY COMMENTS VERY BRIEF --
I'M LUCY SAUCEDO CARTER ADVOCATE
WITH THE YOUTH LAWCENTER WE'RE
SPONSORING THIS BILL BECAUSE WE
KNOW THAT WITHOUT SUPPORTS TO
HELP YOUTH TRANSITION FROM
JUVENILE COURT SCHOOL BACK TO
THEIR COMMUNITY SCHOOL.
MANY OF THEM WILL DROP OUT OF
SCHOOL TOGETHER AND MISS
THOMASES TESTIMONY REALLY.
EXEMPLIFIES THAT UNFORTUNATELY --
AND WE KNOW THAT EDUCATION IS
KEY TO GIVING YOUTH ESPECIALLY
YOUTH WITH TO PROMOTE US TO
SYSTEM INVOLVEMENT OPPORTUNITIES
TO DEVELOP THE SKILLS AND
KNOWLEDGE THEY NEED. TO PREPARE
FOR THE FUTURE AND HAVE A
PRODUCTIVE LIFE -- UNFORTUNATELY
YOUNG PEOPLE LIKE MISS THOMAS
ARE LEAVING JUVENILE FACILITIES.
THE FIRST THERE THEY ARE
STRUGGLING TO GET RE ENROLLED IN
THEIR COMMUNITY SCHOOLS.
THEY'RE STRUGGLING TO GET CREDIT
FOR THE WORK THEY DO IN THE
COURTS SCHOOLS.
AND THEY AREN'T GETTING INTO THE
COURSES THAT THEY NEED TO
CONTINUE THEIR ACADEMIC.
PROGRESS.
I'M.
AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTY SIX WAS
ONE OF THE BILLS THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIPSON MENTIONED -- A
WORK GROUP FROM THAT BILL MADE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT ARE
REFLECTED IN THIS BILL.
AND I'D JUST LIKE TO SAY THAT I
THINK IT'S GOOD POLICY TO FOLLOW --
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT COME OUT OF
FORT GROUPS THAT ARE ASSIGNED BY
THE LEGISLATURE RATHER THAN
HAVING THEM SIT ON THE SHELF.
SO -- BY SUPPORTING AB THIRTEEN
FIFTY FOUR YOU HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADVANCE
LEGISLATION THAT BUILDS ON
FORMER LEGISLATION.
AND ON THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF
EXPERTS APPOINTED BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND YOU ALSO HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO STRENGTHEN
THE LIKELIHOOD THAT VULNERABLE
YOUTH WILL BE ABLE TO CONTINUE
THEIR EDUCATION AND THRIVE.
AND BECOME PRODUCTIVE HEALTHY
MEMBERS OF SOCIETY SO ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
IRVING ALVAREZ -- YOU'VE JUST
COALITION PRESENCE OF COALITION
AS A PRODUCT OF SCHOOL TO PRISON
PIPELINE IS AN EMBARRASSMENT
THAT WE CAN'T HEAR THESE TEENS
MENTALLY PHYSICALLY AND
EMOTIONALLY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NAME AN ORGANIZATION
PLEASE AND CAN GIVE ME A JUSTICE
COALITION FULL SUPPORT AND SORRY
WE'RE SO PROUD IN LOVE YOU SO
MUCH THANK.
I HAVE A CONTACT US ON BEHALF OF
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
JULIE SAID RIVER METIS STUDENT
AT CC STANISLAUS IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. ZERO FACULTY MEMBER
SAN STATE I AM IN FULL SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
I'LL BE AWARENESS STUDENT I
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
STANISLAUS CURRENTLY COUNSELOR
ONE AT AN S. T. R. T. P. PROGRAM
AND COMPLETE SUPPORT.
IF YOU COULD BASS MODESTO JUNIOR
COLLEGE PYCHOLOGY STUDENT IN
FULL SUPPORT.
DIMS MCFADDEN STUDENTS AS LOST
AN ARM FOR SUPPORT.
DR REFERENCE OF RICE EVEN RIGHTS
IN OUR EXPORT THIS BILL.
I SUPPORTERS BELONG HERE FROM
ALL SUPPORT GOD BLESS YOU.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
SIR ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING AND HEARING THAT WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS.
SENATOR DRAWS A I JUST WANT TO
THANK THE THE YOUNG LADY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE.
THANK YOU CENTER DRAWS SO THE
BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR PAN
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
SENATORS FOR ONE ALLOWING US TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN
FIFTY FOUR WE THINK THIS IS A
COMMON SENSE -- PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THIS BEST BEFORE YOU
AND I WANT TO ALSO GIVE KUDOS TO
MISS THOMAS FOR ONE FOR GIVING
AN EXCELLENT EXCELLENT TESTIMONY --
I CANNOT SAY IT BETTER THESE OF
OF HONORABLE YOU -- THANK YOU
FOR STANDING UP AND BEING HERE
YOU'RE A GREAT EXAMPLE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ITEM ELEVEN A. B. THIRTEEN FIFTY
FOR THE MOTION IS TO PASSED
PUBLIC SAFETY LEYVA.
LEAVE THE AYE WILK CHIANG
RUSSELL.
RUSSELL AYE GLAZER MCGUIR PAN
PAN AYE.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU SOME A
MEMBER WILLIE THAT BILLING CALL
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT NEXT UP IS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TO COME ON UP THAT IS
FILE ITEM.
THIRTEEN AB.
FIFTEEN EIGHTEEN THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SHERMAN
DENTURES AND SENATOR I'M HERE TO
PRESENT A. B. FIFTEEN EIGHTEEN
WHICH IS TO MAKE A MINOR CHANGE
WILL COMPLY WITH OUR RECENT NC
DOUBLE A RULING.
WHICH A FACT A VERY SMALL AMOUNT
OF STUDENT ATHLETES.
AB -- FIFTEEN EIGHTEEN WILL MAKE
SURE THAT -- OURS CALIFORNIA
STUDENT ATHLETE ARE.
KIND OF THE NON -- ANALYZE FOR
NOT COMPLYING WITH THIS AND SEE
DOUBLE E..
A RULING SO -- EIGHTEEN JOY
APART BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
IN THE AND A BMP COME COMMITTEE
AND I ASK FOR YOUR I WILL.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
TYLER AGO OR ON BEHALF THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA I DO WANT
TO NOTE WE ARE NOT A SPONSOR --
BUT WE ARE VERY SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU.
AND YOU WATCHING THIS CALIFORNIA
UNIVERSAL ALSO SUPPORT.
AND THE OVER AUTO WITH CREW
STRATEGIES ON BEHALF OF STANFORD
UNIVERSITY IN SUPPORT.
KATHLEEN SORIANO WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
SUSAN REYES WITH A A CC YOU THE
ASSOCIATION OF INDEPENDENT
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
FOR ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING AND HEARING THEM COME
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS CONCERNS BUT JAPAN.
THANK YOU SEVEN TWO FOR BRING
THIS -- BILL FORD I I KNOW WE
HEARD THAT BILL ALONG WITH THE
CHAIR AND AND BEING P. AND I
YEAH AND I HAD EXPRESSED SOME
CONCERNS.
NOT SO MUCH WITH THE BILL ITSELF
BUT AS WITH THE APPROACH I
RECOGNIZE THAT -- WELL CERTAINLY
HEARD SOME OF THE UNIVERSITIES
ARE SUPPORTING TESTS WITH NO ONE
CAME UP TO THE TO THE TABLE HERE
BUT SO I CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND
NIGHT.
WHAT YOU'RE DOING THE BILL ON
WHY A -- AND IT IN ORDER TO TRY --
TO HELP SINCE IN ALLEYS FOR
TRYING TO CONFORM TO NC DOUBLE A
RULES AND SO CERTAINLY THAT'S
UNDERSTANDABLE -- BUT I THINK
THE AS I EXPRESSED IN.
THE IN P. -- I A ALSO WAS HOPING
THAT ARE HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS WOULD NOT JUST
CONFORM THE NC DOUBLE A RULES
BUT ACTUALLY HE LEAD TO CHANGE
THE ONES THAT ARE -- LESS
APPROPRIATE RATE AND THAT THEY
NEED TO BE STRONGER ADVOCATES
FOR THE STUDENTS AND BECAUSE
AFTER ALL THE NC DOUBLE A ARE
THE UNIVERSITIES THEMSELVES I
MEAN IT'S NOT SOME OUTSIDE
ENTITY IS COMPOSED THE
UNIVERSITY PRESIDENTS IT'S
UNIVERSITIES TO GOVERN THOSE.
SO -- SO WITH THAT YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY.
AND REALIZE THAT YOU'RE NOT
TRYING TO TACKLE ALL THOSE THE
ALL THOSE ISSUES WITH YOUR BILL
SO I APPRECIATE YOU BRING YOUR
BILL FORD I RECOGNIZE YOUR BILL
DOES DO SOME VERY IMPORTANT
THINGS.
I I WOULD JUST YEAH BUT I WOULD
JUST SAY FOR THE UNIVERSITY
STORY HERE YOU KNOW I I I DO
HOPE AND EXPECT -- THAT
UNIVERSAL TAKE A STRONGER LEAD I
MEAN WITHIN THE ORGANIZATION IT
IS UNIVERSITIES.
AND AND AND AND ADVOCATE MORE --
FOR FOR STUDENTS -- SO WITH THAT
WHY STATE OFTEN BPO OF FOR THE
BILL.
TODAY THE TWO HERE TOO BECAUSE I
THINK THE OVERALL YOUR SPECIFIC
BILL THE POLICY IS APPROPRIATE
BUT I CERTAINLY HELP THE
UNIVERSITY'S UNDERSTAND THAT WE
OF WE ARE EXPECT MORE FROM THEM
THAN THEY HAVE SO FAR IN TERMS
OF LEADERSHIP.
AND TAKING ON ISSUES THAT HE NC
DOUBLE A AS OPPOSED ON STUDENTS
THAT THAT I THINK ARE UNJUST AND
UNFAIR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER PAN.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
SENATOR ALSO YEAH I I SHARE WITH
MY COLLEAGUES.
THE CONCERNS AS FAR AS THIS NOT
BEING.
THE THE BAR THAT WERE.
LOOKING TO GET -- TO AND AND
THAT'S MY CONCERN IS THAT THIS
COULD BE INTERPRETED AS OKAY WE
DID THIS SO.
THAT'S THE END OF THE
CONVERSATION AND THAT'S FAR FROM
THE END OF THE CONVERSATION SO.
I'M I'M CONCERNED I HAVE MIXED
FEELINGS FOR THAT -- BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY WE ALL TRY TO TAKE
STEPS FORWARD BUT NOT IF IT'S
GOING TO BE USED.
IN SUCH A WAY THAT WOULD HARM
HOW MUCH MORE PROGRESS WE CAN
MAKE.
THANK YOU VERY MCH WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
VERY MUCH I'M VERY PROUD -- TO
REPORT THAT JUST YESTERDAY -- MY
COMMITTEE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
OUR ENTERTAINMENT SPORTS TOURISM
AND MEDIA TECHNOLOGY.
JUST GOT THE OF SENATOR NANCY
SKINNER SPILL OF OUR COMMITTEE A
REGARDING TO THIS NC DOUBLE A
STUDENT ATHETIC AND THE RISK
THE STEP THE THE THE SCHOLARSHIP
WHEN STATUS.
SO -- WAR WAR WAR MOVING TO HAVE.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU SOME
REMEMBER DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
THANK YOU THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR PAM AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM THIRTEEN AB FIFTEEN
EIGHTEEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO JUDICIARY LEYVA AYE LEYVA AYE
WILK CHIANG LASSELL. TO WRESTLE
AYE GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN PAN AYE --
BELIEVE THAT BELONG CALL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
OUR MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
FILE ITEM FIFTEEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO.
AB.
SIXTEEN FORTY FIVE BEGIN
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'D THANK YOU FOR THE
TIME TO PRESENT AB SIXTEEN FORTY
FIVE TODAY THIS BILL WILL
DESIGNATE A DREAM RESOURCE
LIAISON AT CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES.
SINCE THE IMPLEMENTATION OF AB
FIVE FORTY THE CALIFORNIA DREAM
ACT AND OTHER MEANINGFUL PIECES
OF LEGISLATION AXES AND
AFFORDABILITY TO HIGHER HIGHER
EDUCATION IS NOW ATTAINABLE FOR
ARE UNDOCUMENTED STUDENT
POPULATION.
IT IS ESTIMATED EACH YEAR THAT
APPROXIMATELY SIXTY FIVE
THOUSAND UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS
GRADUATE FROM HIGH SCHOOLS AND
WHILE CALIFORNIA HAS TAKEN THE
LEAD TO ENACT LEGISLATION TO
PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
UNDOCUMENTED YOUTH.
ONLY 20% OF THE STUDENTS ATTEND
COLLEGE WE MUST DO MORE TO HELP
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES NAVIGATE THE HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEM.
ESPECIALLY SINCE THERE IS NO END
IN SIGHT FOR THE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATIONS CONSTANT THREATS
TO DOCTOR ARE.
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS CENTERS
AND STAFF PLAY A CRITICAL ROLE
AT OUR COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES --
AS IMMIGRANT IMMIGRATION
POLICIES RAPIDLY SHIFT -- AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL.
ESTABLISHING A PERMANENT AND
INSTITUTIONALIZED DREAM RESEARCH
THE AS A LIAISON ON CALIFORNIA
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES WILL
PROVIDE UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS
WITH ADEQUATE EDUCATIONAL
SUPPORT.
WITH ME TODAY I HAVE EVER HUMANE
AS A YOUTH ORGANIZER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM NETWORK TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
HELLO IT'S AN HONOR TO BE HERE
ARE PRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
JING NETWORK IT CONSISTS OF OVER
FORTY CAMPUSES.
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND I'VE BEEN VERY PRIVILEGED TO
MEET SOME OF THE STUDENTS WHO
ARE ACTIVISTS FURTHER DOCUMENTED
AND IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES.
AND I'VE ASKED THEM WAS URGING
LIAISON AGING CENTER WOULD MEAN
FOR THEM.
AND JUST FOR WHAT THEY'VE TOLD
ME IS BASICALLY IT'S A SAFE AND
INCLUSIVE SPACE FOR THEM -- IT'S
VERY OBVIOUS THAT DURING THIS%
TIME.
MANY OF US FEEL FEEL -- UNSAFE
AND SOMETIMES EVEN ATTACKED
DURING A WITHIN OUR CAMPUSES.
AND THIS IS A SAFE SPACE FOR FOR
STUDENTS IS A A PLACE WHERE THEY
CAN BE THEMSELVES OR THEY CN.
HAVE THE CONFIDENTIALITY AND THE
OPPORTUNITIES TO BE ABLE TO WORK
AMONGST THEMSELVES TO BE ABLE TO
GET THE RESOURCES THEY NEED.
AND THAT WAS ANOTHER POINT THEY
WANTED TO MAKE WAS THAT THERE
ARE SO MANY RESOURCES AVAILABLE
ON COLLEGE COLLEGE CAMPUSES.
BUT THE RESOURCES ARE SOMETIMES
VERY CENTERED AROUND A RESIDENCY
AND CITIZENSHIP FOR STUDENTS AND
A CENTER HAVING A DREAM MAYES ON
HAVING A DREAM CENTER WHAT ALLOW
STUDENTS TO BE ABLE.
TO GET ACCESS TO THESE RESOURCES
AND MANY OF THEM THEY DON'T
REALLY KNOW.
WHAT OPPORTUNITIES ARE THERE OUT
THERE FOR THEM ESPECIALLY DURING
THE TIMES THAT -- IMMIGRATION
DEBATES ARE HAVE THE SYSTEM VERY
IT FLUCTUATED WHERE WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON SOMETIMES.
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS IS THIS
BILL WOULD.
ALLOW STUDENTS TO TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE THAT SPACE AND THAT PERSON
THAT WILL DIRECT THEM TO THE
RIGHT RESOURCES THAT THEY NEED.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT TO
ONE OF OUR MEMBERS HER NAME IS
ABOVE IT NOT.
AND SHE ACTUALLY FOUGHT FOR A
DREAM CENTER AT HERS THE COLLEGE
IS YEAR OF COLLEGE.
AND MY MAIN CONCERN.
FOR I WE'RE REALLY PROUD OF THE
WORK SHE DID BUT I MAIN CONCERN
IS THAT STUDENTS SHOULD NOT HAVE
TO GO THROUGH ALL THESE
DIFFICULTIES TO BE ABLE.
TO GET THE RESOURCES AND THE
HELP THEY NEED IT SHOULD BE ABLE
TO BE THERE FOR THEM WHEN THEY
GO TO THEIR COLLEGE OR
UNIVERSITY.
AND AT THE REASON UC DAVIS
GRADUATE I'M VERY PROUD TO SAY
THAT YOU SEE DAVIS HAD THE FIRST
A BOUT FORTY AND DOCUMENTS
STUDENT CENTER.
SO THAT WAS REALLY HELPFUL AND
THAT'S HOW I MEAN WHAT TO STAND
HERE BEFORE YOU AS A FIRST
GENERATION DOCUMENTS STUDENT
GRADUATE.
THANK YOU.
EXCELLENT THANK YOU FOR SHARING
YOUR STORY NEXT WITNESS.
PRESS RESPONSE WHICH ARE THE
COLLEGE FOR ME TO MAYOR RIGHTS
PROBABLY A SPONSOR THIS MEASURE
HERE FOR ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
THE COMMITTEE MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT.
WHICH A TOYS WITH DEAD
CALIFORNIA G. MAC ABOUT SPONSOR
THE BILL. TO RESET REFORM METIS
IMMIGRANT STUDENT AT CSU
STANISLAUS AND ALSO PART OF THE
CD IN.
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL --
THE LASTED A CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY STANISLAUS IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. ZERO FACULTY MEMBER
SAN STATE IN VERY STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL WHICH IS A MUST
GARCIA -- DIMS MCFADDEN'S
STUDENTS DANCE LOST IN VERY
STRONG SUPPORTER THIS BILL. TO
BE THE BEST STUDENT MODESTO
JUNIOR COLLEGE VERY STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
MERRY WASHINGTON WITH THE CAL
STATE STUDENT ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
JAKE BREMNER ON BEHALF OF THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY
AS WELL AS OF THE CALIFORNIA
UNDOCUMENTED HIGHER EDUCATION
COALITION THAT WE'RE PROUD TO
FACILITATE AND WERE ALL IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK.
RENDON BIGGER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT A COMMISSION
IN SUPPORT.
I AM THE CONTACT US GRADUATE
STUDENT AT UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND ON
BEHALF THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATED
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
MANY RODRIGUEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
EDUCATION TRUST WESTERN SUPPORT.
NICK ROMAN HAVE THE WESTERN
ASSOCIATION FOR COLLEGE
ADMISSION COUNSELING AND SUPPORT.
ANDREA RIVER ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES AND SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE SENATOR TO
RAZA JONI QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR IN THE WITNESSES VERY
MUCH SHOT FOR PROPOSING THIS
SITE JUST A QUESTION.
I I NOTICED THAT -- THERE.
THE BILL REQUIRES THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE LEVEL IN THE CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY LEVEL BUT DOESN'T
REQUIRE.
ON THE UC CAMPUS.
LEVEL THAT IT'S MORE OF A
REQUEST.
IS THAT THE RIGHT INTERPRETATION
AND IF THAT'S TRUE COULD YOU
EXPLAIN WHY THAT'S CORRECT -- WE
TRIED THE BILL LAST YEAR IN THE
THE GOVERNOR VETOED IT AND SO
THIS THIS WAS THE COMPROMISED --
TO TRY AND GET A MOVE THE BILL
FORWARD.
CAN YOU EXPLAIN WHY.
THE UC IN PARTICULAR WITH ALL
ITS RESOURCES COULDN'T.
ARE THROUGH IT AND DO IT.
PLEASE PROCEED UNFORTUNATELY THE
LEGISLATURE CAT REQUIRE THE UC'S
TO DO ANYTHING SO IT THEY WOULD
HAVE TO REQUEST THE THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA TO TO
DO IT SO THE ARMED ISLAMIC
REQUEST OKAY.
IT'S CONSTITUTION BACK OKAY
THERE SOON RIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH VERY GOOD WHAT WERE KINDLY
ASKING FOR THANK YOU.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AT THANK YOU --
AS WELL NO DREAMERS HAVE -- MADE
CALIFORNIA BETTER WITH THEIR
COUNTLESS -- AND RELENTLESS
ADVOCACY EFFORTS THE STUDENTS
LIKE ME CAME TO THE UNITED
STATES FOR A BETTER OPPORTUNITY
AND IT'S OUR DUTY TO CREATE
POLICIES THAT WILL LEAD.
THEM TO A SUCCESSFUL FUTURE
NIGHT AS A FORMER SCHOOL TEACHER
I CAN TELL YOU THAT ALL THE
RESOURCES.
THAT CAN BE PROVIDED FOR
STUDENTS -- CAN MAKE THEM
SUCCESSFUL AND WE CAN HAVE MORE
STUDENTS US STARTING BEFORE AS
AS COUNT COLLEGE GRADUATES AND
WITH THAT I JUST RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THE BILL HAS
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR DORADO
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
I IN FIFTEEN EIGHTY SIXTEEN
FORTY FIVE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA AYE
LEYVA AYE WILK CHIANG WRESTLE.
WITH US SO I GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN.
THE BILL ON CALL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
CURRENT MEMBERS WE HAVE REACHED
OUR LAST A BILL OF THE DAILY
FILE ITEM NINETEEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAMOS IT IS A. B..
SEVENTEEN SIXTY SEVEN COME ON UP
AND PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IT
SENATORS.
AB SIXTEEN OR SEVENTEEN SIXTY
SEVEN EXPENSES SUICIDE
PREVENTION POLICIES THIS SCHOOL
DISTRICTS DEVELOP FOR CRAIG FOR
GRADES.
SEVEN THROUGH TWELVE TO INCLUDE
A POLICY ON YOUTH SUICIDE
PREVENTION FOR KATIE TO SIXTH
GRADE.
SUICIDES IN ALL PARTS OF OUR
SOCIETY IN ALL AGES RANGES THE
IN AN EPIDEMIC AND WHILE THE
ISSUE OF ADOLESCENT SUICIDE.
HAS RECEIVED FOCUS IN RESOURCES
IN RECENT YEARS.
RATES OF SELF HARM AND SUICIDE
AMONG THE YOUNGEST IN OUR
COMMUNITIES HAVE TRAGICALLY
INCREASED.
WHILE OTHER RESOURCE RESOURCES
SCHOOL DISTRICTS PROVIDE OUR
EXPANSIVE TO MOST AGE RANGES
SUICIDE PREVENTION POLICIES ARE
GREAT EXCLUSIVE.
ONLY TARGETED AT GRADES SEVEN
THROUGH.
TWELVE THESE GRADES EXCLUSIVELY
POLICIES CAN LEAVE BEHIND
STUDENTS WHOSE RISK OF SUICIDE
HAS RISEN IN RECENT YEARS.
ACROSS OUR STATE WE HAVE HEARD
FAR TOO MANY TRAGIC STORIES AND
HAVE SEEN FAR TOO MANY TRAGIC
USE SUICIDES.
IN ONE CASE IN MY DISTRICT A
STUDENT WHO TOOK THEIR OWN LIFE
WAS ONLY TEN YEARS OLD.
AND DURING THIS TIME.
THERE WAS A ABOUT SIX SUICIDE
THAT TOOK PLACE IN OUR DISTRICT
WITHIN THE LAST EIGHTEEN MONTHS.
THAT DRAWS ATTENTION TO THE MUCH
NEEDED A LEGISLATION THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE TODAY.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND SCHOOLS AND
EDUCATORS NEED TO BE PREPARED TO
IDENTIFY WARNING SIGNS IN
INTERVENE EARLY. TO SAVE LIVES.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT THESE ISSUES
ARE SENSITIVE.
THAT'S WHY THIS BILL WILL ENSURE
THAT THESE POLICIES ARE
SPECIFICALLY CREATED TO BE AGE
APPROPRIATE.
AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY SEVEN SIX TO
BUILD ON THE WORK OF LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES BY
EXPANDING SUICIDE PREVENTION
POLICIES. TO BEGIN TO ADDRESS
USE SUICIDE.
IN DOING SO WILL FOCUS LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES ATTENTION ON
ADDRESSING THE RISK OF USE
SUICIDE EARLY ON PREVENTING
FUTURE YOU SUICIDES WITHIN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER. FOR
THOSE -- IN SUPPORT.
NO ONE IN SUPPORT IS THERE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
WE WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS CENTER ALSO.
YES -- I WANNA THANK THE AUTHOR
VERY MUCH -- OUR OFFICE IS NEXT
TO AN ORGANIZATION COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATION THAT PROVIDES.
A MENTAL HEALTH AND COUNSELING
AND FOR YOUTH AND FOR SIMILAR
STORIES OR HAVE BEEN TOLD TO ME
ABOUT -- YOUTH AS YOUNG AS TEN
YEARS OLD.
EITHER ATTEMPTED SUICIDE YOU
KNOW ATTEMPTED SUICIDE SO -- I'M
REALLY GLAD THAT YOU'RE.
USING THIS BILL TO RAISE THE
CONSCIOUSNESS AROUND IT SO THAT
WE ALL CAN BE MUCH MORE.
AWARE -- AND HELPFUL AS MUCH AS
WE CAN NO CHILD OF NO.
ONE ESPECIALLY CHILDREN SHOULD
BE -- OUT THERE ON THEIR OWN
WITHOUT THE RESOURCES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO I'LL BE
GLAD TO MOVE MADAM CHAIR THANK
YOU CENTER DRIVE SO.
WHICH ARE TO CLOSE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
SENATORS IN THIS IS A VERY.
TOPIC THAT NEEDED IN OUR
COMMUNITIES TO START THE
DIALOGUE AROUND -- YOUTH
SUICIDES IN THE EARLY AGES THAT
IT'S HAPPENING -- SPECIFICALLY
HERE WITHIN THIS BILL TARGETING
BE MORE PROACTIVE AGAIN THOSE
ISSUES OUT THERE AHEAD OF TIME
THROUGH THE THE THIS K. THROUGH
SIXTH GRADE.
THESE ISSUES ARE MUCH NEEDED AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBERS THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
DRAWS -- MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
IN NINETEEN SEC AB SEVENTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE WILK CHANG.
CHANG I WOULD ASSUME -- NESTLE
AYE GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN.
LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH -- MEMBERS WE HAVE
REACHED THE END OF OUR AGEND
BUT WE DO NEED TO DO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR TO HAVE A MOTION THANK
YOU THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
REMOVED BY SENATOR DRAWS OF THE
ITEMS ON CONSENT.
OUR ITEM SIX AB TENS.
SEVENTY FIVE ITEM SEVEN A. B.
TEN EIGHTY FIVE ITEM EIGHT TEN
NINETY SEVEN ITEM.
NINE AB TWELVE FOURTEEN ITEM TEN
AB THIRTEEN NINETEEN ITEM
SEVENTEEN AB SEVENTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN CONSENT AS AMENDED WE HAVE
ONE ITEM ID.
FOURTEEN AB FIFTEEN NINETY FIVE
IF THERE'S NOTHING THAT ANYONE
WISHES TO REMOVE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
LEYVA BY LEYVA AYE WILK CHANGE
HI JANE I THE RUSSELL TO WRESTLE
AYE GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
A WE ARE GOING TO START LIFTING
THE CALL ON BILLS SO IF YOU HAVE
NOT BEEN HERE THE ENTIRE TIME
AND HAVE BILLS TO VOTE ON PLEASE
COME ON BACK TO SAID EDUCATION.
WELCOME CENTER CHANGE WE ARE
GOING TO LIFT THE CALLS ON I
THINK ALL THE BILLS FOR YOU SO
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE START.
ITEM ONE AB ONE THIRTY THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I'D BUY SHARED
HASN'T VOTED THREE ZERO WILK HI
WILK HI CHIANG.
CHANGE AYE MCGUIRE PAN.
ITEM TWO AB THREE TWENTY FOR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO HUMAN
SERVICES WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
VICE CHAIR VOTING I FIVE ZERO
CHANGE.
CHANGE I MCGUIRE.
ITEM THREE AB THREE THIRTY ONE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR HASN'T VOTED
TWO ZERO WILK [inaudible]
CHIANG.
I'M GLAZER MCGUIRE.
ITEM FOUR AB. TEN OH ONE THE
MOTION IS DO PASSES AMENDED TO
HUMAN SERVICES WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I'VE BY SURE HASN'T VOTED
THREE ZERO WILK HI WILK I CHANGE.
CHANGE I MCGUIRE PAN.
ITEM FIVE AB TEN FIFTY ONE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I
FOUR ZERO CHIANG.
CHANG I AM MCGUIRE PAN.
ITEM ELEVEN AB THIRTEEN FIFTY
FOUR THE MOTION IS DO YOU PASSED
THE PUBLIC SAFETY WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR HASN'T VOTED
THREE ZERO WILK HI WILK I CHIANG
HI CHIANG I AM GLAZER MCGUIRE.
ITEM TWELVE AB FOURTEEN SIXTY
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR HASN'T VOTED
TWO ZERO WILK.
CHAIN.
GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN.
ITEM THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIFTEEN
EIGHTEEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO JUDICIARY WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR HAS DEVOTED
THREE ZERO WILK.
WILK I CHIANG CHIANG AYE GLAZER
MCGUIRE
ITEM FIFTEEN A. B. SIXTEEN FORTY
FIVE THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR HASN'T VOTED
TWO ZERO WILK HI WILK I CHIANG.
GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN. FORTY FIVE
RUBIO.
AMPS EIGHT ITEM FIFTEEN SIXTEEN
FOR OKAY PAN I AN CHIANG.
GLAZER.
I AM.
FIFTEEN GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE.
I WAS ON A FIFTEEN IS REPEATING
ITSELF.
IN OUR PSYCHE.
ITEM EIGHTEEN AB SEVENTEEN
TWENTY NINE THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I VICE CHAIR
VOTING I'VE FOUR ZERO CHANGE.
CHANGE I AM MCGUIRE PAN.
PAN HI.
ITEM NINETEEN AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY
SEVEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR HASN'T VOTED
THREE ZERO WILK.
WILK AYE GLAZER GLAZER AYE
MCGUIRE PAN.
PAN AYE [inaudible]
WE HAVE.
WE WILL NOW DO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
CONSENT CALENDAR WITH THAT
YOU'RE VOTING AYE VICE CHAIR HAS
INCLUDED THREE ZERO WILK.
WILK I GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE PAN CAN I IS
START FROM THE TOP AND GO BACK
THROUGH ITEM.
ONE ITEM ONE AB ONE THIRTY THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
GOVERNMENTAL OR ORGANIZATION
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING II VICE
CHAIR VOTING I'VE FIVE ZERO
MCGUIRE PAN.
HI CAN I YES BUT ITEM THREE
EIGHTY THREE THREE ONE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR NOT VOTING
TWO ZERO WILK.
CHIANG [inaudible]
GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN PAN AYE.
ITEM FOR AB TEN OH ONE THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
HUMAN SERVICES WITH THE CHAIR OF
THE VOTING I ADVISED HER VOTING
AYE. FIVE ZERO MCGUIRE PAN
[inaudible]
CAN I ITEM FIVE AB TEN FIFTY ONE
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS AT THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I
FIVE ZERO MCGUIRE PAN.
PAN AYE.
ITEM ELEVEN AB THIRTEEN FIFTY
FOUR THE MOTION IS DO YOU PASSED
TO PUBLIC SAFETY WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I'VE VICE CHAIR VOTING
I'D FIVE ZERO GLAZER.
PLEASE ARE AYE MCGUIRE.
ITEM TWELVE AB FOURTEEN SIXTY
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I BY SURE HASN'T VOTED
TWO ZERO WILK [inaudible]
CHANGE [inaudible]
GLAZER.
MCGUIRE PAN.
ITEM THIRTEEN A. B. FIFTEEN
EIGHTEEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO JUDICIARY WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I
FIVE ZERO GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE.
ITEM FIFTEEN AB SIXTEEN FORTY
FIVE THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I BY ST REDDING HI FIVE
ZERO CHIANG [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
PAN.
THE CONCERT CANNERY BUT I CAN
SAY.
ITEM EIGHTEEN AB SEVENTEEN
TWENTY NINE THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED YOU APPROPRIATIONS AT THE
CHAIR VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING
AYE SIX ZERO MCGUIRE
[inaudible]
OKAY
A WIRE.
WE ARE GOING TO START -- AT THE
TOP.
FILE ITEM.
ONE ALL RIGHT MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THE OPEN
ITEMS ITEM ONE AB ONE THIRTY THE
MOTION IS DO YOU PASSED TO
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I VICE CHAIR
VOTING I SIX ZERO MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE HI.
THE BILL IS OUT
.
SEVEN ZERO ITEM TWO EIGHTY THREE
TWENTY FOR THE MOTION IS DO YOU
PASSED TO HUMAN SERVICES WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I VICE CHAIR
VOTING I SIX ZERO MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE SEVEN ZERO THAT
BILLS OUT.
ITEM THREE A. B. THREE THREE ONE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR NOT VOTING
THREE ZERO WILK CHIANG GLAZER
MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE HI FOUR ZERO THAT BILL
IS OUT.
ITEM FOUR AB TEN ZERO ONE THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
HUMAN SERVICES WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I SIX
ZERO MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE SEVEN ZERO THAT BILLS
OUT.
ITEM FIVE AB TEN FIFTY ONE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I BY SURE VOTING I SIX
ZERO MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE SEVEN ZERO THAT
BILLS OUT.
ITEM SIX A. B. TEN SEVEN FIVE
THE MOTION IS. ONE SORRY CONSENT
[inaudible]
ITEM.
ELEVEN AB THIRTEEN FIFTY FOR THE
MOTION IS DO YOU PASSED TO
PUBLIC SAFETY WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I ADVISED HER VOTING I
SIX ZERO MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE NINE SEVEN ZERO THAT
BILL IS OUT.
ITEM TWELVE AB FOURTEEN SIXTY
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR NOT VOTING
TWO ZERO WILK CHIANG GLAZER
MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE I CAN.
THE BILL DOES NOT HAVE ENOUGH
VOTES TO GET OUT IT HAS FAILED
BUT WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL
GRANT RECONSIDERATION.
ITEM THIRTEEN A. B. FIFTEEN
EIGHTEEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO JUDICIARY WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I ADVISED HER VOTING I'D
SIX ZERO MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE. SEVEN ZERO THAT
BILLS OUT.
I AM FIFTEEN AB SIXTEEN FORTY
FIVE THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I AM VICE CHAIR VOTING I
FIVE ZERO CHANGE.
MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE SIX ZERO THE
BILL IS OUT.
ITEM EIGHTEEN AB SEVENTEEN
TWENTY NINE THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I'VE I SURE
VOTING I EIGHT SIX ZERO MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE SEVEN ZERO THAT BILL
IS OUT.
ITEM NINETEEN AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY
SEVEN THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I SIX
ZERO MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE SEVEN ZERO THAT BILL
IS ALSO OUT THANK YOU SOONER
MCGUIRE WE JUST NEED TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AND CONSENT
CALENDAR WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
VICE CHAIR VOTING I SIX ZERO
MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE SEVEN ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS CONFIRMED AS
WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU EVERYONE OF THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
IS ADJOURNED